okay perfect
um so I'll be presenting the overview
report titled federal government
entities involved any decision to invoke
the emergencies Act
this overview report is now available to
the parties on the party database and
will be posted on the commission's
website for the public very shortly the
document ID for this report is
com.or708.
next slide please
so by way of introduction this
presentation focuses on the mandates of
three key Federal entities that is the
Federal Executive the Prime Minister
cabinet and the governor and Council the
privy Council Office and the prime
minister's office
of course there were many other
departments and agencies implicated in
the decision to declare a public order
emergency and the commission will hear
from evidence we'll hear evidence from
these Witnesses in the coming two weeks
the purpose of this overview report is
to contextualize and frame the
anticipated evidence for the benefit of
the parties the public and of course the
commissioner
next slide please
so we'll begin with the definition
section 17 1 of the emergencies act
assigns the formal authority to declare
the existence of a public order
emergency to the governor in Council
the term governor and Council refers to
the governor general of Canada acting on
the advice of the king's privy Council
for Canada
the king's pervy Council in turn is a
technical term that describes the full
group of people who have the authority
to advise The Sovereign or the governor
general acting as the representatives of
this sovereign
in Practical terms however references to
the king's privy Council are references
to the federal cabinet the federal
cabinet is a committee of the privy
Council and is effectively its only
operative branch
and by a constitutional convention the
governor general is required to follow
the advice given by cabinet this is of
course a fundamental part of our system
of responsible government
next slide please
so here we have an organizational chart
depicting the structure of the Federal
Executive Branch you'll see that while
the formal authority to govern is vested
in the governor general the that
Authority is exercised on the advice of
the Prime Minister and cabinet
in turn prime minister and cabinet are
supported by two Central offices the
privy Council Office and the prime
minister's office
so to put it into context the four
orders and Council that were issued by
the governor and Council in the context
of the public order emergency were
issued on the advice of the Prime
Minister and cabinet
next slide thanks
the federal cabinet is a political
decision-making body that consists of
all federal ministers as well as the
Prime Minister the cabinet is sometimes
referred to as the Federal Ministry
cabinet is the Forum wherein the
government of the day sets its
priorities and decides how to advance
these priorities
the Prime Minister sets the agenda and
will lead ministers to agreement in
making cabinet decisions but the final
and ultimate decision-making Authority
rests with the prime minister
cabinet members are governed by two
related conventions cabinet solidarity
and cabinet confidentiality
cabinet solidarity requires that
ministers as a group be held accountable
to Parliament for their government's
actions
cabinet confidentiality requires that
ministers not disclose the substance of
their cabinet discussions to the public
the two principles are of course
intertwined because cabinet
confidentiality allows ministers to
frankly and vigorously discuss their
views with their colleagues in private
while remaining United in their
decisions to the public
ministers are also individually
responsible for the federal departments
they oversee the powers and duties and
respect of their departments are set out
in their departmental statutes
in practice however the day-to-day
operations of the federal department or
agency are carried out by the deputy
Minister and civil servants
a deputy minister is the senior most
member of the professional nonpartisan
public service
finally every minister is supported by a
ministerial office consisting of a
political staff in carrying out their
duties as members of parliament
political staff are sometimes referred
to as exempt staff because they are not
bound by the strict impartiality rules
that apply to the public service and are
instead temporary political appointees
so there's a clear separation between
political staff and the public service
the public servants who work within
Federal departments in that political
staff do not have the authority to give
direction or instruction to public
servants
next slide please
so here we have another organizational
chart that depicts the work of cabinet
and cabinet committees the work of the
government is also carried out by
several cabinet committees the protests
and the government's response to the
protests were discussed by two cabinet
committees in particular the first was
the cabinet committee on safety security
and emergencies or SSE which was chaired
by the minister of emergency
preparedness
the SSC met on February 3rd 6th and 8th
the second cabinet committee was the
incident Response Group or IRG
the IRG took over the management of the
issue after February 8th and was chaired
by the minis the Prime Minister and
therefore had decision-making Authority
the IRG met on February 10 12th and 13th
and then daily thereafter between
February 16th and February 23rd
I will also add that there were two full
cabinet meetings at which the protests
and the invocation of the emergencies
Act was discussed these meetings took
place on February 3rd and February 15th
turning now to the prime minister's
office the pmo is a central political
agency supporting the prime minister in
his three roles as the head of
government the leader of a political
party and a member of Parliament
pmo's staff advised the Prime Minister
on policy issues Communications and
parliamentary Affairs and pmo is led by
a chief of staff who reports directly to
the Prime Minister and is also appointed
by the Prime Minister like the staff at
ministerial offices all staff at the pmo
are exempt staff in that they are
temporary political appointees
the pmo operates as a critical link
between the partisan interests and
agenda of the Prime Minister and the
general workings of government
for instance pmo maintains close
relationships with political staff at
ministers offices as well as with
officials at the privy Council Office
and pmo officials often attend cabinet
meetings
the privy Council Office or PCO is the
central coordinate coordinating agency
within the federal government and in
contrast to pmo the PCO provides
non-partisan advice to the Prime
Minister and cabinet and ensures that
the government's agenda is implemented
across all federal departments and
agencies and for this reason PCO is
sometimes referred to as the prime
minister's Department
PCO is led by the clerk of the privy
Council the clerk holds the additional
titles of the Deputy minister to the
Prime Minister the secretary to cabinet
and the head of the public service
and as the secretary to Cabinet the
clerk is responsible for the smooth
operation of cabinet business including
the preparation of cabinet memoranda and
the keeping of cabinet confidences
in addition to its primary role as the
central coordinating agency PCO also
serves as the department for some
ministers this includes the minister of
intergovernmental Affairs who is
supported by the intergovernmental
Affairs Secretariat as well as the
minister of emergency preparedness who
is supported by the emergency
preparedness in covid-19 recovery
Secretariat
another important PCO actor is the
national security and intelligence
advisor or the nsia the nsia holds the
title of deputy secretary to cabinet and
provides National Security advice and
intelligence briefings
to the Prime Minister as well as to
cabinet
the office of the nsia plays a
coordinating and convening function
amongst national security agencies and
the office of the nsia itself consists
of four secretariats and it is
responsible for convening two standing
committees of senior civil servants
the nsia also acts as the secretary to
the incident Response Group
so this chart depicts the relationship
between the privy Council Office Federal
departments and agencies and the various
secretariats within PCO
it should be noted that there is no
legislation governing the role of the
NSA or PCO as these entities are meant
to play only in advisory secretarial and
coordination function to cabinet
the nsia chairs the deputy Minister's
operations and Coordination Committee or
dmoc and the assistant secretary to
Cabinet security and intelligence
co-chairs the assistant Deputy ministers
committee on National Security and
operations or ADM NS Ops
both the admns Ops and dmoc met
frequently in fact almost daily in late
January and throughout February 2022 to
discuss the government's response to the
protests
finally the Departments and agencies
listed on this slide were also involved
in the federal government's response to
the protests and blockades and the
decision to invoke the emergencies act
and as I mentioned earlier Witnesses
from each of these departments are
expected to testify in the coming weeks
and I would invite the parties to
consult the institutional reports
prepared by each department for a fuller
explanation of the Department's mandate
and involvement
foreign
so that concludes the presentation on
this overview report but before I go I
would also like to enter three
additional overview reports prepared by
commission Council and that I understand
the parties have had the chance to
review
first commission counselor entering a
room can you slow down for the
interpreters please yes
um commission Council are entering a
report summarizing the proceedings
commenced in response to the protests in
January and February 2022 including
judicial review proceedings commenced to
challenge the invocation of the
emergencies Act
the document ID for this report is
com.or701
the second report that commission
Council are entering is a report
summarizing the protests that occurred
at six International ports of entry in
January and February 2022 the document
ID for this report is com.or706.
and the final overview report that
commission counselor entering is a
report summarizing the oversight
responsibilities of Parliament and the
Parliamentary Review Committee under the
emergencies act the document ID for this
report is com.or707.
uh and with that that concludes my
comments thank you
thank you
[Music]
and uh the parties will find that
document the overview report useful for
determining
who they should be questioning as we go
through the various departments because
for obvious reasons the amount of time
for cross-examination is is limited for
each of the parties so you should be as
much as possible targeting the
the Departments and Witnesses who are
likely to have the answers to the
questions you may pose so with that
brief introduction we'll call on the
next witness I think it's a panel as I
understand it
thank you Mr commissioner my name is
shantona shodary co-lead commission
Council I'd like to call Mr Rob Stewart
and Mr Dominique to the stand
foreign
Mr Stewart will you swear on a religious
document or do you wish to affirm a firm
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Robert neela Fleck
Stewart
spell it yes please r-o-b-e-r-t
-n-e-i-l-a-f-f-l-e-c-k-s-t-e-w-a-r-t
do you solemnly affirm that the evidence
to be given by you to this commission
shall be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth I do thank you Mr
Rashon will you swear on a religious
document or do you wish to affirm I will
affirm
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Dominic James
Roshon d-o-m-i-n-i-c
r-o-c-h-o-n
do you solemnly affirm that the evidence
to be given by you to this commission
shall be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth I do thank you
go ahead good morning Mr Stewart good
morning Mr hashel nice to see you again
um I'll just start by introducing your
witness summary so you'll recall sitting
for an interview with commission Council
on September 1st 2022.
thank you Mr clerk I'll ask you to pull
up
wts.0000 I think it's five zero sixty
six
okay so Mr Stewart Mr Hashanah you'll
recall that some of your colleagues were
not with us today uh were not called to
testify also sat for That interview
namely Mr talal dakalba I'm not sure I'm
pronouncing that right pardon me Taco
Bell thank you and Mr Derek treehern
also participated in that interview
I'll just ask you to confirm that you've
reviewed the summary of the interview
and if you have no changes to make
confirm that insofar as contains your
information you've adopted and insofar
and it's accurate to the best of your
knowledge and belief insofar as it
contains the information of your
colleagues
and you believe them to have accepted it
as accurate
I accept it I believe it's accurate
thank you
um Mr Stewart at the time of the freedom
Convoy events in January and February
you were the deputy minister of Public
Safety is that correct that is correct
okay and you've since moved on to become
the deputy minister of international
trade that is correct and when was that
just recently 17th of October 17th of
October okay
uh Mr Roshan at the time of the events
uh you were the senior assistant Deputy
minister of public safety's National and
cyber security branch is that right
that's correct and you've also since
last Public Safety to to take another
position
is that correct that is correct okay
associate Deputy minister of Transport
correct and when was that October 31st
was my first day okay so also very
recent
um the next thing I'll just ask you to
introduce state public safety's
institutional report despite the fact
that neither of you are currently with
Public Safety Mr clerk that's
d-o-j-i-r-608
okay so Mr Stewart you'll recall that
Public Safety Canada uh prepared and
filed with the commission this
institutional report have you reviewed
it I have okay and is it accurate to the
best of your knowledge and belief yes
okay and can you confirm that it's been
filed with the commission as part of
public safety's evidence I believe it
has thank you
okay with those introductions out of the
way
um I'll just ask you to start by giving
an overview of the structure of Public
Safety it's slightly complicated uh
Department it's as we know the public
the Department of Public Safety and
emergency preparedness so Mr can you
walk us through Public Safety writ large
by all means Public Safety is a
relatively small Department that covers
all matters associated with the security
of Canada it has three main branches
which deal with national and cyber
security that's one branch crime
prevention that's another an emergency
management that's the third
um it has other branches which do more
coordinating or corporate work
okay but the three that you that you
mentioned are the ones that were most
implicated in the in the events of the
Convoy is that right those are the
policy branches okay
um and Mr social I I understand that the
national and cyber security Branch
manages five directors can you tell us
about that and if you'd like to have the
reference for your for your notes it's
uh dojir at page eight paragraphs 25 and
26 so we can just pull that up
if you could just move up the page just
slightly but I can speak to them yes so
the uh the national cyber security
branch has five divisions primarily it
is responsible for national security
policy matters National Security
operations matters
uh critical infrastructure
cyber security and over the last three
years uh there was a special task force
regarding Economic Security
okay and if we can just scroll down a
little bit Mr Clerk
under critical infrastructure and
strategic coordination it says this
directorate supports the ministers in
leading the national effort to enhance
the resilience of critical
infrastructure against a variety of
Hazards do those hazards include protest
they could uh essentially that
particular directorate oversees the
critical infrastructure strategy that
has been in place since 2010 we have
been uh over the last couple of years in
the midst of refreshing that strategy
we uh that particular directorate
engages with the 10 critical
infrastructure sectors there are uh
private sector leads and public sector
leads for each of those sectors and they
deal with matters of we provide risk
assessments when there are threats they
could be cyber related threats but any
threats to any critical infrastructure
across those 10 critical infrastructure
sectors okay
um and then the the next not bullet
there but the next line in the chart the
task force on economic security tell us
a little bit about the work of of that
task force and whether or not it played
into the Convoy at all
it did not that task force was stood up
over the last three years as I pointed
out in order to look at a the broader
framework that is uh Economic Security
Economic Security is a term that could
mean a lot of things from a national
security perspective that task force was
looking into through various lenses
potential threats to uh
Canada's economy stemming from threat
actors potentially hostile State actors
those threats can emanate from uh and
and indeed we we have a elaborate uh
control system across Canada we have
export controls we have the investment
Canada Act we have a series of tools but
the economic security task force was
looking at whether or not those tools
were fit to purpose and indeed whether
that tool set was adequate in order to
protect ourselves against uh the threats
of today and so uh most of that work
looked at uh and and is is moving
towards an economic security strategy
that would introduce research security
to protect
um intellectual property for example
things of that nature so specifically
that task force did not have a role to
play uh with regard to
um the uh the these this particular
situation
okay
um now getting to your your own
individual roles and responsibilities Mr
Stewart
can you tell us first of all a little
bit about your general role as a deputy
minister of Public Safety and and then
describe at a very high level uh Your
Role with respect to the events of the
Convoy by all means I um as a deputy I'm
responsible for the administration of
the department
and providing policy advice to the
minister on matters associated with
Public Safety uh and overseeing program
delivery
um the department runs a number of uh
contribution programs that provide
funding for various activities
and I also work with the deputy heads of
organizations that are in the portfolio
and by the portfolio I mean these are
organizations who are responsible to the
minister in the public safety portfolio
there are five main organizations RCMP
cbsa
Canadian border Service Agency Canadian
Security intelligence service the
correctional service of Canada
and the parole board thank you
um and uh they all are independently
accountable to the minister but we work
together as a group and provide advice
and if necessary the department will do
legislation or regulation on their
behalf
okay I'm sorry going in the context of
the protests I was working with a subset
of that group
uh who are involved in daily calls and
briefings that would be the RCMP and
cbsa primarily
and to a degree thesis I think we're
going to hear a lot more about that
shortly and thank you for speaking
without acronyms that's appreciated on
the first day of federal government
evidence we're still getting used to all
the acronyms I think thesis we can
handle and probably cbsa but when it
gets deeper than that it's going to be a
struggle
um okay Mr Rochelle
can you tell us at a high level first of
all your role at the time and your role
in the Convoy
I would describe my role specifically
having gone through the five uh
directorates in my branch
the one director in particular the
national
um security operations directorate
uh through that directorate I have a
responsibility and I'll refer to the
presentation that was it was given to us
this morning where we highlighted the
privy Council Office and and its role
um with the privy Council Office they
have a security and intelligence
Secretariat
the assistant secretary responsible for
that Secretariat and I have a
responsibility of convening the security
and intelligence Community which is some
16 departments and agencies on a regular
basis to discuss ongoing operational
National Security matters for
situational awareness and indeed to be
able to make sure that we're
coordinating the community to be able to
respond to potential threats to National
Security
so that particular committee is called
the assistant Deputy minister
National Security
uh operations committee admns Ops if you
don't mind me that acronym I'll probably
refer to that a lot so admns Ops meets
every week once a week
during the Convoy uh situation I would
say that uh the regular meeting on
Tuesday January 25th we discussed the
Convoy but after that date we decided to
have adoc meetings so everyday daily
meetings of that committee uh pretty
much throughout uh throughout the rest
of the um the operational situation if I
could put it that way so I guess my role
uh primarily was to convene uh along
with my PCO colleague the private
Council Office colleague all the various
representatives of these departments and
agencies in the security and
intelligence community and I'm happy to
to walk you through who they might be
but we would get together and discuss
whether or not uh this issue was a was
an issue of National Security and
whether or not it could lead to threats
to National Security okay I certainly do
want you to elaborate on that
um first of all who was your PCO
colleague who Mike McDonald is the
assistant uh secretary to the
Secretariat for security and
intelligence
okay well uh you've anticipated
essentially my next question because the
the first sort of broad topic that I
think we're going to cover here is uh
public safety's preparation for the
Convoy and that feeds into Mr Rochelle
what you were telling us about uh public
safety's intelligence rules so at this
point I'll ask you to yes please explain
that and explain how it was uh how it
fed into public safety's preparation
so I'll start by explaining that
intelligence uh
with regard to the federal family you
have collectors of intelligence you have
assessors of intelligence and you have
consumers of intelligence Public Safety
department is a consumer we don't per se
collect intelligence and we don't assess
intelligence we consume it why does one
consume intelligence in order to be able
to be better informed so so that
decisions uh so that decisions can be
made and those decisions uh
are made across all departments and
agencies
um
the key collectors of intelligence
thesis the communication security
establishment
cbsa to a certain extent what they
collect and what they see at the border
RCMP but indeed beyond the federal
family there's also collection of
intelligence that occurs within police
of jurisdiction which I'm sure you would
have heard about at the municipal level
at the provincial level Etc
intelligence uh is uh can be very broad
it's not an exact science and really
only provides a piece of information at
a moment in time
the federal family also has assessors of
that intelligence which means they pull
different threads of intelligence
together in order to be able to fuse it
and provide a more holistic picture to
again better inform potential decisions
related to National Security matters
assessors
are the integrated
uh terrorism Assessment Center itac
you have the privy Council Office also
has a Secretariat the intelligence uh
assessment Secretariat
but to a certain extent cecis uh the
communication security establishment
performed their own uh assessments and
are able to provide reports as does the
RCMP
when we convene uh the ADM NS Ops group
typically we will use different pieces
of intelligence in order to be able to
inform us on various uh issues that are
happening all over the world that could
lead to or are posing a threat to
National Security
so throughout the um
the particular situation with the Convoy
I would say that there was some
intelligence that was uh likely being
pulled together at a police of
jurisdiction level that isn't something
that would make its way to our federal
Family Table uh as a matter of course
the RCMP sits at that table and would
bring any information that they would
learn as they're stitched up with
different police of jurisdiction across
the country they would bring that
information to the table if there was
something relevant that needed to be
flagged but there is a distinction
between something rising to
a national security level and something
that is a police matter that they might
be dealing with uh throughout uh
throughout the country
okay um and in your interview we're
going to go back to some of that as we
go along but you explained that prior to
the convoys arrival this is taking you
up on your last point ncsb so the
national cyber security Branch wasn't
Gathering or disseminating intelligence
about the Convoy uh because at that
point there was no indication that the
offense would be a national security
threat so can you explain and elaborate
on that a little bit uh what that
threshold is and when if at all ncsb did
start doing that and why
so again our Branch does not collect
intelligence we're consumers of it so
um we would be receiving that
intelligence from different parties be
it csis or be it the RCMP in the federal
family context
um
the government operations center is
another uh another element of Public
Safety they fall under the Emergency
Management Branch they don't fall under
my Branch
nevertheless the uh the government
operations center otherwise known as the
gawk does have a role to play with
regard to any potential emergency in
terms of pulling together information
and disseminating that information about
a potential emergency there are 24 7 op
Center at Public Safety
so uh the reason I mentioned them is uh
obviously if there is a potential
protest or for example on Canada Day
when there are Provisions that need to
be made in terms of securing a
particular area or
um if there's a Potential Threat that
may be arising the government operations
center uh does start collecting open
source information and sharing that
information across the Federal Security
and intelligence community in order for
there to be situational awareness about
a potential for
um social disruption or uh uh some
something that that may be of concern
so uh I would say the the GOC was aware
and within Public Safety would have been
the first entity that would have started
collecting information I think that uh
the weekend before the uh the Convoy
decided uh to make its way to uh to
Ottawa they would have started
collecting some information and
disseminating it
um following that uh Transport Canada
obviously given their mandate would have
started having concerns about uh slow
roles and disruptions to traffic and the
member of Transport Canada that is
um a member of the adms Ops Uh Kevin
brosso would have uh would have called
both Mike McDonald and I to say that he
wanted to make sure that the issue was
brought to the attention of the ADM and
Sops committee because it did have the
potential of rising to a national
security
level given the the fact that this was
happening across Canada okay and when
you say he would have called you mean he
did he did commentary habit okay yes
um and so I I understand that gox
started monitoring this as you said
around January 19 and started producing
two types of reports one is called key
points on potential impacts to critical
infrastructure and the other is daily
operations briefs so these were being
produced as of around uh January 25th
January 28th is there a difference a
marked or noticeable difference between
those types of reports no no okay and
there who receives those reports who are
they disseminated to
um I can't say for sure what the broad
distribution list is but it's pretty
much
um uh uh Federal provincial and and then
the key points would have been going to
a selected group of deputies and Senior
public servants
and I appreciate that it's it's your
colleague Mr trahern who is in charge of
the GOC so he's the person with the best
knowledge on this but um if you'd like I
I could just clarify a point here
um
uh because my colleague has talked about
the intelligence side of the um
operation the GOC does not uh consume
intelligence or report it all it does is
uh bring together open source
information and operational information
that it obtains from various parties um
and in the event of a protest or an
event in Ottawa that requires
coordination with police forces it will
sit in on that and it'll report that
information but none of that is
considered to be intelligence and
therefore classified so maybe you can
help us hear a little bit understand
that this move sorry the distinction
between information and intelligence
who wants to tackle that one
um well I'll go first and Dominic can
follow uh information is is anything
that you can obtain uh via open source
um and uh is is not by its nature
classified
um to a uh any degree
um I suppose you could uh you know
quibble about that but as a general
matter and to the point that I was
making it really isn't it needed to be
protected in any way whereas
intelligence which is classified at
various levels needs to be guarded and
protected and it you know represents a
threat to the security of Canada if it's
um
disclosed
I would just elaborate that um there are
different forms of intelligence you have
human source so human human intelligence
that you get from Human sources you have
signals intelligence so there are a
whole series of different types of
intelligence that can be collected and
different departments and agencies can
collect that intelligence under their
respective mandates so they can only
collect that information provided that
it follows uh the the various
legislation that underpins uh their
existence
okay
um and appreciating that Public Safety
is a consumer neither a collector nor a
gatherer of intelligence and the fact
that we're going to be hearing from both
thesis and itac uh next week
I won't spend too much more time on this
but there's one thing I did want to
raise with you
um Mr clerk could you please pull up uh
trn50s 11.
so uh this is uh an excerpt from a
transcript of commissioner karik's
evidence uh from a couple of weeks ago
uh I'll set the context for you and then
I'll I'll ask you to
uh maybe elaborate a bit on what he was
discussing so
the reference is Page 90. we can just
pull that up
so the context here is
um commissioner karik was being
questioned by my my colleague Mr puso uh
about a reference and an opp Hendon
report and I'll just stop there
um
in the interview with the commission's
heard quite a bit of evidence about
project tendon and OPP's Hendon reports
and uh in the interview that we we had
in September you told us that neither of
you had heard of project Hendon at the
time specifically and that the the
project engine reports hadn't been fed
up to you
um and I take it that that goes to your
point of provincial and law enforcement
intelligence would likely not be
directly fed up to you but I'm wondering
if you can or if it did it would be
through the RCMP but I'm wondering if
you could just explain elaborate on that
a little bit
I I certainly can
um
I would say and and you'll have the
opportunity I assume to speak with the
RCMP and with thesis uh as you have with
uh
police of jurisdiction whether it be
provincial or Municipal uh every at
every level I would assume and I believe
is is the case there are uh intelligence
bodies that pull together uh
Intelligence on a on a wide variety of
of issues and if there's a particular
incident that is occurring they will
pull together a particular operation and
start collecting information
intelligence about that particular issue
so I'm assuming here in this case that
uh the Ontario Provincial Police will
have started would have started uh
operation Hendon now
uh police of jurisdiction will get
together and lieze with the RCMP so I
would be uh I'm quite certain that the
RCMP would have been privy to anything
coming out of project tendon as they
would have been privy to anything coming
out of the Ottawa Police Service and
other police of jurisdiction across
Ontario or indeed across Canada and uh
for the purposes of our national
security committee that looks at
operational situations the RCMP would be
feeding us any relevant information but
they would not be referring to an
operation Hendon or an operation
whatever the the various operations they
wouldn't tell us where the information
would be coming from specifically they
would simply be flagging anything that
would be of interest for the table
okay so if I can just summarize that if
the RCMP was privy to anything from
Project tendon that was relevant you
would expect to have knowledge of that
through them yes okay
um thank you that's helpful so just
getting back to this little transcript
excerpt here so commissioner Creek is
being asked about a reference in an obb
engine report to a Potential Threat to
Canada's sovereignty and National
Security that's around line 19 I believe
um and if we can just scroll down now to
the next page page 91
97
91.
oh sorry yes no problem okay so I'm just
going to read through the the first few
paragraphs here uh commissioner karik
says what is required is further
analysis of that threat Hendon did have
those conversations with the appropriate
security Partners to see if that
Potential Threat Rose to the point that
would warrant them enacting their
mandates for the items they're
responsible for and as we know slow down
in the thesis act it says threat to the
secure or it says the security of Canada
it doesn't actually say National
Security
Public Safety Canada goes to a much
broader context when describing National
Security
and one of the items in National
Security if you look at the National
Security strategy and how it's described
by Public Safety Canada actually
includes impact to economy activities
critical infrastructures international
border crossings
so Mr Rochelle or Mr Stewart whoever's
best place to answer this can you
explain and elaborate a little bit on on
what commissioner Creek is referring to
here Public Safety Canada's national
security Strat strategy and definition
I'll give it a go
um
to be honest the National Security uh
strategy uh dates back to 2004 and there
are several academic institutions as of
late that have uh recommended that the
government of Canada
um come out with a more
um
a newer version or at least refresh that
strategy
uh I'll start by by explaining what was
meant in terms of uh thesis and whether
or not the threshold was met with regard
to their act
uh what that what I think uh
commissioner Creek was was referring to
was the fact that as I was mentioning
earlier cesus has the ability to collect
intelligence but they can only collect
intelligence if certain thresholds have
been met
ceases are only uh but one of a number
of uh inputs into the National Security
landscape and uh so they do have targets
whether it be uh and I'll use a term
here that I'm sure is is going to come
up
um or probably already has come up that
will come up fairly frequently that of
ideologically motivated violent
extremism
uh
Public Safety also has a
counter-terrorism strategy we have a
cyber security strategy we're developing
an economic security strategy as I
mentioned earlier we're looking to uh
create a hostile activities of State
actors framework to deal with foreign
interference so
the reason why we don't have a perhaps
an up-to-date National Security strategy
is because National Security Now
permeates
uh a whole host of things all walks of
life in terms of uh of Canadian society
and I won't even get into uh threats uh
posed by climate change uh indeed the
pandemic itself the the public health
um situation
unfortunately there is no as far as I
know no definition in legislation of
National Security
uh cesus does uh have a definition of
threats to the security of Canada I
believe the security of Canada's
um information disclosure acts Gita also
speaks to a definition of threats to the
security of Canada
we have review bodies for the security
and intelligence Community
um the National Security and
intelligence review agency the National
Security and intelligence Committee of
parliamentarians and Sierra and NSI cop
they have gone to Great pains to sort of
Define what their purview is in terms of
National Security and indeed it covers
as I mentioned earlier some 16
departments and agencies so
when it comes to National Security
we're not necessarily looking at one
specific one specific threat a terrorism
threat but rather the impact on
Canada's ability to maintain uh the
security of its institutions its
democracy its uh people its economy the
resilience of all of these things
okay so from public safety's perspective
then or it's in its modus operandi
there's a distinction between National
Security and threat to the security of
Canada as defined in the thesis Act is
that fair yes absolutely okay
okay
um
moving on from there
um
I just want to situate Us in time here
with the information the public safety
was receiving prior to the arrival of
the convoys so the information it was
receiving from its various sources and
Mr clerk I'll just ask you to pull up at
this point PB can
50703 this is the GOC key points from
January 27th uh but as that's that's
being pulled up feel free to already
start and in describing what your state
of knowledge was at that point and what
you anticipated happening
when the Convoy arrived
uh so
um
maybe I'll back up just one step to of
course for that is just to say that we
were monitoring as you noted earlier uh
the rising level of um of of protest
around the vaccine mandate which came
into force on the 15th of January so we
were through uh various groups
monitoring
um just that there were protests that
were likely to arise and we started
getting word of uh the convoys formation
on around January 20th
and were through the gawk uh and its
connection to
um uh planning and coordination groups
and one in particular called intersect
which is a a group that brings together
all the police of the region
um and various other uh entities that
have an interest in the security of the
national capital
um that would have been meeting and
talking about that and we were hearing
reports and we were and then they would
be reflected in these key points those
those discussions so this would have
been uh January 27th is on the uh Eve of
the arrival of the early uh in Ottawa of
the trucks
um uh and
um I believe just prior to the blockade
at Coots but the so we were growing uh
paying a lot of attention to it getting
somewhat concerned about how it would
manifest how many trucks and from where
and there were many uh there were many
convoys coming from east and west uh and
I believe South um and so we were trying
to get a handle on that and the RCMP
were informing us about uh the numbers
of trucks and when they were likely to
arrive and we were asking questions
about what is the plan for you know
managing this protest when it manifests
okay thank you um Mr Clark if we can
just scroll up I guess or down sorry
keep scrolling keep scrolling keep
scrolling so as you've mentioned convoys
coming from several directions keep
scrolling
Mr sir I think you covered most of this
in your in your introduction uh keep
scrolling
okay stop around there so we see Ottawa
Police are planning for around a
thousand to two thousand vehicles uh the
Convoy is going to be directed to Sir
Sir John A if he's the second to last or
third to last bullet there near Vanier
old jet Forum Park will be used to park
trucks and passenger vehicles with cabs
and LRT available for demonstrators to
get downtown so we've heard a lot of
evidence on the commit at the commission
already about what the plans may or may
not have been
um but I understand this reflects the uh
notion that protesters would be would
park at I think what's what's now
referred to as in common products of
Coventry Road and then be bussed in from
there or from various locations
um and then if we just scroll down here
do assessment
Ottawa Police assessment determines
there's no need for people to stay home
or close or businesses to close
OPP is advising motorists to avoid trial
uh travel because of the delays
Ottawa Police OPP RCMP as well as the
city of Ottawa or coordinating a
response
disruption to government activities
expected to be minor because most
employees are at home intersect is
indicating this will be a significant
hint and extremely fluid event that
could go on for a prolonged period it's
anticipated to be peaceful does that
reflect essentially the information that
you had at the time and your
expectations yes okay so is it fair to
say you anticipated that it would be
well actually I'll just ask it
open-ended how long did you think it
would last what were you expecting to
happen when the Convoy arrived
uh the expectation that I had was that
the Convoy would uh Park and stay for
the weekend and leave on the Sunday okay
Mr Roshan is
is that your expectation as far as the
Ottawa situation was yes and we were
also watching to see whether other
protests that were bubbling across uh
the country would also but the
expectation was they would all be
peaceful and they would last for that
weekend okay
is there anything in particular you'd
like to highlight about what was going
on across the country at that time
no other than to say you know uh
transport obviously had
um some concerns with regard to various
protests happening and how it might
affect the flow of traffic how it might
affect uh supply chain issues from a
transport perspective uh Canada Border
Services Agency I think started to ask
questions about uh political particular
ports of entry and
um so from a critical infrastructure
perspective and this is really why gawk
was was involved is to make sure that we
were mindful that there could be impacts
to critical infrastructure and as a
result we were being watchful
but the expectation although it does say
in this in this document I note that
intersect which uh was uh the broader
group that um that uh Mr Stewart
referred to a moment ago
um they indicated that uh the situation
was very fluid and that it could go on
for a more prolonged period particularly
in Ottawa
so I would I would like to add to that
if I may please do um
so the convoys
um were very organic
um kind of uh protest and it was very
difficult
uh and I've used the word intelligence
in a very technical sense before but to
be to have good Intel of what the plans
were for any of the convoys as they
manifested and uh we were starting to
see uh Slow Roll convoys in other places
in the country
and as as as Dominic has said
um we were concerned that this movement
would grow and it wouldn't be just a
one-time only event but this would this
would in the end uh manifest across the
country in various places and I believe
right by the end of January we're
starting to see the blockade and the
Coots Port of Entry so therefore you
know we had evidence that it could in
fact impair critical infrastructure and
the you know the economy and the lives
of Canadians okay so one eye open that
this could develop into something but
essentially with respect to Ottawa at
least the expectation was that it would
end after the weekend and as we know now
that didn't happen
um and it didn't end up after the
weekend some tracks stayed many
protesters stayed
um so the next sort of topic I want to
address is very broadly how did the
federal government respond
um and let's start by talking I we know
that there were a variety of committees
struck and uh calls and meetings taking
place so Mr Stewart I'll ask you to walk
us through that starting with the
internal federal government response so
all right so we've we've established
that prior to the convoys arrival in
Ottawa
uh there were discussions taking place
in the regular fora which included the
deputy Minister's operational and
Coordination Committee
um and uh um
bilateral discussions across departments
including transport uh to just um take
stock basically and make sure we had
situational awareness and I believe PCO
officials would have been informing uh
political officials at their end we were
certainly keeping the minister apprised
in his office
um
as the weekend progressed
um and it became clear that the Convoy
was intending to stay in the original
thinking was so they would only stay
another couple of days and then it
gradually morphed into a extended period
of time uh we ramped up uh the internal
discussions
um and started to have a regular
briefing on a daily basis of a small
group of ministers including the
minister of Public Safety and the
minister of emergency preparedness quite
often the minister of transport and the
minister of intergovernmental Affairs as
well and occasionally the Minister of
Justice so these were key ministers in
in the context of the protests and they
were uh there we started daily briefings
of that group at the beginning of the uh
the first week after the weekend
um and I were supported by regular daily
meetings of the dmoc Deputy ministers
operational committee uh court and
Coordination Committee meetings
um as well as other uh uh discussions
that we were having and that goes
outside of government but with other
officials around the country
so
those two groups the dmoc group of
senior officials and the ministerial
briefing group were the principal uh um
for in which uh the ongoing protests
around the country and the situation
otherwise was discussed
okay
um so dmoc is another acronym that we're
going to have to get used to pretty
quickly so no no this one is going to
come up a lot over the next couple of
weeks so so we'll learn it now Deputy
Minister operations committee the dmoc
who who attended the dmoc who
participated in them
um the standing membership
would be a chair of National Security
intelligence advisor uh the intelligence
agencies uh the Canadian Security
establishments and csis RCMP Department
of Transport or Deputy minister of
Transport Deputy minister of Public
Safety
uh
Deputy minister of global affairs
Deputy minister of in immigration
and citizenship
um
I'm going to miss one here the the the
chief of Defense staff
sorry I'm cbsa cbsa yes of course in dry
defense
okay
um and you saw you you refer just now to
the communication security establishment
can you just explain what that is
it's one of the two primary intelligence
agencies that does signals intelligence
signals intelligence can you explain
what signals intelligence is
foreign signals intelligence I should
point out the communication security
establishment is responsible uh for two
things one collecting foreign signals
intelligence uh on
non-canadians outside of Canada
very strict mandate but they also have
the responsibility for the Canadian
cyber Center so they produce threat
assessments for example for for cyber
incidents and things of that nature
thank you
okay Mr Stewart sorry about that little
interlude so there was the democ and
then you said there was these daily
ministerial briefings and at a high
level can you explain what those daily
ministerial briefings were about
they had multiple purposes the first was
of course situational awareness so there
was a a briefing at the beginning of it
uh typically by the commissioner of the
RCMP and as well by the president of the
Canada Border Service Agency on as the
on the situation on the ground across
the country
um that would be supplemented by any
information obtained from other sources
if I had had conversations with other
officials elsewhere I would report on
that
um and then we would
um discuss you know the federal
government's ability to to to deal with
the protests what we were able to
mobilize or what we were doing such as
the provision of RCMP officers uh to
support the Ottawa Police Service and we
would also discuss you know what
ministers messages would be for
Canadians because they were making
frequent public appearances okay
um and you mentioned that uh the the
principal briefer was often commissioner
Lucky from the RCMP yes why was that
well the police of jurisdiction in
Ottawa
um were connected to the RCMP and are on
a regular basis the RCMP coordinates
because they have jurisdiction over some
some areas of the city small areas that
are federal
um and and so they work very closely
together and of course the police were
including the opp uh they had an
integrated command oh well they had a
national capital region uh crisis center
that they were uh uh that they'd staffed
um and that was where the RCP was
getting the information but the opp was
not in these calls nor was the Ottawa
Police so they were the they were in a
sense
um uh the commission of the RCMP was in
a sense the person who who uh collected
that information and brought it to the
table okay so these two things that
we're talking about the democ and the
ministerial briefings these are entirely
internal to the federal government
that's what you asked for it's exactly
right
um okay and before we move on to
external
um Mr Rochelle just ask you to explain
we you touched on this before but what
the ADM and Sops was doing at the time
so uh commensurate with those uh two
meetings that uh Mr Stewart just
described administops was also meeting
daily and essentially feeding into those
meetings so it's just one one layer
Below in terms of assistant Deputy
ministers from all of those same
departments and agencies coming together
and discussing situational awareness
around the various incidents that were
occurring across the country so would it
be fair to say that the information
chain would sort of be ADM NS Ops up to
dmoc and then from dmoc up to cabinet
where warranted yep to the ministerial
level
okay Mr Stewart now I'll ask you about
the the meetings that were happening
that included actors external to the
federal government
so a couple of different points of note
there
um
as a standing matter there is a
committee of federal provincial
assistant Deputy ministers which was our
colleague talal dakabab who is a
co-chair of that committee
and it was a committee to discuss crime
prevention and policing matters
and it it exists on a permanent basis
and involves adms from across the
country all provinces and territories so
that fora was used for outreach and
discussion information sharing
and that's what's referred to as the
fptcpcc I think that is correct
crime prevention and policing committee
cppc sorry about PPC
uh so that was one one Forum um on an ad
hoc basis we convened Deputy Ministers
of uh Federal provincial uh and
territorial governments
um to discuss the situation with the
protests around the country
um and uh that happened
uh so more than once because
um I I co-chaired a call uh and then my
colleague uh the deputy minister of
Transport had calls uh with debt with
Deputy ministers or of Transport
departments around the country uh as the
protest went on I'm sure we'll come back
to that but but there was generally
speaking Deputy ministers calls and
meetings
um and as well
um I reached out to the city of Ottawa
uh early in the week that the protest
um became entrenched and we stood up uh
calls and um discussions amongst
officials and also at the ministerial
level involving the city and the
province
okay um Mr clerk can I ask you to pull
up ont000159
five zeros one five nine
these are notes that we received from
Ontario
um from a meeting on on February 6th
which I understand was one of the uh
situation in Ottawa meetings that you
described Mr Stewart and and as you said
I believe
you convene these meetings in order to
to have some input on what was going on
in Ottawa and and assist with that
situation
okay so I just want to take you to the
various things that
um you're reported to said in in this
meeting so the first thing is uh you
convene the meeting and you were looking
to get a sense of what the girl what was
going on on the ground in Ottawa and
steps to resolving the situation
first thing is you noted that uh some of
your federal ministers were concerned
and wanted a quick resolution to the
matter uh in addition there continues to
be concern from the federal ministers
about coordination of activities
federally and with other partners can
you just elaborate on on what you were
reporting there
so I was reflecting the fact that the
federal government was taking and the
Ministers of the federal government were
taking the protests very seriously and
were very concerned about how it was
evolving I've referred earlier to its
kind of organic nature the uncertainty
that prevailed the sense of
um quite frankly Menace that was
starting to manifest itself
um and given that it was happening on a
national basis
um ministers were actively to the best
of my knowledge talking to counterparts
across the country and trying to bring
things uh bring bring powers and plans
to the table
um
it's important to to note I think at
least for the record that at no time did
did uh anybody start to think about
instructing police to do anything but uh
they were very interested in what the
plans of the police were
um in various parts of the country and
and as well you know how we would
mobilize
um you know for for border crossings
with the Canadian border Service Agency
and and local
um local police so
um the sense here that you know uh there
was a uh a growing
um
set of protests occurring that it was
taxing the abilities of local
authorities uh to manage or to to
address them and uh the lack of at that
point in time
um a particular sort of
uh co uh um coordinated Federal
provincial approach
um that was what I was referring to
okay
um and just moving down if we can scroll
down to the next time you see Rob
Stewart there we go
just keeps scrolling down a little bit
Mr Clark so we can see this quote
um
sorry scroll down a little more
keep going
there we go
Rob Stewart posed the following question
to Chief Peter slowly what is the nature
of the support that auto was likely
going to ask for it says here note Rob
Stewart was trying to understand in
unsaid terms whether the Ops will
directly request non-law enforcement
assistance
uh can you tell us a little bit about
what was going on there
um well I didn't take these minutes and
I don't
um
think that's accurate
um
the chief chief slowly was saying very
openly almost right from the beginning
after the weekend that he needed more
resources and
um
fairly early on the RCMP did add
resources to help the Ottawa Police
um
and the number was quite a bit slower
than Chief slowly was asking for so
um
we weren't entirely clear
um as to what exactly he needed and in
in terms of the type of resources and
here we're talking about policing
resources
um
I had already spoken to the city
and here I mean city manager Steve
kanalakos and clarified that the federal
government had no intention of
mobilizing the Canadian Armed Forces to
deal with the protests
um
and so it was not it really uh I think a
subject of discussion at that time
um and uh the issue was more the just
the the scope and nature of the policing
resources that the city was calling for
okay and the next bullet bullet point is
what are the obvious and visible
successes that ministers can be told and
can also see what were you referring to
there what were you asking Chief slowly
about
well Chief slowly and I think the uh the
document does give some clarity to this
was reporting on what the auto Police
Service was trying to do to limit and
and and and
um contain the protests
um and uh there had been for instance
say um
uh a kind of a shack erected in one of
the parks Federal Parks which was
causing
um uh quite a lot of heartburn in that
the police were successful in
negotiating being taken down it was
storing gas and was actually I think a
barbecue stand
um but that was as an example one of the
things that you know she slowly was
recording on the police having achieved
um and uh you know he was projecting uh
a sense of
um
uh intention that that you know they
were going to continue the Ottawa Police
to the best of their ability with the
resources that they had stretched as
they were to take steps to um to
interdict and to disrupt the protest and
so this is what that question gets at is
what are your plans in the short run to
do
um that kind of thing it wasn't it
wasn't this is not predicated on at that
point in time the expectation that the
Ottawa Police
um would be able to actually bring the
protests to an end okay and that I
suppose reflects the fact that these
meetings are some information sharing
and aimed at sort of information sharing
and attempting to sort of brainstorm
solutions to be fair okay now if we can
just keep scrolling down
uh sorry let's just stop right there
nope keep going
until you see Jody Thomas National
Security advisor
and scroll down a little bit more please
uh sorry to keep going
I'll be the next one
it's a long minute okay there we go
um so Mr Stewart I just want to ask you
a little bit here about uh these
meetings were meetings that the the
officials level largely
is that right
yes okay and there was participation
from Ontario uh Mr D tommaso yes would
participate in these meetings and we
heard from Mr D Tomaso last week
um
and you'll see that quote that's
attributed to to Jody Thomas who is the
National Security advisor and you've
already told us that the National
Security advisor is an official at PCO
yes uh Who's involved in I think both
chairing the democ and coordinating
federal government response here
um so Ms Thomas has said you said noted
that it was a positive meeting and
regrets to end on this point would the
province be looking to the federal
government if this protest was happening
outside the city of Ottawa EG happening
in other places like Kingston
Mr Tomas Di Tomaso when he was here last
week the transcript reference for this
is
trn5021 Page 262 testified that he
understood this comment to mean that Ms
Thomas was trying to have the federal
government wanting or this comment
indicated that uh the federal government
was wanting to wash its hands of the
entire thing and I was wondering if you
could comment on that was that your
understanding of Ms Thomas's comment
here
not at all and I I believe
um Mr D Tomaso misinterpreted what she
was driving at
um
I think that um it wasn't uh
it was never
the view of federal officials or
ministers that the federal government
didn't have some degree of ownership of
the protest and some degree of
responsibility for dealing with it as it
was a national event
um
so it wasn't predicated the question I
don't believe was predicated on the
federal government is looking to to not
take action
um in fact it was the the opposite I
believe that the concern here was that
the province was not taking as much
action as
um they might be taking and I I want to
caveat that by saying that at no time
did I think the opp was not Rising
um uh to the to the to deal with the
event was their response was as far as I
was aware and through the commission of
the RCMP
um what it should be in terms of coming
to the city and participating in
planning and response so and Mr D Tomaso
in my conversations with him of which
there were many uh was always assuring
me that the opp was on the job
um and this this pertained to Ottawa it
pertained to Windsor it pertained to
other places in the province where Slow
Roll protests occurred so I think
you know I would interpret this exchange
as being largely about
um whether or not provincial politicians
would be coming to the table as Federal
ministers were coming to the table to
discuss what tools and and tactics they
could uh they could contribute
okay um and that leads into something I
want to ask you about more specifically
I think you've you've already uh
introduced it here but which is
Ontario's General position and attitude
towards the Ottawa protests and and what
was going on in in late January early
February Mr clerk can I just ask you to
pull up WTS
5066 this is your witness summary
um I'd like to refer directly to some of
the things you've said in our interview
foreign
there we go
so a in the interview you said it was
never clear whether the government of
Ontario was willing to assist Ottawa let
me you noted that the mayor of Ottawa a
new recollection was frustrated
and then
um you added there's there's a question
about how quickly the provincial
government would endorse the opp whether
it would put the weight behind the opp
uh and then
I think you've just uh answered that the
opp was fully behind this but then you
know that there's a misconception that
in the normal course protests in Ottawa
are not a provincial issue but rather
they're dealt with by a combination of
federal and local police
as he explained it he being you they
were treating Ottawa as Washington DC
can you explain what you what you meant
by that they were treating Ottawa as
Washington DC and sort of walk walk us
through what your Viewpoint was in in
the early days in February of
um attempting to deal with the situation
on behalf of the federal government
and the response you were getting from
Ontario
so in the normal course
the opp does not come to Ottawa to deal
with uh small-scale protests or Canada
Day or any other major event
that tends to be coordinated that's
within the scope and capacity of the
Ottawa Police Service and it tends to be
coordinated with the RCMP who have
responsibilities in the jurisdiction as
I said before
um for protecting ministers and federal
certain federal sites and also the
Parliamentary Protective Service who
have the responsibility of protecting
the precinct the Parliamentary Precinct
um so those would be the people who
would normally you know coordinate
around the kinds of events that have
occurred in the past uh where the scale
of the protest is not major here we were
talking about a situation where it had
clearly gotten out of control uh and
then become illegal and uh
um uh and notwithstanding that the
Ottawa Police were being backstocked by
the OPP and the RCMP there was clearly
more that needed to be done and
ultimately was uh to to at um you know
tools and powers to address the
situation and this was lurking in the
background on all the calls that we had
with ministers is where's Ontario
um
and
um
uh the technical point that I think
should be made here though is uh and I
believe Mr D Tomaso touched on this
um you know municipalities are creatures
of provinces and under the law if uh the
uh Ottawa Police Service is um uh
Innovative assistance technically they
should be asking the opp first and not
the RCMP that's according to the law
this isn't normal course and indeed it
wouldn't be the rcmp's
um I believe it would not be the rcmp's
position that they wouldn't do anything
if Ottawa needed help please come to the
help of each other all the time
um but this issue here of
um uh of Ottawa of Ottawa turning to the
federal government and asking for RCMP
and not really articulating uh you know
how many more OPP they needed I think
was also kind of a question that was
floating around in the background
when you say according to the law they
should go first to the opp what law are
you talking about there uh I can't tell
you it's specific law it's the one that
Mr D Tomaso cited
I believe that was a police services act
I believe so okay
so in addition to the meetings that
we've already talked about then uh the
dmog meetings and the mysterial
briefings there were also a series of
tripart types convened can you tell us a
bit about those
so bootstrapping in in the same way we
did with DMACC and ministers from the
calls that we had with Ontario and the
city city managers City police OPP Mr T
Tomaso we convened ministers and the
mayor
and invited uh provincial ministers to
attend
um in the end uh only Mr D Tomaso
attended those calls but they were
called tripartite because they were the
city The Province and the federal
government and they were of a very
similar nature
um to the kinds of calls we were having
with ministers internal to federal
government a discussion of the situation
the discussion of what people's position
and concerns were a discussion of what
we knew the plans uh to be at that stage
um largely a sharing of information and
concerns
okay and you noted that um those calls
were not attended by any political any
politicians from Ontario it did not have
political representation
who convened the tripartite
um
I think the federal government did
although it was very much Collective
with the city
um the city manager and I would agree
that this needed to be done
and did you attend all of the tripart
types I did okay I believe the dates of
those would be February 7th February 8th
and February 10th
yes
um before we leave this this document
your witness summary here the other
statement I wanted to ask you about was
the one where you say the provincial
government was more engaged in Windsor
because the Ambassador Bridge blockade
impacted the Ontario economy I realized
we haven't talked about Ambassador
Bridge and Windsor here yet this morning
but we heard several days of evidence
about it last week so the we're aware of
what happened in Windsor can you speak
to a little bit that that's that
Viewpoint that you held or hold that the
Ontario was more engaged in Windsor than
it was in Ottawa
um
well to a certain extent I believe it
speaks for itself
um in my conversations with Mr D Tomaso
um we were also discussing of course
what was happening in Windsor and what
the plans were for
um uh ending the protest there
um and it was
um
clear that there was a lot of attention
being paid to it at the provincial
uh government
um level
um and there was
um in part because it was a smaller
scale protest a much more
active set of plans going on to to bring
it to an end so in other words
um
uh
as I understand it I'm not a police
official
um you know there are different skill
sets that police have and one of the
skill sets or one of the types of um
policing units that was necessary in
both Auto One Windsor was a public order
units
um who where you know who are at the
helmets and carry the batons
these were needed and uh had to be
mobilized from across the province and
so
I was aware that that was the plan that
was underway that they were mobilizing
to to take take out the protest in
Windsor
um and therefore this would support the
comment that I made
okay
um the next series of meetings that I'd
like you to tell us a bit about you've
already referred to uh the acronym this
fptc so Federal provincial territorial
crime prevention and policing committee
um Mr clerk can I ask you to pull up PB
NSC can six zeroes five
seven zero is five
I see you nodding so you know better
than I do
okay can can we just scroll down so
these are
um this is a readout of the fpt actually
this is an fvdm's ad hoc meeting on
February 7th do you recall this meeting
Mr Stewart yes I mentioned it earlier
okay perfect so here's the readout
um and the first comment I want to take
you to is
just at the sort of the end of that
first paragraph where it says Intel
there's been there's not been
significant element of violent extremism
we've discussed this before can set up
another meeting with thesis and how
monitoring threats to democracy for now
there's no planning going on no degree
of violent extremism going on not saying
that this will happen
um can you just tell us a bit about what
you were saying there
um
so
CSS officials and the thesis director
was on
many calls Minister calls in fact I
think attended to try for tight meeting
call
um and actually can I just ask you to
tell us who attended this particular
meeting what was this meeting this
particular meeting this would have been
the all the deputy ministers those at
least that were available across the
country from provinces and territories
plus myself
and I believe Mike Michael Keenan the
deputy minister of Transport so would
these be all public safety uh Deputy
ministers or yes okay
yes I mean they're not all called Public
Safety very nice jurisdictions but
that's what their responsibility is
um and this the purpose of this call was
to share as I've mentioned ER
information uh you know help people uh
um uh come to terms with what was going
on make plans in their own jurisdictions
and as we know
um police jurisdiction across the
country learned very quickly
um but there was still the broader issue
of why are these protests happening and
what can we do to
de-escalate them
um so the director of csis um had been
reporting
um fairly consistently that in terms of
the threshold for
um monitoring under the thesis act uh he
was not observing any increase in
activity or any evidence of plans and
this is to be clear here
um
a very high threshold um csis
um
and my colleague Mr Rochelle can explain
this in more detail if you wish Canon
can only monitor people that they
believe to be uh threats to the security
of Canada and that's uh that's a high
bar for them and so there it's not a
very large number of people that they're
monitoring it's quite small it does not
as a general matter include the
population or large elements of the
population they are very targeted in
their activities
so in that context given their targets
they were reporting they were not seeing
any activity on the on the part of those
targets
um
and that's what I was reporting there
um uh and and then the the simple
observation that on the ground in Ottawa
um things were kind of chaotic we didn't
have any evidence of planning weren't
hearing about planning
um and and no sense of extremism in the
in the violent sense although there was
plenty of plenty of criminality by that
point
okay and we will be hearing from thesis
directly next week but I think it might
be useful Mr Rochelle you can just
elaborate briefly on um what ceases can
and cannot do and what it was and was
not monitoring here following what Mr
Stewart said
well in this particular case it again
refers to uh extremist elements so from
a terrorism perspective I mentioned
earlier the um
the ideologically motivated violent
extremism
uh which is something that uh cesus is
coming to grips with and indeed have
provided uh language in and around
defining that because
um historically I would say uh
individuals are are influenced by a
singular
um definable belief system and uh that's
how we used to treat terrorism there's
been an evolution with regard to
terrorism as of late uh now there is a
Confluence of a whole series of of uh
grievances that that can come to bear
and uh it becomes a lot more difficult
to track
exactly how a particular threat can
manifest itself in this imve environment
so there are
um xenophobic violence anti-authority
violence gender driven violence other
grievances that uh that ceases now have
to wrap their minds around how do we go
after and collect information to protect
Canadians against these emerging threats
when it can as as opposed to a a as I
mentioned earlier a belief system where
there is a clear head and a auric
structure behind a particular
organization in today's world now we're
seeing more and more that a lone wolf a
lone actor can actually perpetrate a
particular extremist violent event
nevertheless the the tools at our
disposal and at thesis disposal is very
much the thesis act that was written in
1984 and there is part 2C of the thesis
act uh or indeed part two of The Thesis
act gives four different distinctions as
to what they can collect Intelligence on
and it describes threats to the security
of of Canada so in this particular
instance what we were referring to as
you could appreciate
um
Federal provinces and or sorry provinces
and territories Representatives would be
under the impression
that federal government is sitting on a
treasure Trove of cat of classified
intelligence and based on that
intelligence they would want to know are
we seeing something from an intelligence
perspective that would show that that
these protests are organized and that
ultimately they constitute an extremist
threat to overthrow the government or
something to that effect so specifically
with regard to that extremist element uh
what we were saying here or what the the
deputy was referring to here is that as
of yet cecis has not met a threshold to
cause them to collect additional
Intelligence on a broader set of
Canadians because they had not seen
evidence of
um of that
that being said I should I should just
also qualify that that doesn't mean that
they weren't monitoring
certain extremist targets of theirs that
have met that threshold and seeing
whether or not they were interested and
I also want to qualify a comment that I
might have made earlier intelligence
again is not an exact science
and it's not
um it's not foolproof so uh
just because you have a piece of
evidence or a piece of intelligence
rather doesn't mean that you have the
full picture and it becomes a very
difficult uh Mosaic to try and pull
together in terms of pulling together
intelligence emanating from thesis
emanating from police forces emanating
from Canada Border Services Agency
pulling that picture together to
determine whether there's a national
security threat is a different
proposition than indicating whether or
not cesus specifically had evidence of a
a violent extremism meeting their
threshold
thank you that was helpful in
understanding that
um so the second bullet point then to go
back to Mr Stewart
uh on people protesting accordance in
accordance with the law
in Ottawa the law has been disregarded
Norms of behavior and laws you talk
about what's going down going on on in
downtown
Ottawa Police have not been able to
control have heard comments made to
Federal ministers do something cbsa
transport and PS that's Public Safety
officials who have heard from our
ministers roles of police and government
have not tried to get involved in
enforcement but staying in touch with
police police including RCMP and outside
Ottawa have supported of straight I
think that's probably stayed in close
touch political layer is engaged and
then the last line is strong desire not
to engage protesters and to let
enforcement take its course do you
recall what that referred to in
particular that last line
um
that last line refers to the
essentially the decision by ministers
not to speak to the protesters okay so
this was uh to situate Us in time this
was on February 7th and at that point
that was the
that was the the position being taken
that was a physician
um Mr Clark we can take that document
down
and the next one to pull up is
ssm.nsc dot can five zeros246.
so these are the nsia's talking points
on February 8th and it looks like
they're for a cabinet briefing we're
going to get into to the specific
cabinet meetings in a bit
um but for now if we can go to page four
of that document Mr Clark
just a couple of specific points I'd
like to ask you about
sorry up a bit
yesterday in fpt table of DM of Public
Safety and transport met to discuss a
national and coordinated strategy that's
built upon quote-unquote maximum and
strategic enforcement using any and all
tools available at all three levels of
government and need to align all
Communications to protesters about
maximum enforcement and the consequences
General support for approach more to
come so the first question is is that
fpt table that happened the day before
is that the call that we just looked at
yes okay
um now I think we're going to hear a lot
more about this in detail when you're
calling Deputy Minister Keenan from
Transport Canada testifies which is on
Wednesday but can you briefly explain to
us what this idea of a maximum on
strategic strategic enforcement strategy
was
the idea here was to use tools that
would not normally be used
in addition to the to to
um
um to the to the powers that the police
have so
um that would in a sense it would
include enforcement of bylaws and
traffic
um uh laws but it would also
um involve
um as a means of deterring people from
joining protests or being party to
protests the use of regulations and
other
provincial authorities uh which are
related to trucking
um so here
um you know for as an example and as you
say Mr Debbie Mr Keenan can speak to
this
um you know we're talking about
um uh deregistering a commercial vehicle
um making it unable to be used for you
know Commerce
um not renewing licenses
um or various other ideas that were
being floated around that we could do we
could use at the transport level
transport Authority level uh that would
that would have some effect so that's
that's the general idea okay and if we
just scroll down a little bit more to
page five
departments have developed a Rolodex of
quote-unquote creative alternatives to
be explored in addressing this matter so
that refers to that's what you were just
talking about this this idea of trying
to come up with Alternatives or ideas
and can you give us some examples of
what those that Rolodex would have
contained
well certainly what I just spoke of
um
uh
um I would I would really need to refer
to the the lists that we developed to be
to be accurate and there are lists and
evidence there are um which come up um
or manifest a little bit later uh so off
the top of my head
um
I don't recall any other specific things
other than in the transport realm okay
well again I think Deputy Minister
Keenum will be taking us through this in
great detail but sort of skipping to the
the conclusion
um what happened with the idea of the
the maximum enforcement strategy did
that ever materialize were steps taken
by the provinces to to
our municipal authorities to actually
Implement some of these well the the
most obvious manifestation of action
would have been the Ontario emergency
order on the 11th of February okay
before we get there
um there is another topic I'd like to
ask you about which is requests for
federal assistance so this again Falls
within the rubric of what was going on
between the provinces municipalities and
the and the federal government at the
time
um so request for federal assistance I
understand that that's a responsibility
that falls to the gox so can I ask you
to ex to an extent at least to be
processed through the Glock if I can put
it that way uh can you explain uh W
Master Stewart how that process works
um so it's under the Emergency
Management act and a responsibility of
the department and then that's delegated
to the government operations center to
coordinate and the government operations
center for the record is a coordination
unit a surveillance and coordination
unit it doesn't have powers it doesn't
execute it doesn't have authorities it
just works to bring Partners to the
table so an RFA is in essence a
situation in which uh the provincial
capacity to deal with an issue or uh yes
a provincial territorial capacity to
deal with an issue has been surpassed
and they need federal assistance
and the the role of the gawk is to is to
discuss the the request and to
coordinate the response
um
they occur most frequently in the uh in
the world of um you know natural
um events uh fires floods
um but there were many in the context of
the pandemic as well in fact there were
I think well over 190 in the last
three two and a half years or so
um which is Way Way Beyond the normal
level
um in the context of the uh the protests
there were only three
um and some of them some of them can be
very routine so one of the the first one
was for uh to use a federal space the
crochet
um drill Hall uh to Park police vehicles
um and and that was just that's a
federal land it needed a permission
granted
um there was also an RFA from the
parliamentary protective service at one
point in time to make sure that they
could be supplied with food and support
in the event that they were barricaded
in due to police enforcement so those
are two rfas that occurred the main RFA
uh that I think is of of note is the one
that came in from Alberta and that one
did not follow the normal course the
normal course for an RFA is it is it to
be flagged by a provincial emergency
authority to the gawk allows for some
back and forth about you know is this
possible can we meet this need uh how
are we going to respond to this and and
you know that just Smooths and expedites
the process in this case it came in by
letter from uh thought uh a Alberta
Minister uh directly to
um a federal Minister and we had no
forewarning of its um of its appearance
um so do you want me to further explain
that sure and maybe actually at this
point it would be helpful to bring up
the document it's PB can 50718.
so this is the RFA request for federal
assistance from Minister MacGyver to
minister Blair and the request here is
for tow trucks and personnel
prescribed largely
so I believe Mr Stewart you were in the
process of telling us how that RFA was
dealt with
in public safety yes so um
uh background
um this is a with respect to situation
in Coots the rcmp's police of
jurisdiction and we're
um you know faced with a problem of
getting the trucks uh off the off the
border crossing and the highway
um and uh the absence of tow trucks um
and in in a general sense it was a
feature of these protests across the
country and particularly where they they
manifested as as encampments that the
local tow truck industry would refuse uh
to provide service uh
uh I ostensibly due to threats
um
to their livelihood so
um uh this letter came in
um it as you say came a bit out of the
blue it wasn't uh uh hard to understand
why the request was being made
um and uh the question became you know
is this a RFA that we can address and
you know two issues surfaced uh one was
whether we had the resources uh and that
would be um in effect the towing
equipment of the Armed Forces
um you know they have a base in Edmonton
quite a long way from the border
um and it has uh equipment to tow uh
heavy Vehicles however uh there's a very
limited number of of those uh units I
understand and and moreover they were
not uh of the of the same type as heavy
heavy lift tow trucks and and would have
had they been used likely damaged
um the trucks they towed so the general
um conclusion was that the the resources
of the Canadian Armed Forces were not
appropriate to the task and of course we
didn't have any other tow trucks
elsewhere
um
the other issue that surfaced was
whether the province had exhausted its
authorities
and here I note that the province had a
critical infrastructure Defense Act
which gave them the power to
command tow truck industry as as we did
with the emergencies act and that had
not been used
um so for both of those reasons uh we
signaled that we would not be
meeting this RFA
um although we bore it very very much in
mind is when we formulated the orders
under the emergencies Act okay so just
to make sure I understand that on the
one hand it was determined uh that the
Canadian ROM forces did not have the
appropriate equipment that was not
suited to task and on the other hand
uh Alberta did have in its own powers
the ability to compel tow trucks and
under his critical infrastructure
correct act okay
foreign
the next topic I'd like to address
briefly is the engagement between Public
Safety and the US Department of Homeland
Security I understand there were a
couple of calls around February 10
February 11th are you able to speak to
those at all and tell us a bit about
what what you were hearing from Homeland
Security
um well I'll expand a bit I was partied
to a call involving an official from the
White House in the National Security
intelligence advisor and the call was
essentially to express the concerns that
the U.S had with the situation at the
Windsor at The Ambassador Bridge and
also what was going on uh generally in
terms of public order
and that conversation uh was a
situational update
we were we explained in the National
Security intelligence advisor provided
some insight into the thinking in Canada
around what we were doing and how we
intended to dress the protests the White
House official
offered support uh you know whatever
they could think of and in particular
say tow trucks from Detroit
um so that was that call there were
subsequent calls she that that person
was the White House person responsible
for the Department of Homeland Security
what was her name I think it's Elizabeth
Sherwood Randall
that was the only call I was yelling um
there was calls with the Department of
Homeland Security officials and I
believe you did one I
two there you go
so the assistant secretary responsible
for counterterrorism and threat
prevention Samantha vinaigrad
did reach out to my national security
policy directorate to ask about you know
for situational awareness about what was
going on with regard to the protests and
whether or not threats were manifesting
themselves and so I was brought in I
don't have the data off the top of my
head but I was brought in uh I think the
week of February 10th
um during that week I uh I provided a
a brief to her and some of her officials
in terms of the situation happening in
Canada and whether or not we had any
um uh how we were how were we were
coping with the Potential Threat to
National Security and similarly
obviously on her side of the Border
um
you know following the year the Year
prior with the January 6 Capital uh
event
um they still had
potential extremist elements and uh
there was also the possibility of
convoys happening in and around uh
various activities happening in
Washington so we were just comparing and
and we agreed to keep each other in
touch with regard to the threat
situation from a counter-terrorism
perspective
were they expressing concern about about
various convoys happening through the
U.S as well
uh from my recollection not specifically
but they they certainly had it on their
radar as uh they they were expressing
concern about what they were hearing
about and seeing in Canada and wanted to
make sure that they understood how we
were coping with it and whether or not
it could manifest itself on their side
of the Border
the next topic I want to get into is the
inputs that you were providing to
cabinet over the uh the course of the
Convoy so Mr commissioner I don't know
if you'd like me to start now or if this
would be a good time for the break
if it's a good time for you it's a good
time for me always a good time for me
we'll take a 15-minute break and uh
come back in 15 minutes to continue
the commission is in recess for 15
minutes
foreign
so as I mentioned before the break uh
the next topic I'd like to address with
you is the various inputs that you were
providing to cabinet over the course of
the Convoy so Mr clerk I'll ask you to
pull up SSM
NSC can five zeros292
these are minutes from a cabinet
committee on safety security and
emergencies on February 3rd so Mr
Stewart the first thing I'll ask you to
do is can you tell us what the big
committee on safety security and
emergencies or SSE is
it's a standing committee of cabinet
um under the um the current government
created to
um
provide a form for discussion on issues
associated with its title
um and as chaired by Minister Blair
meets periodically and generally is a is
a is a forum for
bringing forward policy and expenditure
items in this domain but it also is a
forum for discussion of extraordinary
events
okay and I understand that the cat the
SSC committee met three times in
relation to the Convoy and this was the
first meeting that addressed the events
of the Convoy is that right
I think that's right I could cribble a
bit and say I think one of those
meetings was a regular meeting and they
talked about the Convoy but I believe
there were two ad hocs okay
um if we can just scroll down to page
five Mr Clerk
we'll see about halfway down that page
the deputy a minute there we go Deputy
minister of Public Safety
oh
so Mr Stewart
um I'll read this slowly for the benefit
of the interpreters
the deputy minister of Public Safety
provided an overview of engagements to
date with the city of Ottawa and the
province of Ontario
the deputy ministers stated that the
view of the Ottawa Police is that they
will not be able to bring the protest to
a conclusion without the assistance of
the federal government due to concerns
for Public Safety there is a risk that
increased enforcement will provoke some
protesters there is work being done by
the city on an injunction however there
is no timing on if and when it could be
issued finally automatic compensation
for policing costs and consideration for
compensating the businesses and people
impacted
so if I understand correctly what you
were
putting forth the cabinet at that point
was the result of all of the various
conversations you were had it having
both within the federal government and
with counterparts from Ottawa Ontario
Etc so this was the state of the
situation that you were reporting on
February 3rd is that right that's
correct okay
um so a couple of specifics in here
The View uh that the Ottawa the view of
the Ottawa Police is that they will not
be able to bring the protest to an end
without the assistance of the federal
government can you tell us where that
view that you're expressing comes from
Chief slowly okay and uh more generally
uh what was he expressing and also was
he you say specifically here without the
assistance of the federal government was
it Federal specifically or was it both
provincial and and federal so
essentially just convey to us what what
she slowly he conveyed to you and what
you were bringing up to Cabinet here
um
I would say
that as a general matter Chief slowly
was not uh trying to pick who would come
to his assistance and the assistance of
the auto Police Service uh so I would
say I was just focusing on it the
federal government for the purposes of
this meeting it's implicit that the
provincial police would also be uh
required to assist to to meet I believe
the number he was using on or about that
time was 1800 police officers which is a
very large number
um so
um uh I wasn't I wasn't in a meeting to
suggest that the provincial government
was not involved at this stage
but what you're conveying essentially is
that at this point he'd formed the
conclusion that the Ops couldn't do this
alone they needed help
um
that's enough of that document can we go
Mr clerk to SSM NSC can five zeros293
so this is the next SSE meeting which is
on February 6th these are the minutes
from that and again at page five please
there we go
paragraph three there the deputy
minister of Public Safety provided an
overview engagements to date with the
city of Ottawa and the province of
Ontario the deputy Minister stated that
there is a clear indication that the
city of Ottawa will declare a state of
emergency
an emergency council meeting is planned
for Monday to identify options which
will likely result in a request to the
government of Canada for police support
the deputy Minister indicated that the
Ottawa Police Services viewed the
dismantling of structures at
Confederation Park as a success and will
continue to enforce further the deputy
Minister reiterated the views of
provincial colleagues that negotiation
is the ongoing preferred option for
resolution at this time
so can you tell us what essentially in
not these words but your own words now
where that information was coming from
and what you were attempting to convey
here
it was an extension of uh the activities
that we've discussed my conversations
bilateral conversations with the city
manager uh multilateral conversations
involving the chief of police and the
opp
um and the RCMP uh conversations
bilateral conversations with the
commissioner of the RCMP and with Deputy
Minister Dita Massa those are the
principal points of contact
okay
um
no I want to take you to something
specifically that actually arose in the
last extract and the sort of alluded to
here as well but
um the law enforcement response in
Ottawa generally so so what happened in
Ottawa
Ottawa the ops's reaction and response
to the protests as they as they happened
uh and I'll take us away from the the
minutes for a second to pull out your
interview summary up again so Mr clerk
that's WTS 5066.
perfect
if you can go to page 12 Please Mr Clerk
okay so this is a topic Mr Stewart that
we canvas fairly in depth at your
interview
um
and you're starting here I think from
the from the very initial reaction of
the Ops to the protests and you say from
the beginning well you're actually
conveying commissioner Lucky's words
here or her views uh
she reported that from the beginning the
Ops were on their heels the volume of
people exceeded their ability to do
policing and they made a mistake in
allowing trucks to come into the
downtown corn park on the street
commissioner lucky also reported that
the ncrc fee sorry that the ncrcc was
not working particularly well because
there were personality issues involved
Deputy Minister Stewart explained that
he got the sense that as time went on
the Ops pulled together and the ope got
OPP got involved so I'll just stop there
and ask you to describe in general terms
what you were hearing about the Ops
response and what views you formed about
it
my understanding
both firsthand in conversations with
Chief slowly and uh second or third hand
through the commissioner of the RCMP was
that
um
have the situation having come to to
where to what was
um in other words an uh an embedded
protest that that um you know had formed
a perimeter in essence that was hard to
enter and to do any enforcement within
um
uh that there was some considerable
debate behind the scenes as to what uh
the strategy would be for enforcement
um and kind of a chicken and egg
situation where uh the various police
forces involved and here I'm I'm not
just referring to the opp and the RCMP
but also other Ontario Police who
ultimately came to Ottawa to assist
um were uh waiting for a clear
um a plan of action before they
mobilized the vast amount of police
officers that ultimately came to the
city
um to take action and that plan
um you know in the early going was very
fragmentary in the sense that it
involved some enforcement actions but it
wasn't to take down the protest plan and
the formulation of the takedown the
protest plan took time
um and
um uh
in general I think
um there were differences as far as I
could tell of you about what the right
strategy would be and um it took um it
took uh a couple of weeks before uh the
right uh chemistry in behind the scenes
in the integrated Command Center was was
attained that was my impression
okay um and if we can just scroll down a
little bit here to page 13.
and
paragraph three so just scroll down a
little bit
so here you're adding it was difficult
to get people to come to an agreement
about a plan because they were
personality issues in the mix and then
you go on to talk about that so that
probably refers to what you were just
saying about chemistry at the NC RCC can
you can you elaborate a little bit on
the personality issues that you were
hearing about
uh not really I mean this this in a
sense what I said before is probably
the main uh substance of this and what I
knew and understood
um
and I don't
I would not want to lay this at the door
of Chief slowly to be honest with you
um he what I was hearing that he was
very involved and and that it was uh
difficult uh partly because everybody
was stretched so thin to get to a
landing Zone on a plan
um
and that there were disagreements
um about about what the right strategy
was
um my own firsthand uh experience with
Chief slowly
um was quite limited and to the calls
that we had with the city I had seen him
before in another context and not but
not met him
um and I knew he had um a strong
personality
um and then just scroll up again sorry
the previous page
there we go um the rcmp's position was
that the Ops should have asked the opp
for more resources
and it was the OPP's responsibility to
come and serve he explained this is you
explaining that the RCMP felt pressed by
the Ops but that the opp was the force
that the Ops should look to pursuant to
legislation so that's what you were
telling us about it's according to that
so that information is information that
you were being given by the RCMP we're
not the right people the opp are the
first sort of call to action here is
that right I just want to correct the
last part um the RCMP was always willing
to come and assist
always wanted to you know sort of play a
role and were willing to do so
um but to get RCMP uh officers
into Ontario is is actually quite a
significant logistical issue because
they only have federal police in the
province they don't have contract police
now RCMP is
contract police in a number of provinces
and territories which is your regular
police and who are trained and equipped
to do public order and and enforce the
law
um and relatively speaking they had very
few federal police in Ontario so to get
uh RCMP officers uh into Ottawa required
them to be mobilized outside the
province and that requires
um you know some paperwork
um in an agreement and a request of the
minister of the jurisdiction and
approval by the minister of Public
Safety so they were they were concerned
that they were being pressed to do this
without a plan and they wanted the opp
to be first in line to come and help but
they were always willing to help that's
fair I was sort of talking about the
order as opposed to willingness so so
that's a fair response thank you
um
you can just I the next uh issue I want
to raise here is the issue of swearing
in so if we can just scroll down a
little bit there we go so there's all
there's also the obstacle you say of
swearing in RCMP officers so they would
have the jurisdiction to enforce
Municipal and provincial laws
um we've heard again evidence about this
already in the commission uh Mr clerk if
you can just scroll to page 13.
now I appreciate here that it was your
colleague not you speaking
um but can you speak to the swearing-in
process uh at all and how that may have
played into difficulties on the ground
my understanding uh is essentially
reflected in these in these comments
which was that
um
uh when the RCMP had come to a decision
about people to bring into the province
they had to go through this
um administrative process of getting
sworn in which was a decision of the
solicitor general of Ontario and as for
that purpose then they had to send a
detailed list of names and then when
that list was sent it wasn't coming back
that's what I was hearing
um as quickly as you know it might
otherwise I can't really put a time on
that to be honest with you
um but it was a material enough issue
that of course when we did the orders
under the emergency act
um we decided to you know exempt the
RCMP from that requirement so that they
could move a lot of people into the
province very quickly
so that was a concern that that had been
raised there's an impediment to
mobilizing police resources
thank you Mr Clark can we take up the uh
the February 6 minutes again so SSM NSC
can five zeros293
page five
so Mr Stewart the last line in that
little blurb of what you were saying
says the deputy Minister reiterated the
views of provincial colleagues that
negotiation is the ongoing preferred
option for resolution at this time what
were you referring to there
um
well two things in in essence um one was
my experience
um
uh two years before
uh when we had the wetsuit and protests
um and we had uh the situation in tie
and denauga where the trains were
blocked
um and my conversations with again uh
Deputy Minister D tommaso at that time
where he was
uh very clearly and strongly expressing
The View and this was based on history
for the opp that
um de-escalation is uh very important uh
to managing a protest and enforcement
can only lead to uh further trouble and
that was certainly
um
seemed very likely in the context of the
wet sweat and protests
um but I'd say as a more General matter
in the in the context of the
conversations that I was having with him
he just always held that view that from
a policing point of view
and I want to say this actually I want
to say this very clearly
the police as I understand them and I've
come to know them
fairly well in the three years I've been
in the job at least the RCMP are very
concerned about Public Safety
and protecting Public Safety and and and
and keeping the peace and they will
always prefer
given the latitude to do so
to de-escalate and to find ways to
um uh uh stop protests and uh
um prevent violence from occurring
without taking enforcement action
because it's safer for their members and
it's safer for the public
and so this is a in a sense a first
principle of policing protect
the members and the public from you know
things escalating
and uh in that context you know uh and
it's been mentioned I think in testimony
before the activities of the police
liaison teams is is very important
okay so this is this in time we're on
February 6 here and this was a view that
you you say you held from your own
experience and was being expressed by Mr
G Tomaso from his policing experience
um Mr Clark can we now bring up February
8th minutes which is SSM NSC can 50295
page 10 please
there we go
paragraph eight
so here the the Debbie Minister provided
an update on engagement with Ottawa
confirming that since the injunction has
been in place there have been no horns
used in Ottawa by the protesters the Ops
is reporting that their staff are tired
and need enforcements
it is evident that the protest is well
organized and that the blockade at
Ambassador Bridge is designed to divide
the attention of the op of the Ontario
Provincial Police the deputy Minister
confirmed that Ottawa has developed a
plan that is being reviewed by the OPP
and the RCMP which includes four key
elements Reliance on negotiation ongoing
enforcement
containing the demonstrations once an
area is cleared and Gathering
intelligence uh of various trucking
companies okay
um
so a couple of things I want to ask you
about here first of all just to situate
Us in time this is now February 8th and
and the blockade at Ambassador Bridge
has happened and sort of coalesced on
February 7th so one thing you note here
is that
um
there's
the Ambassador Bridge blockade is
designed to divide the attention of the
opp and that this is evidence that the
protest is well organized uh can you
comment on that and whether where that
observation came from and and
it may have been an overstatement
um it is evident that that the protests
were being organized and in a way that
attracted significant numbers of
individuals and it wasn't in fact just
the Ambassador Bridge it was elsewhere
in Ontario ultimately other ports of
Entry
um where uh convoys manifested
um so
uh
well is perhaps too strong a word but
there were there was definitely
organization happening
um and uh I want to be a little bit
um
uh clear here that you know we were not
well cited when it came to how uh people
were communicating with each other
um they were using different uh social
media platforms and maybe others as
other tools
um but we
um in part going back to comments made
by my colleague
um weren't weren't monitoring other than
through open source uh what was going on
so we would have we would not have felt
uh we did not feel well equipped to
understand what uh plans were and and
yet things were happening so that's
that's the Genesis of that comment and
and also
um just to flag that um you know we were
sensing that
um this was Nationwide because convoys
were happening across the country
okay um and I'm going to ask you to tell
us a little bit about that keeping in
mind that we're going to be hearing
directly from cbsa Canada Board of
Services Agency and from Transport
Canada who will have a lot to say about
the specifics of what was going on at
various ports of entry and places across
the country uh would you be able to give
us a sort of a high level overview of
what you were seeing and what you were
being informed about around this time
across the country
um
well there was quite a list actually
um I'd have a hard time itemizing it but
there were the principal places in which
disruption was occurring were uh Windsor
of course and that happened
um well after Coots started um being
blockaded uh and at uh shortly
thereafter shortly after coot started we
had Emerson in the province of Manitoba
um and
um uh slow roll and a traffic Highway
blocking protests near the Blue Water
Bridge in Ontario near the Peace Bridge
in Niagara
um and and and and some sense that this
something could happen in Cornwall
um
in later on in British Columbia we had
the Pacific Highway uh Convoy
um so those would be the the principal
ones um every day in our calls with
Minister cbsa would be reporting across
a whole set of uh ports of Entry what
they were observing and they had um
they had taken steps to better equip
themselves to to see what was going on
uh and to talk to local uh police
authorities to see if it could all be
met could be managed that if a trucking
or a convoy manifested itself it could
be directed away from the Port of Entry
and couldn't install itself in in in the
port or on the bridge or whatever the
case may be
okay
so essentially um as you've said
you and your position as as DM Public
Safety we're looking at the not just
what was happening in Ottawa but what
was happening across the country and
yes the federal government was as as a
as a group we were all conscious that
this was not something which limited to
ottawattawa was the most extreme example
uh but the general
uh impression we had was that um
uh what had begun as a protest about
vaccine mandates had become something
more than that and was attracting
various people from various
um with various issues and causes and
had become a kind of a popular
thing
um and we were seeing in other countries
by the way too
can you tell us a bit about that yeah
there were
there were convoys in New Zealand with
Canada flags
um which were just essentially emulating
protest
that was happening in Canada yeah
um so
let's go to uh now the February 10th
minute so this is SSM NSC can five
zeros209
so these are now minutes from a
different cabinet committee called the
incident Response Group
um and we will be hearing from PCO later
in the week and the details of what that
that is and how that transpired but
again can you just give us a very brief
definition of what the incident Response
Group is
well to begin with I wouldn't call it a
cabinet committee as such fair enough
cabinet committees um
in the I guess in the in the normal
courts are standing committees to deal
with various you know policy and uh
policy matters um the internet Response
Group is an ad hoc uh committee that the
Prime Minister convenes as and when
required
um and so it doesn't have regular
meetings
um and indeed it only meets when
something extraordinary is happening so
and an IRG that's the acronym that will
come to know and love over the next
couple of weeks
um the IRG was convened on February 10th
so this is the first meeting of the IRG
is that right that's correct okay uh can
we go to page six please
scroll down a little bit until you see
Public Safety Canada there we go
okay Public Safety Canada reported on a
conversation with the lead negotiator
OPP
who noted that in Ottawa approximately
80 percent of protesters had a weak
connection to the cause
five percent had a strong Devotion to it
and 15 percent were a swing Factor
The Negotiator suggested that the
leaders of the protest could potentially
be encouraged to leave and denounce the
blockade in exchange for a commitment to
register their message with the
government
okay Mr Stewart first question is is the
lead negotiator OPP you were speaking
about there who's that Marcel bodett
okay Marcel Bowden so we've heard Mr
Bowden come and testify here
um
can you start off by just telling us a
little bit what you were reporting here
to cabinet at this time
so I've mentioned earlier that the
federal government
um to the best of my knowledge
had made a decision not to engage
formally the leaders or the protesters
um in in
um you know just allowing them to
represent their views
um
and that was that was just as far as I
was aware an issue of principle
um
and uh uh rooted in in a sense that it
was hard to know who to engage and uh
also what that engagement would lead to
and there was definitely no desire to
get into uh discussions around the
federal Public Health policy
um which was one of the original reasons
the protests occurred
um as time passed
um the notion of
um uh engagement
um kind of morphed into more of what
I've already mentioned as being kind of
a police tactic
um and a
a potentially useful one so
shortly the day before in fact this
meeting occurred
um we were we Deputy ministers were
meeting and um agreed that we would
pursue any ideas we could come up with
from our list which you have I think uh
attached to this document
um and and see what it turned up by way
of
um possible decisions possible actions
for the federal government
so I had
reached out uh in fact on the morning of
this day uh to Marcel beaudette who had
been identified to me by the RCM no by
by Mario Di Tomaso and uh and echoed by
the commissioner commissioner Lockheed
that he would be the right person to
talk to and we'd had a general
conversation around
uh you know the role of uh plts and
de-escalation
um
which was very educational for me
um and
um what I took uh from that conversation
was that there was some
possibility that
if they could identify appropriate
interlocutors and he said that they knew
of six people that they could talk to
who were
leaders of A Sort and within the protest
and offer an opportunity for them to be
heard that this would have the effect of
um
allowing people to see achieve something
and some success and feel that their uh
their objectives had been achieved and
therefore leave
um and this is the where the statistics
come up is that you know 80 of the
protesters
um
uh and particularly two and two and a
half weeks into the protest you know
where they've been sitting on the
streets of Ottawa and freezing weather
um we're probably likely to go if they
had the right offer
um and so we were talking about
um that possibility and and
it was really at that point in time not
about
um
engagement in this in in the in the way
that had been about engagement before it
was more in that in the context of
Engagement as a stepping stone to
enforcement because it was very clear by
the 10th of February
uh that uh the RCMP the opp and the
Ottawa Police Service were beginning to
come
together on a plan and enforcement was
only a matter of time
and so
uh in the background of course was this
question which I think was very material
in the overall decision to invoke the
act of what would that enforcement and
gender by way of reaction
and we had strong concerns as Mr Roshan
has mentioned about you know lone wolves
and people who've been attracted to the
the protest and could could act out in a
violent way
um so I there was a there was a virtue
to de-escalation in in this context
okay
uh engagement as a stepping stone to
enforcement I just want to unpack that a
little bit so you said at this point the
engagement that was being contemplated
would not was not something that would
lead to an end a protest in and of
itself correct so the intention would
have been shrink it to shrink it to
shrink the footprint as they say in the
lingo that we've we've learned
okay
um
and we know what ultimately comes with
this or at least part of what comes of
this as something that's come to be
known as the engagement proposal
can you tell us how that proposal came
to be
well it flowed directly from what I've
just spoken about
um in the context of coming up with
options for federal government action at
a point in time when the protests were
in Ottawa in particularly but but just
Nationwide given the Slow Roll convoys
manifesting all over the place what
could we do uh that would that would um
that would help
um and so uh with the aid of uh
inspector bodan I drafted a very short
uh document it's attached to the minutes
of one of these IRG meetings
um and uh you know brought it forward
for consideration essentially
it was
um the notion that the federal
government would acknowledge
uh the desire to meet
um and and offer to do so at a later
time
away from the protest
on the basis that a protester
uh would denounce the protest and leave
so it was essentially a you know a
bargain
um and it was positioned to be just a
hearing of protesters views and not any
discussion of what the federal
government would do or could do
um
there was that it happened very quickly
did it over a day or so
um and didn't have time to do anything
other than consult with sort of key
authorities which would have been uh the
RCMP and the opp
um
and colleagues at PCO who obviously were
leading the overall effort
um it could have been consulted more it
could have been you know talked about
but it was raced forward to the cabinet
table uh two days after this
conversation occurred
okay um you noted that there were some
colleagues from PCO involved do you
recall who was involved
um and I talked to my inspector bodak I
was accompanied by a PCO official um
Jeff Hutchinson
and I I I included him in the call
because I
I wanted PCO to be fully plugged into
what we were what I was doing okay
so Mr hutchison's role there was
essentially
Observer Observer okay
um and I understand there were some back
and forth that you you had with the RCMP
and with inspector Bowden about the The
Proposal itself so Mr clerk if we can
just pull up opp50150
excuse me
so this is an email that is not sent to
you so you may not have seen it before
but this is commissioner lucky speaking
to commissioner karik and inspector
Bowden I believe
um
so she attaches a draft of the
engagement proposal and then says I'm
not the SME SME we know stands for
subject matter in this area but my folks
are a bit worried on a few items and
need to get your thoughts do you know
what commissioner Lucky's concerns were
at that time and I'll just say two
things one we're going to hear from her
directly so we can ask her that question
and two in the course of our interview
you mentioned that uh one of
commissioner Lucky's concerns may have
been around the issue of police
Independence so just to situate a little
bit you a little bit
I believe
uh that commissioner Lucky's concerns
were essentially
um
a in the issue of you know if this came
forward to a cabinet table and was
decided upon would it constitute some
kind of direction to police to do it and
of course police want to maintain
operational Independence and maximum
flexibility
um
so it it she did not want it to be
construed in in that fashion
um
she may also have had concerns
um she didn't Express them to me about
how it played out so we're to have been
used as a strategy and failed would it
would the RCMP or the opp plts the
police station teams be held accountable
for for that in some way
so I think the the line we've heard
expressed is there may have been some
concern that across the line between
church and state that would be the you
know okay
one thing you noted uh when we were
speaking in your interview is that the
government could benefit from some
clarity around where that line is in
police Independence
um is there anything you'd like to to
add or share
about that in this context
I believe there is virtue in clarifying
the RCMP act on this on this basis
um
recent experience in other contexts has
led me to think that too sorry you said
recent experience in other contexts
and what would those be uh the
discussions that um were going on um
with respect to uh developments in Nova
Scotia
uh and and uh the the role of Minister
Blair and ultimately decision to ban
assault rifles which engendered a lot of
questions about the communications
between ministers and the police
um Mr clerk can we bring up opp50171
foreign
as you've noted this is something that
evolved over the course of a one or two
days and we're just trying to put
together the the chronology of how
things evolved so
uh if we can scroll down top of Page
Three I believe
okay I know so in this email you're
raising some concerns about the
engagement proposal but to the very last
bit of the email now sorry
if I can manage to work through this
process and the RCMP commissioner will
be privy to the discussion I think I can
assure you that the federal government's
commitment will be solid but we have to
get their first fix so at this point in
time and this is Saturday February 12th
at 11 23 in the morning what was your
understanding of what levels of support
there was in the government for this
notion and where it came from
I had support from colleagues to bring
it to the cabinet table for discussion
I couldn't tell you
about the specific uh you know views in
terms of whether they thought it was a
good or a bad idea it was just in the
option set okay
um
and the next document then that we want
to look at is ssm.nsc.can402958
foreign
so this is a text between Minister
Mendocino and Katie Telford who's the
prime minister's chief of staff and I
believe this is a the evening of
February 11th
and Minister Mendocino expresses here
that uh he's just learning about the
engagement proposal so do I understand
that at this point while this was
playing out you might not yet had the
opportunity to to brief Mr Mendocino on
this is that right or well Minister
Mendocino was aware that I was working
on uh this idea
um as it had been mentioned
um the day before in the context of the
IRG meeting
um he had not seen the proposal and as I
say it was he came together uh really
very quickly and I only had time to
solicit the views of uh and it wasn't
the Ontario government it was the opp I
believe
um and and just to make sure that nobody
had any objections to what it said
um or or put on you know put forward
um so he would have just had seen it in
terms of paper and he
um would have I think felt orbit feel
uncomfortable that he had not had an
opportunity to contribute to the
drafting of it
so it was the opp as opposed to Mr D
Tomaso you think who you were speaking
to about I'm pretty sure I'm I'd have to
check the emails but I I wasn't
I mean I was certainly conveying to Mr D
Tomaso that this is something that we
were considering and there was a
parallel event I think I should note it
for the record
um
so he knew that I was talking to Marcel
Bodega he had given me the name
uh and he knew that you know the general
idea of what I was
um trying to bring forward
on the day of Friday the 11th Ontario
um did their emergency order which I I
didn't know about he called me in the
morning and informed me
um and then later in the day he called
me and he said that they were planning
to do enforcement uh over the weekend on
the Windsor bridge the Ambassador Bridge
and that is a stepping stone to that
enforcement they were going to adopt
this idea of offering a meeting
um and that Minister Jones Sylvia Jones
was interested in making that offer and
would the federal government join
the Ontario government and making that
offer and I uh I signaled that that was
not possible we had yet to discuss
engagement at the federal level
um and so you know there was no way on
an hour's notice that he was going to
get a decision to sign on but he he sent
me a draft letter that
um uh which is referred to here uh that
they were going to use with the
protesters the opp was going to use with
the protesters on the Ambassador Bridge
so it was a kind of a parallel
exercise
which was really an independent exercise
of the Ontario government
but in a very similar way to what was
put forward to the cabinet table the
next day okay and so when you
communicated to him that the the winds
you could get the federal government to
sign on to Windsor that was a matter of
timing as opposed to a position being
conveyed that's right okay
because they were going to do it that
evening
and there was also um we've heard
evidence about another potential sort of
Engagement uh possibility which is the
mayor of ottawa's uh a sort of deal that
was that was happening to potentially
move some trucks up to Wellington Street
Etc that was playing around in around
the same time what was your awareness of
of that at the time
I had no awareness of it until it was
fed a complete uh when the city manager
Steve canalecos called me and said we'd
made a deal
uh with a representative somebody
ostensibly representing the protesters
to move these trucks and the mayor is
sending a letter
so would it be fair to say that there's
sort of these different branches of
potential engagement going on
um with not perfect sight over over all
of them no coordination at all no
coordination at all okay
and what ended up ultimately happening
to the the engagement proposal where did
it go it was not taken up it was
discussed not taken up so it was brought
to cabinet or to the IRG rather that's
correct okay on February 12th but it was
not taken up
so with the benefit of hung site and and
this I'm going to ask you all though
it's completely speculative but what
what effect if any do you think that
might have had
the engagement proposal
I only know what uh inspector bodan was
telling me which was that he believed it
was
um worthy of consideration and you know
given that
the sense he has of the behavior of
protests uh that it might it might have
effect I I
if I were to push it I would say I had
the feeling that it was a very low order
probability that it would have had a
material effect because the protesters
had been in Ottawa in a determined way
for an extended period of time
um and uh you know I think
uh the
uh the the general view here is just
it's part of the toolkit of policing
um and and you want to try and
discourage people from staying in a
protest if enforcement is going to occur
because it's
gonna get rough
so would it be fair it's an option worth
considering but not not a deus ex
machina right
okay um
I know I want to move to to the
invocation of the emergencies act itself
um and appreciating that we'll be
hearing from a lot of people on this
topic I'm going to Target my questions
quite specifically
um
uh you mentioned in our interview that
uh the the emergencies act started to be
seriously considered around February
11th is that about right in your
recollection
yeah I could go back a day maybe okay
well why don't you just tell us how your
recollection of of how it sort of came
onto the radar okay so the emergencies
Act
uh has a history
um in in discussions
um and rooted in the in the in the
pandemic where uh in at one point in the
pandemic the federal government
conducted consultations on whether the
emergencies act would be a useful tool
to help address the pandemic at the time
it was determined that that was not the
case so I was always sort of in the back
of people's minds and it came up in
meetings uh along the way
um and uh as as something that we should
bear in mind
serious consideration of the use of the
emergencies Act
was
began in a lot of part of the week of
February
6th or seventh and then became you know
a
matter for discussion and decision after
that
okay and I understand that Public Safety
was was asked to put provide its input
on potential measures that could be
helpful under the emergencies Act is
that right
uh all departments
um involved in this in the in these um
in in managing the protests was that
were asked for ideas that would provide
additional tools
um to uh police
um to uh uh and and generally to um
deter protests and and cause them to
de-escalate
um
uh so Public Safety we were using the
information that we gained from our
regular consultations and our calls with
Federal provincial colleagues
um so an issue for instance of note
there is the use of tow trucks
um other parts of the public safety
portfolio such as the RCMP provided
independent views in terms of what might
be added to an emergency measure uh
order
emergencies act order
um and um other departments did as well
so this would have been a topic of
discussion at the dmox happening in
around that time that's correct
okay
um
Mr quote can we pull up SSM can
50399 please
so this is an email and you weren't on
this email so uh but it reports
something you said it's it's from Mike
Keenan who's the deputy minister of
transport to Kevin plesso ADM a
transport and it's reporting on the
February 13th Dimock and you'll see
um emergencies does that act as fast
don't need to pass anything Rob and I
argued Rob being you here I believe I
believe
that the emergencies act can backfire in
building more energy what did you mean
by that
well we were having a discussion uh
around the pros and cons of using the
emergencies act and one of the concerns
that I had at the time was of the
potential for serious violence so in
fact one of the reasons to invoke the
Act was also a concern in terms of what
happens when you evoke it
um and and if it were uh to
um lead people to become
violent then that would be you know an
an undesirable outcome so we were that
was just one of the many considerations
we were discussing
so essentially it might do more harm
than good by by inciting rather than
calming that's right okay
um another document related topic PB can
four zeros 1147 please
okay I scroll down a little bit please
until we see something that says these
are okay an email from Mr Stewart
page five please
okay there we go
so this is forward a bit in time but
it's on the same topic
um this is in preparation for us it says
some technical briefing remarks that Mr
Rochelle was due to give on February
15th about the emergencies act once it
had been invoked
um and Mr Stewart your comments here are
these are okay but we'll be duplicative
I expect of what Justice will say and
rather short of substance if possible we
need to weave in a few more for
instances that suggest how law
enforcement authorities and the cbsa as
relevant will deploy the new powers EG
intercept and turn away attempted
blockades from critical infrastructure
facilitate synthesis of local police and
the RCMP and then you say I'm afraid I
don't have a lot of great ideas because
there aren't a lot of significant
benefits but we have to try to tote PS
portfolio specifics as much as we can
so can you tell us what you were
expressing here vis-a-vis the the
measures that were being implemented
can I get the time stamp on that email
please
sure
February 14th 11 12 p.m okay
um
so uh
I believe that I underestimated
the impact of the emergencies Act
and that in in aggregate the measures
that it contained had a material benefit
and this was not uh this was me reacting
to what I'd seen drafted and feeling
that um I hadn't really got a handle on
how it would be implemented
um and also me saying you know to Mr
Rocha you're in these technical
briefings uh and you're representing
Minister Mendocino and you've got to
talk to the elements of his portfolio
that are going to be operationalizing
these these powers can you actually
explain what it what that technical
briefing is
sure
following the indication of the ACT I
was given the responsibility to lead a
number of government officials into a
series of technical briefs that occurred
over the course of I want to say three
possibly four days
those briefs included uh briefing
leaders of opposition parties
in fact culminating in I think we
briefed all members of the Senate and
there and Senators offices
um and and we we essentially offered up
as many technical briefs as necessary to
explain why the Act was evoked and how
it would be implemented so I was chosen
as given my position and my role with
regard to national security policy uh as
the the main
of the um of the brief but included with
me were members of cbsa RCMP uh
Department of Finance Department of
Transport and of course uh
Department of Justice okay
so they're essentially explanatory
technical brief here I mean sort of an
explanatory this is how what it is this
is how it works kind of briefing I
should point out I think we also did uh
offered same technical briefs for
members of the media
we do technical briefs a lot
particularly when we table legislation
technique that's helpful
um
so just to take you back then to Mr Mr
Stewart to what you were saying uh would
it be fair to say that at the time uh so
shortly before and immediately after the
Act was invoked you had some hesitancy
about it
I saw pros and cons
and then you said that um
in hindsight you think you
underestimated the utility of the
emergencies act can you tell us a bit
more about why that is not why you
underestimated but why you say that it
wasn't an underestimate
well it's a judgment only because
um
the police have uh attested to the value
of the act in terms of getting the
protests to disperse in particularly in
Ottawa but generally speaking there was
within two weeks uh very little
manifestation of those kinds of protests
around the country so I think
um it's just it's essentially on the
basis of the fact that others have uh
come forward to say that this was a tool
that they in the end used and found
useful okay
and you're speaking they're not just of
Ottawa but of the situation across the
country yeah
absolutely
okay um another topic I want to touch on
briefly and I appreciate that time is
short is uh something you noted in your
interview was
the consultation with the provinces he
said some of the consultation was
discounted because it wasn't premised on
whether the government was going to
decide to invoke the ACT
what did you mean by that comment
I can pull up the reference if it's
helpful
um
well I'm going to uh
infer that
um the what it represents is the view
that uh you know we had been
actively engaged for over two weeks
uh with a variety of concerned parties
including police of jurisdiction the
RCMP Federal provincial officials and we
were
um
not on the face of it asking the
question should we invoke the
emergencies act we were asking what
tools do you need what are you facing in
terms of challenges how can we to work
together to overcome these challenges
and so we
deemed that to be consultation
on the of what was ultimately the
decision to invoke the act because it
was about the substance of that decision
okay
um
so when Mr D tommaso testified last week
and I can bring up the references if we
need them but
he noted that uh you spoke to him on
February 13th and essentially gave him a
heads up if I could put it that way uh
told him or advised him that the federal
government was considering invoking the
emergencies act do you recall that
conversation
not in its detail but yes I would have
talked to him and and I do accept that I
would have said to him it's on the table
okay
um
another thing I'll come back to that in
a second but another thing he noted you
said was that the provincial Declaration
of emergency that had come in on
February 11th quote unquote had more
teeth than the provisions in the in the
Federal Emergency act do you recall that
and and what you were speaking about
then well
again more by way of inference than by
you know kind of clear memory I would
say I was conveying to him that
I would have been let me back up and say
I would have been
trying to be a good colleague with a
provincial colleague
uh but not at uh the expense of
betraying any federal uh decisions or or
you know kind of thinking
um in in a in a political sense I would
I would just have been trying to keep
him apprised of for the State of Affairs
and I would have said to him I believe
that you know there are pros and cons of
invoking the act because that was my
view and one of the one of the cons
which had been noted in other
discussions was the fact that the
penalties under the emergencies act are
not very big
it's like five thousand dollars on
indictment uh six months in jail
whereas the Ontario order which was put
out on the Friday
uh contained very significant penalties
hundreds a hundred thousand dollars
um and so as a form of deterrence to
anybody thinking of joining a protest it
was a clearly a more a substantive tool
but that wasn't the only that that was
really just one of a number of
considerations
so the reference to had more teeth was
specifically in reference to the Penalty
to the penalties yes
um
are you aware of any other discussions
with provincial officials uh on the 13th
or before the invocation of the
emergencies act and in which they were
notified that the Act was under
consideration not aware
so the the other thing that Mr Di Tomaso
mentioned was that you had a call with
him the following morning I believe on
February 14th
and on that call he inquired as to
whether the Act was going to be the
emergencies Act was going to be invoked
that day and his comment on the notes
was silence exclamation mark
um so I'm gathering that you said
nothing at that point about whether it
was going to be invoked can you just
explain a little bit how that
conversation went
um
well I can't really give you the blow by
blow I
um this would have been a normal
conversation to touch base on what's the
status of things whereas enforcement how
is how are things going with the opp
um and uh I would have been because on
that morning I believe the Prime
Minister held a first Minister's call
to formally consult on the invocation of
the act and I was aware that that was
going to take place and I didn't want to
do anything that would get in the way of
that conversation
um so I was not in a position as I said
before to convey anything about what the
state of federal thinking was at that
time
okay
um we're fast forward now to to the
issue of revocation so Mr clerk if I can
ask you to pull up SSM can zero five
zeros429
okay so just to situate us a little bit
you told us in the interview that
between invocation and revocation the
government was tracking developments
across the country at the ports of entry
and receiving input from the RCMP as to
what powers were being used whether they
were necessary
um
Mr Clark can we just scroll down a bit
here until we get to
an email from Rob Stewart
okay so I will see these email probably
a couple of times over the course of the
next couple of weeks but this is a
discussion that's happening between
officials including yourself Jody Thomas
the nsia several officials from PCO Mike
Keenan transport and others
um
about what considerations to go should
go into revocation and when the ACT
should be revoked and your comment here
is your quick comment my quick comment
is that why while these are probably all
worthy considerations they focus too
much on the utility of the act and not
its proportionality in other words we
need to assess the threat in terms of
serious violence not in terms of whether
the truckers are hanging around what
were you attempting to to convey here to
your colleagues
uh
well I think
in the back of my mind was uh the
grounds for invoking the ACT
um and uh they are that's a high bar
uh which ministers decided was met and
uh in that context serious violence was
an important element to his economic
violence economic uh impacts as well but
but but particularly from a public
safety point of view
um the uncertainty and risk of serious
violence was an important uh
consideration
uh and so given that that was the reason
for invoking the ACT I thought it should
be the reason for considering revoking
it okay so essentially bring revocation
right back to invocation coming forward
same grounds
okay that takes us to essentially the
end of our time together today
um but I'll just before before leaving
completely ask you is there anything
that we haven't covered in the last two
and a half hours that you think we
should have or anything else you would
like to say
about the events
I'd just like to do a technical
clarification on intel if I may of
course for the record
um because it's used in many different
ways and when we spoke about it earlier
today I conveyed the impression that was
all classified and very you know kind of
secretive and in fact Intel is a vast
spectrum of things and one of the issues
um that has surfaced in this context
uh and more generally frankly is
um the compilation of intelligence in
the general sense from not just you know
use of our intelligence agencies but
from open sources is a a real challenge
um and it's one that we
um are grappling with today and so uh
you know intelligence
uh is is something that is um uh was
underneath the rationale for invoking
the ACT was the lack of good Intel as to
what was going on and when I say that I
don't mean
top secret I mean a compilation of
information from any possible source
so so sort of it
uh
can you elaborate on what was lacking
essentially any information about this
the the uh plans and intentions of
protesters around the country and that
was a result of inability to gather that
information or was it at the Gatherings
level or the sharing level or it may
have been both
um it was certainly in the context of
having a clear line of sight
and when I say plans and intentions I
mean to convoys and slow roles and
obstructing
um you know critical infrastructure I
don't mean the causes that they were
espousing that was quite clear
okay
so maybe some lessons to be learned in
the information gathering sharing and
and line of sight
thank you
situation of those are my questions
okay thank you so uh we can now start
with the as the cross-examinations
so first uh
I'd like to call on the Convoy
organizers
morning for the record my name is
Brendan Miller I'm counsel to Freedom
Corp which is the organization that
represents the protesters that were in
Ottawa in January and February of 2022.
thank you for coming here today and
testifying first before I begin sir I am
going to be referring to one document
that I believe I need to leave before I
do so it has been referred to in the
notice I gave already but because it is
a witness statement with a witness who's
not yet testified but it's relevant to
this it's
wts000060 it's the statement from the
thesis panel uh the relevance
materiality of that is is that these
gentlemen were the essentially the
consumers of information and there is a
lot of statements in there with respect
to what the government was told and when
and I'm intending to put that to them so
I would ask for leave to be able to
refer to that document through my exam
okay seeing no objection that's fine
thank you sir so uh just to begin uh
Deputy Master Stewart you've been the
deputy master of Public Safety since
December of 2019 is that fair until just
recently yes until just recently all
right and when you took over that
portfolio I take it that you had
familiarized yourself with the process
of law enforcement and intelligence
agencies uh with respect to
investigations is that fair
let's say I learned on the job you
learned on the job right and because
prior to that you were with Finance is
that correct that's correct right and uh
prior to your appointment into the
portfolio of Public Safety is it fair to
say that other than financial
intelligence that you had not worked in
the area of law enforcement or the
intelligence field is that fair not
entirely not entirely the world of
Finance they're worth there were
criminal issues right exactly so
Financial intelligence within uh the
criminal sphere of the Ministry of
Finance anti-money laundering Securities
crimes right right and so in your
evidence here today already you've
spoken about the thresholds for
investigations uh in your Chief and I
want to discuss that for a moment okay
so you understand I take it that law
enforcement and intelligence agencies in
Canada the threshold that you're
speaking of with respect to opening an
investigation it's referred to in Canada
as Reasonable Suspicion are you familiar
with that term
simple grounds to suspect yes yeah so
there's and we'll get into that and you
can agree with me that that's a pretty
low threshold is it not in in law
enforcement terms
I would not agree okay and you're aware
that the law recognizes though that
Reasonable Suspicion essentially
requires more than a mere suspicion but
something less than a belief based on
reasonable grounds is that your
understanding
I I would say it's reasonable grounds to
suspect right and so reasonable grounds
to suspect is different than reasonable
grounds generally you understand that
correct no all right so you you don't
know the difference between reasonable
grounds and reasonable grounds to
suspect
I don't understand where what you're
trying so there's two there's two
thresholds in Canada within respect to
investigations criminally and in
intelligence we have the lower threshold
of reasonable suspicion which you call
reasonable ground suspect and then
reasonable grounds which is also called
reasonable and probable grounds
reasonable probable grounds is a higher
threshold than Reasonable Suspicion you
understand that
I would have gone the other way pardon
me I would have put it the other way so
this just shows what I know so your
understanding is that Reasonable
Suspicion is a higher threshold than
reasonable grounds
if you're going to suspect something
you're going to have a particular act in
mind
okay and it's the same thing with
reasonable grounds right you also have a
particular act in mind can you agree
that reasonable grounds require some
reliable information that there is a
reason to believe a person or group
could have committed an offense or pose
a threat to the security of Canada can
you agree with that yes all right so
whereas Reasonable Suspicion it just
requires a reasonable suspicion right
it's a lesser threshold than reasonable
grounds can you can you agree
and you know that I'm I'm I'm I'm a
little uh uh concerned about getting
into a discussion about legal
terminology in which I'm not an expert
all right and so can you agree though
that it is thesis who is the main agency
that administers the thesis act yes all
right and they're the agency that's
primarily responsible for assessing if
there's a section to cease to sack
threat to the security of Canada right
yes
and under section 12 of The Thesis acts
thesis is only required to have a
reasonable suspicion but there is a
section to cesus act threat to open an
investigation is that fair
yes and they're not required to meet the
higher threshold of reasonable grounds
to open an investigation
well for section 12 they they would have
to get a warrant
for section 12 and that's reasonable
suspicion that's what it says again I'm
not an expert when it comes to uh thesis
uh when cesus
uh
gets a warrant they have to bring a case
to a judge a federal judge right so
there's going to be more than just
reasonable grounds in that case okay so
can I bring up uh WTS
000060 please
and can we scroll down to page five
okay and can we scroll down to The
Heading intelligence
and just the first paragraph will give
you a moment to read that
would you help me with the pronunciation
of uh Minister David's last name we've
all been debating about how to pronounce
it
properlyo all right so David Vino he
stated that at no point of the service
being cesus assessed the protests in
Ottawa or elsewhere those referred to as
the freedom convo and related protests
and blockades in January and February
2022 constituted a threat to the
security of Canada as defined in section
two of the thesis act and that ceases
cannot investigate activities
constituting lawful protests and I take
it uh you were advised of this correct
correct all right and can we scroll down
then to
uh page seven
and go to The Heading foreign
interference
so
director venue explained that the use of
the term foreign influence under section
two of the cesus ACT refers to foreign
State interference as the term is used
within the National Security Community
cesus assessed there was no indication
of foreign State interference occurring
in the course of the protest caesus did
not assess that any foreign State
supported the protest through funding
that foreign States deployed covert or
over disinformation techniques or that
any foreign State actors attempted to
enter into Canada to support the protest
and I take it that you were advised of
that by thesis and director venue is
that correct that is correct all right
and if we can go down to page number
eight
and the heading recommendation to
cabinet
their director venue states that he
learned that the EA reference the threat
definition set out in section two of
thesis act once the federal government
began to seriously consider invoking the
EA between February 10th and 13th he
requested that the service prepare a
threat assessment on the risks
associated with the invocation of the EA
he felt an obligation to clearly convey
the services position that there did not
exist a threat to the security of Canada
as defined by the services legal mandate
the threat assessment prepared by the
service was that the invocation of the
emergency's legislation risked further
inflaming imv rhetoric and individuals
holding accelerationist or
anti-government views you were told that
is that correct that is correct all
right
so can we now please bring up document
number
ts.nsc.can dot zero zero one zero zero
zero zero zero two zero six underscore
Rel underscore zero zero zero one
so in this document which has already
actually in evidence I just want to
scroll down to page five please
so there again on February 3rd ceases
assessed there's no indications of known
imve actors we're planning to engage in
violence and it's on February 13th I
believe that this is the the document
that director vigno is referring to that
states that you know it could have been
a risk if you invoke the emergencies act
to making things worse is that correct
yes okay and you knew about that
I did right and so did cabinet they knew
about all of this correct yes right
okay if I could bring up uh the next
document
which
is going to be uh TS
NSC dot c a n dot zero zero one dot zero
zero zero zero zero one six zero
underscore Rel underscore zero zero zero
one
now before I I get into this uh you can
agree that it was clear to both you and
cabinet that ceases did not have
reasonable suspicion that there existed
a section to cesus act threat during the
protest is that correct
it is was clear to me and I believe it
was clear to ministers right I can't say
with that with authority over and I also
understand uh that the Canadian Security
establishment the CSE they never advised
you or the government or cabinet that
they had identified as section two cesus
act threat either is that correct
that would be correct right and both the
RCMP and the opp uh from at least their
evidence and things we've seen to date
they never identified or advised the
government that there was a section to
cesus act threat right the best of my
knowledge no right and so
the entire intelligence apparatus
and law enforcement apparatus within
Canada
tells the cabinet and the government
that there is no section two cesus act
threat is that right
no that is not right
csis
and I I you know
director Vino will be here to speak
speak for himself cesus assessed
according to their standards under their
act
nobody else was assessing under the
standards under the thesis act you asked
me did they tell anybody it had met a
standard they weren't they wouldn't use
the thesis act that wouldn't be their
tool they would be looking at broader
National Security issues
okay so what intelligence
Bureau or agency or law enforcement
agency
told the government here's the evidence
of reasonable and probable grounds
are reasonable grounds
of a section to cesus act threat and you
know I take it now because it's advised
to you that that's required to invoke
the emergencies act it's in the
documents you were advised of that yes
right so what agency gave you
the evidence and the intelligence
that said hey we have reasonable grounds
of a section 2 thesis act right there
wasn't one was there
so let me
um explain uh nobody bringing advice to
the table other than thesis is assessing
uh that against that threat nobody
advising the cabinet the cabinet is
making that decision and their
interpretation of the law
is what governs here and the advice they
get
and their their decision was evidently
that the threshold was met and I
understand that but you understand that
when ministers or administrative
agencies Etc are entitled to make a
statutory decision whether or not a
statutory requisite is met they do so
based on the evidence that is before
them in the submissions before them you
know that
and indeed they had they had a lot of
evidence right and
you have the RCMP you have csis you have
the entire intelligence apparatus in the
federal government
and none of them
said that this threshold was met did
they
they weren't asked okay
so and with respect to the the ministers
making the decision when you're talking
about ministers you're talking about the
elected executive correct I am all right
so the prime minister
among others right to your knowledge
what training and National Security and
law enforcement does the Prime Minister
have
I couldn't answer that question yes can
you agree with me that he doesn't have
any to your knowledge I couldn't answer
the question I'm sorry all right and
what about uh Minister uh medicinal uh
he he I understand has training as a
crown prosecutor at least is that right
that was his former job yes right and
Minister Blair he was the chief of
police for the Toronto uh Police Service
that's correct right and when did
Minister Blair first tell you that he
was thinking about invoking the
emergencies Act
Minister Blair didn't tell me it came up
in discussions at the officials level
and then it came up in discussions at
the ministerial level there's a record
not yet in evidence that states that
ministers Blair's strategy was from
February 4th on to invoke the
emergencies act were you aware of that
no
okay
can you please bring up the uh next
document which is uh oh we have the the
input and I'll just ask you about these
these are the if you can scroll up to
the top please
I take it that this is the input that
csis gave to your ministry Public Safety
with respect to the key messages they
thought should be put out with respect
to the Convoy is that right
uh presumably I don't have a date on
this document so I'm not really sure
where it falls in the overuscued things
okay so I'm just going to go through it
with you then you're you're out of time
so you're gonna have to do it very
quickly right
I'll be quick this document you agree
that none of the messaging from this
document was actually incorporated into
the messaging from Public Safety
was it ah I really I wasn't a
spokesperson for Public Safety my
colleague maybe right and I have to be
quick so I just want to bring up one
last document uh and that's
ssm.can.0001079 underscore Rel
dot zero zero zero one
no that's not the correct document it's
okay I'll deal with it with another
Witness
so thank you very much for answering my
questions
okay well rather than or maybe I could
ask the city of Ottawa hey are you going
to be taking your 10 minutes or if
because we can do it after lunch if you
prefer
I'm contending to do it now or after
lunch I think we will need our 10
minutes and there's a chance there's a
better chance we get right under the 10
minute Mark if we have the lunch break
to shorten it up and tighten it up okay
but I am content to go now if that's
your preference yeah well we'll take the
lunch break we'll take a another one of
our long lunches uh
we'll come back at uh two o'clock and
have an hour and five minutes for lunch
the commission is in recess until two
o'clock
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
order order a lot
the commission is reconvened
just
okay uh is there a point of
clarification I believe
yes thank you uh Mr commissioner just a
small clarification coming out of the
overview report that was presented this
morning the first cabinet meeting of
full cabinet uh in relation to the
Convoy was held on February 13th and not
February 3rd
thanks
okay thank you so with that
clarification city of Ottawa please
ready if you're okay to go ahead yes
foreign
my name is Ann tardif I'm one of the
lawyers for the city of Ottawa can I ask
Mr clerk to pull up PB Dot
nsc.can.409542
and this is an email chain and if we
could well you're not on it gentlemen
but Mr uh
decal Bob have I got that correct thank
you you're both nodding is on the Chain
I understand he was interviewed along
with you and some of your other
colleagues by the Commission in this
case right
and we'll need an audible answer sorry
and he is at Public Safety as well
correct yes and if we scroll down to the
top of page two Mr Clark
and actually just scroll up a little bit
just so we get that email up a little
bit higher there we go this is an email
from an individual with the solicitor
General's office in Ontario to your
colleague Mr treehern among others at
Public Safety correct
yes and he says hi uh Trevor and Derek
your colleagues uh I was hoping for some
clarity on a few RFA meaning requests
for assistance process related item
based on some references I have been
seeing in recent media coverage for
Ottawa scrolling down to number two
which is the one that interests me
it's titled requests for law enforcement
support under Ontario Police Services
act this article and there's a link that
we can't access says that the feds
approved a request from Ottawa for RCMP
support I would have assumed such a
request would have required a provincial
Minister request but clearly it didn't
as in did not I am fine with that but
want to check on process was that a
political decision that bypass process
or
this type of request could be made by
either a municipal or Provincial Police
Service so scrolling back up Mr clerk
this is a question as we've seen that
the solicitor General's office is
putting to your colleagues and I believe
the date is February 4th if we could
scroll up Mr Clerk
yep February 4th and if we scroll all
the way up to the top
you'll see there's an internal email
chain within Public Safety and your
colleague Mr daklebab says this is far
from being solved still discussions on
their way to clarify question two which
is the one I just read you see that
there
yes
so fair to say that at least as at
February 4th uh within Public Safety
there were still discussions in terms of
the process for Ops or Ottawa requesting
law enforcement resources from the RCMP
correct yes okay
um now Mr Stewart
I heard you're saying your testimony
that almost right from the beginning
right after that first weekend Chief
slowly was adamant that he needed more
resources than he had at his disposal to
dismantle the occupation correct correct
and you're aware that on February 7th I
won't turn it up the mayor of Ottawa and
Miss Dean's who was then the chair of
the Police Services Board wrote a letter
to the federal government asking for
1800 additional officers to support the
Ops correct correct
okay so I'd like to go that was on
February 7th I'd like to now turn to a
readout of the SSE Committee of cabinet
which I take it as a committee that
deals with safety security and
emergencies I got the acronym right okay
and Mr clerk it's ssm.can.nsc.402661
and this should be a February 9th
meeting of the SSE Committee of cabinet
it's a readout and you'll see there the
date February 9th correct
I believe the committee meeting was on
the 8th but okay so the committee
meeting was on the eighth the readout is
being circulated on the ninth Fair sure
can we go to the bottom of page one
please
right there thank you Mr clerk do you
see it says RCMP resources deployed are
you with me Mr Stewart I am 304 40
members on duty every day within our CMP
mandate and that would be in part the
protective mandate that you described
earlier right yes so to protect Federal
assets and people that's right increase
in protective posture associated with
RCMP mandate and then this is what I
wanted to draw your attention to it says
50 uniformed resources in support of Ops
mandates since last weekend so from
January 31st to February 8th
um roughly 50 uniformed RCMP officers in
Ottawa Fair yes under ops command I
should say ferris and then it says
working to deploy another 200 people on
new plan with Ops and partners right yes
and then finally it says OPP setting up
integrated planning sale to review ops
plan and that was going to to include
two RCMP members as well correct yes if
we can scroll to page three please the
second Bullet at the top of the page
there we go again we see that the plan
and this is the ops plan
is going to be subject to review and
verification by OPP and others
presumably the RCMP correct yes and that
had to happen before additional
resources were committed to Ottawa by
the RCMP correct
I don't believe that's true okay let's
keep going then so I'd like to turn then
to the first meeting of the IRG which I
understood occurred on February 10th
correct right and that's day 13 of the
Convoy or occupation here in Ottawa
correct
yes okay Mr clerk if we could turn to
ssm.nsc.can.50209 please
okay and if we could turn then to page
five please halfway through the first
complete paragraph yet so you'll see
there it says
um the RCMP it's about six lines down do
you see that thank you Mr Clark the RCMP
has provided all recourses requested by
the Ops do you see that there I do but I
think we can agree that the the 1800 or
any significant portion thereof
requested on February 7th was not yet in
Ottawa by this date February 10th
correct correct correct
um and then if we scroll to page six
please halfway through the page
right there the commissioner of the RCMP
do you see that Mr Stewart I Do
indicated that Windsor Remains the
number one priority and I don't think
that's that's quite contentious this is
February 10th
um but that that was what the
commissioner indicated on that date
right right and I put it to you that
that's the reason that the IRG was not
convened until this date that is until
Windsor had occurred the blockade at
Windsor
I would not agree okay and then why did
it take 13 days for the situation in
Ottawa before the IRG to be convened
uh that's not a question that I can
answer
um other than to say that
um there was extensive involvement at
the Federal
officials and political level right from
the start
so when the Prime Minister chose to
convene the IRG is a decision that you
should ask either him or colleagues at
PCO about okay we'll do
um I guess we'll jump ahead now to add a
second to IRG meeting I only have a few
minutes left
um we can turn it up it's SSM NSC can
50214 Mr Clerk
if we can go to page six please at the
bottom
in the last two sentences
um there continue to be challenges and I
should say the date it's February 12th
this is the second meeting of the IRG
there continue to be challenges working
with the integrated planning team in
Ottawa around communication and I think
that word should be decisiveness of the
Ops Chief every request made by the Ops
has been fulfilled with RCMP Personnel
exceeding the 250 agreed upon in the mou
and maybe this comes back to what you
were saying earlier Mr Stewart that you
thought more had been provided than that
200 even before the plan had been
finalized but I take it we can agree
that the large number requested the
number that was eventually needed in
order to dismantle the occupation was
still not in Ottawa by this date on
February 12th
to the best of my knowledge that is true
right and that was the number that had
been requested on February 7th crack the
1800 from both levels of government
that's not here yet at this point in
time correct
uh yes that's correct right and you
mentioned and Mr uh pardon me
commissioner if I could just have one
minute I think I'm out but I'm wrapping
up
thank you you said earlier that it took
several weeks on condition you speak
slower okay understood
um I heard you say earlier Mr Stewart
that it took several weeks for the right
chemistry to be achieved at the
integrated Command Center recall saying
that I do
and I take it the ICC established
unified command over the operation to
dismantle the Convoy right that's my
understanding between all three police
forces Ops OPP and RCMP right right and
you describe Chief slowly as a strong
personality right I did you had heard it
was challenging to get him to relinquish
his authority that's what I had heard
and I expect we will hear evidence that
commissioner lucky of the RCMP told her
counterpart at the opp on February 5th
so during that first week that the
federal government was either losing or
had lost confidence in the Ops did you
share that view
no
did you hear of any such concerns either
from the commissioner or from ministers
I heard concerns about the ability of
the Ops to manage the situation
definitely
um now you've said that the Ops should
look to the should have looked to the
opp first right to fulfill its need
technically speaking although I want to
be clear on this point this is this is
not a situation in which you go by the
book
fair enough I think you also said the
RCMP was always ready and willing to
assist I did and I appreciate the
religistical concerns paperwork swearing
them in getting them to Ottawa if
they're deployed elsewhere right right
but fair to say the real issue was what
was perceived at least as the Ops lack
of a plan right
that was a major impediment and what you
understood to be Chief slowly's
reticence to relinquish Authority
because he was controlling the approval
of the plan that's what you understood
you can put the two points together I'm
not sure that I was I can testify in any
uh direct way that that was the case I
mean two things seem to be facts that I
was hearing okay the relationship
between the two you can't put together
that's correct and the reason I said put
to you that the Ops or that the
government of Canada wanted the Ops to
look to the opp first was that it hoped
the opp could resolve the issues around
leadership and the plan
I I don't know that
thank you
okay next if I could call on the
Ottawa Police Service please
good afternoon to you both my name is
Jessica Barrow and I'm one of the
council to the Ottawa Police Service
my questions will be directed to you Mr
Stewart
um I just want to start by discussing
some of the information that was known
to Public Safety prior to the arrival of
the Convoy and I know you went through
some of that already with commission
Council but I wanted to clarify a couple
of things so you indicated in your
weight witness statement that there were
challenges in obtaining information in
relation to the Convoy because the
novelty of the events made it difficult
to distinguish between things seen on
social media that were credible versus
not credible is that correct that is
correct
and in fact you testified this morning
that because of the organic nature of
the events it was difficult to obtain
what you referred to as quote good Intel
okay that's correct and you would agree
with me that these would have been
challenges that all uh law enforcement
agencies would have been facing as well
correct yes
so commission Council took you to one of
the key points documents and I want to
take you through a couple as well I'll
start with January 26th and Mr clerk the
number is pb.can.701.
foreign
to page two
towards the bottom of the page
and the third to bottom bullet
it says some supporters suggested they
would not leave Ottawa until vaccine
mandates for public servants Canadian
Travelers and cross-border truckers are
lifted do you recall seeing that I do
and so this suggests that there was at
least some information available to you
and others uh to the effect that some
protesters may not leave Ottawa correct
yes
but again as you've indicated uh with
open source information it's difficult
to know whether that information was
credible or not correct correct
and so from your perspective this
information was not enough
to raise any kind of alarm bells that
this was going to be the three-week
occupation that we ultimately saw here
in Ottawa correct correct
and the RCMP was presumably privy to
this same information as well
I would I would believe so yes
and you indicated in your witness
statement um at page 10 and I'm happy to
turn it up if necessary but I suspect
you'll recall saying this that if the
RCMP had intelligence that the Convoy
was planning on becoming entrenched in
Ottawa and failed to report that
information up to Public Safety that you
would have considered that to be
problematic correct
yes and notwithstanding the fact that we
see that there's at least some
information to suggest that protesters
might stay the RCMP was similarly not
raising any kind of alarm Bells around
that correct that is correct and if you
scroll to the top of the document
I if you go down yes the first sentence
there the following relates to a planned
peaceful demonstration in Ottawa on 28
29 January
so even with that information in mind
you're still planning for you know a
couple of days that's correct okay
so I want to turn back to the one on the
27th which you did speak about briefly
with commission Council that number Mr
clerk is pb.can 703
foreign
that's perfect thank you my friend took
you to one of the bullets in the bolded
section that we see here but I want to
turn to some of the bullets that precede
that one bullet
so what we can see here is a number of
directions that appear to have been
provided by Ops in relation to where the
trucks could park when they arrive right
right and is it your understanding that
this information was coming from
intersect
that would be my understanding okay
and so what we see is a number of
different options the first one we see
is from the West they're being directed
to Sir John A McDonald Parkway correct
yes and then following this Kent and
Metcalf exits can be used
um the George etchin Parkway can be used
and then ultimately we see in the third
bullet there that Wellington will be
closed but there will be three lanes
dedicated to the demonstration correct
yes and so you were provided information
prior to the Convoy's arrival that the
ops plan was to allow at least some of
the truckers to park downtown correct
yes
and I'm just going to bring you to the
intersect document
um that one is pb.can
one two three four
if you could scroll down a little bit
please
so this is presumably then the intersect
information that ultimately we see
coming through that key points document
is that fair I believe so and so again
we see here that there is information to
suggest that that ops plan involved
having some truckers Park on Wellington
correct correct
and so um
again this didn't raise any kind of
alarm Bells from your perspective that
this was the plan for Ops right
no alarm Bells and again this
information would have been available to
our CMP
yes and similarly RCMP didn't raise any
concerns with you in relation to the
plan not with me
and you understood at this point and I'm
happy to turn back to the previous
document if necessary but I think you
would agree that this was a group at
this point that was cooperative and from
your perspective was exercising their
Democratic right to Peaceful protests
correct correct
um Mr clerk could we turn to SAS
um 12 please
so these appear to be the minutes or
notes from a deputy Minister's call on
February 7th do you recall that meeting
I do so I just want to take you through
a couple of the comments that you've
made uh in here on February 7th the
first bullet references a protest of
significant proportions we have not seen
before
do you recall saying that
I do and if we can go down to the third
bullet point please
um and in there we see setting a
standard to worry about setting standard
for Behavior how to go above the norms
and laws so I take it you agree that you
made those comments I do and what you
meant by these comments was that what
Ottawa was seeing was unlike any protest
that any city in Canada had ever seen
before is that correct that is correct
and specifically you were saying that
the behavior of these protesters was
unlike anything seen in previous
protests
that may be too broad a statement
there's certainly the aspect of having
the trucks
um involved and being used to
essentially occupy uh physical spaces
was was the unprecedented part right as
well as the honking some of the
harassment that that we saw in terms of
behavior the behaviors of the the
protesters as well as the trucks I think
and so the protesters were prepared from
your perspective to disregard the laws
as well as the social norms of behavior
that we had come to expect in a city and
other other places as well with respect
to the behavior of protesters is that
fair
yes
and when we walked through we I took you
to two of the key points documents
um and I take it you would agree with me
that the specific references to this
idea of honking or lawlessness or the
the departure from social norms there
wasn't really any indication that the
protesters were going to engage in that
type of behavior is that fair that is
fair
and in fact they as far as you're aware
they weren't engaging in that type of
behavior before they arrived in Ottawa
well there was quite a bit of honking on
the highway but I we did not assume that
they would do anything other than
peacefully protest fair enough
and so you would agree with me then that
the behavior was unexpected
I would
and I don't need to pull it up I don't
think but please correct me if that's
not the case but on page 12 of your
witness statement you indicated that the
other cities that subsequently had
similar events were able to learn from
What was seen in Ottawa do you recall
saying that I do and so you would agree
with me that it's because of what
happened in Ottawa that other cities may
have been able to prepare in a different
way
that is correct
I just have one last issue I want to
raise and that's in relation to the
engagement uh proposal that you went
through with commission Council earlier
and so I wonder if we could pull up OPP
142 Mr Clerk
foreign
we'll see an email between yourself and
inspector Bowden
and that's setting out some
considerations in relation to the
proposal
if we can I think it might be up a
little bit
do you recall seeing this email with all
the considerations yes indeed
and what we see from inspector Bowden is
that he was of the view that this could
constitute a win of sorts for protesters
in in terms of providing an exit
strategy is that do you recall that yes
and would you agree with me that the
comments that come from inspector Bowden
um involve an advocacy for a measured
approach consistent with the national
framework rather than simply resorting
first to enforcement yes
I agree and in your witness statement
you indicated at page 18 that there were
particular difficulties actually to
enforcement operations in Ottawa do you
recall saying that I do and that was
because the protesters were very
entrenched and they were aggressive
towards the police that's correct
and so the proposal was presumably aimed
at trying to change that posture is that
fair that would be true okay
and you indicated in your witness
statement that you did not share The
Proposal with Ops is that right
uh I believe it was shared with Ops
because there was a question about who
would if it were actually approved how
it would be managed and I think Ops was
alerted that their plts their teams
would would be perhaps delivery agents
okay I just I didn't consult Ops you did
not consult them so maybe we'll just
bring up one last document I'm almost
completed Mr commissioner
um OPP 633 just to provide some clarity
on this point so you're asking for more
time if you wouldn't mind yes you can
have a little more time thank you very
much
and so it's just that first email we see
from inspector Bowden uh and he's
indicating that it's the opinion of uh
Deputy Ferguson that the letter go to
her and she will ensure the letter is
disseminated to the proper people so you
would agree with me that deputy chief
Ferguson was both aware and approved
uh this correct I would infer that yes
yes okay thank you those are my
questions and thank you Mr commissioner
okay thank you
next is uh Council for former Chief
slowly
foreign
ER I'm Tom Curry for former Chief slowly
thank you
just have a few questions my colleagues
have covered some of the things I was
going to ask you about so
um
the Mr Stewart you said just a minute
ago in response to one of my friends
that
that
you don't go by the book in a situation
like this
you recall saying that I too and does
that capture the idea that what you were
dealing with during the time
that we are speaking about with the
protests in different locations across
the country was completely without
precedent and there is therefore no
Playbook that you can follow
I would agree with you that we were in
unprecedented and unanticipated
circumstances absolutely
one of the things that
um
that you have spoken to us about in your
statement and and today was
um
the role of various of the of the
federal government entities that concern
National Security recall that yes and
did this did the events in your opinion
uh reach become a national security
threat
they were they were decided to be and
adjudicated to be a national security
threat yes it was at your own View
I was very concerned about the uh the
possibility of physical and um serious
violence Mr Roshan
I would agree yes same opinion yes and
and uh as a consequence of of and of
course as you've described to I think
one of my friends it was not thought to
be a national security threat at the
time that the
convoys began to organize and come to
Ottawa
no
you agree it was not I agree
now
um
when I asked you if I can about
um
the uh
well one one more thing I think you've
probably covered this but former Chief
slowly has described these events as
representing a paradigm shift in in
protest in Canada probably for the
reasons that you've given Mr Steward
concerning the use of of heavy Vehicles
you share that view
yes I do Mr Roshan I would agree yes now
um
the
uh
you've spoken to my friends about she's
slowly's consistent requests for the
need for additional resources do you
agree that those came in two forms first
there was a request for resources to
maintain the safety of the citizens the
protesters and and police service
members who were policing the areas in
Ottawa that were the subject of protest
yes
and second of course the a greater need
for resources in the event that that are
dismantling of the occupation was
required I would agree two two very
separate
ways of thinking of resources you agree
I agree do you also agree that the
second that is the an effort to to bring
public order
and to dismantle an occupation requires
the greater number of resources that you
were eventually speaking about I agree
and everyone understood didn't they that
the Ops itself did not have the
resources needed to do the second thing
agreed and it's true also of course they
didn't even have the resources to do the
first thing because their own members
were were stretched so thin I think you
said I agree
now the this was of course the same
thing that occurred uh in a sense in
both Windsor and Coots and probably
other places in terms of the
under-resourcing of police services
trying to manage those situations is
that true
um
I think
there's a Confluence of events here
obviously the unprecedented nature of
these protests
um did lead us into a situation where
more resources were required I don't
know if that equates to chronically
under-resourcing police because if we we
were better prepared and as as they were
in other cities they didn't need more
officers understood I I suppose that it
it wasn't we know that don't we that
that the the protest in Coots the
blockade in Coots was not prevented by
able to be prevented by our CMP officers
on the ground there
uh it wasn't anticipated and it happened
before they could mobilize and then once
it did once they were the protesters
were there the vehicles were on the road
and stopped then enforcement became very
challenging correct exactly and I think
in fact one of the lessons that was
learned in Coots by by your team I
assume and others was that
an effort an early effort to enforce
failed because protesters resisted and
police were required to fall back do you
recall that happening February 1st I do
and and that that's an indication isn't
it of the challenge of enforcement you
need significant resources to to enforce
that kind of a of a police operation I
would agree now
um in terms quickly of about Windsor
uh do you do you understand that the
Windsor
uh that resources that were requested by
The Windsor Police Service
and by the OPP were pledged by the RCMP
prior to the completion of a plan by The
Windsor Police Service
I don't know the details of that okay I
would I would I would be inclined to
believe that the RCMP would have made a
commitment to support whatever action
would be to be taken in the absence of a
plan just a commitment right and of
course for the reasons that you've given
to one of my friends the circumstances
of the blockade of the Ambassador Bridge
was a significant escalation in the
national security threat wasn't it
absolutely
uh now
the um
of the protests across the country do
you agree that Ottawa was the most
complex
and the most challenging
in a the physical sense I believe that's
true in the economic sense
um not as much fair enough in terms of
the as you say the physical sense or if
one thought about it as a as a security
issue it was the more volatile it had
the the most vehicles and the most
protesters across a larger area is that
fair agreed
now the uh I think you indicated that
there was a time at least when there was
a debate between or perhaps even a
disagreement between Federal and
provincial officials in Ontario that is
about which Police Service was the first
Port of Call for the Ottawa Police
Service to call on is that fair
well we've been showing evidence to that
effect I didn't have that issue with my
colleague all right understood
uh now a couple of other things you were
also aware and I think you've told the
commissioner that enforcement was not
the preferred strategy here in any of
these protest locations negotiation
de-escalation was the preferred strategy
that is always the preferred strategy
and yet the ministers the federal
government ministers with whom you were
interacting were were demanding some
kind of action is that fair
the ministers we were briefing wanted
the situation to be resolved there is no
question about that
and the same was true to your
observation of Municipal officials here
in Ottawa absolutely and of course the
community the residents absolutely a
high level of impatience and a high a
high uh it was a highly uh challenging
situation for the police service and for
chief slowly yes absolutely you observed
and I'm sure you felt it the your the
two of you were in the middle of this
too did can you tell the commissioner
did you yourselves feel enormous
pressure to try to do something to solve
this problem I did Mr Roshan that would
be fair yeah and you observed it across
the spectrum of police services and
other government agents is that fair
that would be fair you agree that Chief
slowly during the time that you were
dealing with him was a passionate
defender of the city's residence and of
the Police Service in trying to find a
solution
I would agree
and acted in good faith in the
performance of his duties I would agree
uh now one one last area if I may
um
Chief slowly had had has described
options that were other than enforcement
and do you agree that commissioner lucky
also expressed a preference for
um
even uh the effort of an interlocutor to
try to negotiate something with
protesters do you recall that no may I
just show you please uh
a um a document then see if you can
assist us because I think you received
it
um you're a member of the uh one of the
acronyms the deputy ministers committee
on operational coordination yes true
dmoc could I please show the witness
um
the interview summary from oh no I won't
need to go to that let me show you the
document PB
c-a-n
five zeros seven five zero
see if this assists your recollection if
you would please Mr Stewart
there's a suffix on that Rel
1.001 I don't know if that's important
to the registrar
there we go thank you do you recognize
this document Trucker's Convoy and
protective services key messages for
dmoc February 3rd at 2 30 pm
well these would be speaking points for
the commissioner I would not have
received her speaking points all right
can you can you confirm for the
commissioner for this commissioner that
you were at this meeting
yes could you please just scroll down if
you would please Mr registrar to a to a
expression that begins I will be honest
second page
ah there it is just to read that if you
if you would Mr Stewart I'll for the
record I'll be honest this may not be
something that can be negotiated out of
or resolved only with enforcement
there may need to be some other
Solutions maybe the engagement of an
interlocutor does that refresh your
recollection that on the 3rd of February
in the afternoon commissioner lucky
raised this concern that there may not
be
a solution through
only through uh enforcement and there
may be other Solutions including an
interlocutor yes it refreshes my memory
and that she said that
I check against delivery but I believe
she did all right
I'm out of time thank you very much
thank you commissioner
thank you next to the Ottawa coalition
of
good afternoon commissioner Mr Stewart
Mr Rochelle my name is Emily tamman I
represent the Ottawa Coalition of
residents and businesses
and I just have a couple of questions
for you arising out of your testimony
today
if I could start with you please sir
you explained that within the broader
intelligence Matrix in Canada that
Public Safety is a consumer of
intelligence right correct
and you indicated this morning that the
government has determined had determined
prior even to the freedom Convoy that
there is a need for a refresh of the
National Security strategy is that right
uh not technically speaking the
government is always looking at uh
policy matters and and it'll be a
decision for for the sitting government
of the day whether or not to publish uh
an update to that strategy but subset to
the National Security strategy there are
a series of other strategies like a
cyber security strategy a critical
infrastructure strategy so we're always
working on those yes okay and the the
current strategy I believe you said
dates back to 2004. the National
Security one yes
and at that time I think you explained
that
um
threats to Canada's national security
were understood to be different than
they are today is that fair indeed I
would say post 911 the very creation of
our department at Public Safety uh
followed and indeed I think that was uh
the impetus for uh Canada's national
security strategy at the time in 2004.
okay and so in pursuing a refresh or in
continually
um you know considering and
reconsidering uh the government's
approach uh it's a recognition that the
current strategy may not be optimal
because it could miss certain kinds of
threats from groups oriented around
certain radical ideologies or even as
you said I think this morning
individuals acting alone on the basis of
a broader range of grievances then the
current strategy might have otherwise
been built for is that fair
I would even go so far as to highlight
the counterterrorism strategy which I
think dates back to 2012 if I'm not
mistaken and uh we're in the process of
refreshing that uh Parliament
parliamentary Committee in the House of
Commons uh for National Security SECU
has recently done a study on
ideologically motivated violent
extremism which came up with 33
recommendations we recently tabled I
believe the government response to that
study and we're in the process of
updating our counterterrorism strategy
that will deal with uh
what you refer to yes okay and you
testified this morning that in the lead
up to the freedom convoys occupation of
Ottawa
there was no reason to see the Convoy as
a national security threat right based
on the intelligence
um that have been produced for you that
would be correct
But ultimately a national security
threat was
um as Mr Stewart articulated I think
adjudicated to exist at least from the
perspective of the federal government
which ultimately led to the invocation
of the emergencies Act Right correct
so as a consumer of intelligence
products then would you agree that the
intelligence product you're provided
with
was flawed in the sense that the threat
posed by the Convoy was grossly
underestimated at every level of Ops OPP
RCMP thesis
I wouldn't say flawed because
intelligence is only as good as a moment
in time when it's collected and you have
to know where to go looking for it and
um at the time all of the various
indications were pointing to a peaceful
protest and so police of jurisdiction
who handle these types of protests on a
regular basis there was no reason to
question
their integrity in terms of their
assessment but as uh as the protests
grew in number across the country and
indeed witnessing the various behaviors
and the entrenchment of the occupation
in Ottawa
and the impacts on uh Canadians Canadian
lives the economy uh the reputation of
the country trading issues supply chain
issues yes it definitely Rose to a
national security concern but but we
can't necessarily know if the issue was
how the available intelligence was
interpreted or if it was actually a
failure of intelligence to actually
see what might have been
in front of law enforcement authorities
is that fair the difficulty is that you
don't know what you don't know and
therefore there are always unknowns
right
so we heard from former Chief Peter
slowly that he believes that there is a
double standard that exists in how
National Security threats are identified
and communicated and that right-wing
extremism and white supremacy are often
not flagged and threat assessments while
radical Islam and Islamic based
terrorism threats are do you agree with
that assessment
I would only agree with it in so much as
perhaps historically there might have
been a bias but I believe uh more
recently as I've as I've indicated
ideologically motivated violent
extremism is has risen to the level
where uh our security and intelligence
agencies have it as the top priority at
the moment I would argue that if you
look at just at the terrorist listings
that we're responsible for with Public
Safety we've I think listed up to nine
now imve groups in the last three years
so uh so I would I would not agree with
that characterization in the present day
but historically speaking we we
certainly were more focused on other
types of terrorism
so you wouldn't agree then I take it
that the potential threat posed by the
freedom Convoy wasn't recognized or
articulated as a national security
threat because of biases and
intelligence gathering and in a
reluctance to identify
certain types of threats as being
National Security threats no I would
disagree okay
uh Mr Stewart
um in your statement you're said to have
expressed The View that the government
and law enforcement lack certain tools
to monitor social media and properly
distill its content to identify threats
is that accurate yes
I wonder if you would agree then that
it's it's likely surprising to Canadians
that law enforcement continue to have a
deficit in that regard given the central
role that social media plays in modern
day communications
and particularly given that it can be
monitored on an open source basis
is that something to your knowledge that
will be addressed in the in the refresh
or reconsideration of the National
Security strategy
I'd like to clarify that point um
there's a very high noise to Signal
ratio in social media so there's a
challenge inherently in monitoring all
the channels that people use to
communicate to the extent that they're
accessible and there are many that are
not that are encrypted so uh it would be
I think a mistake to say that the police
or any institution have necessarily all
the capabilities they need
to to you to to monitor what is going on
in the uh in the electronic world and
then beyond that it's about assessing it
and trying to make sure that you know
what we understand to be the case
is either likely to be or is the case
and that that assessment process is also
very challenging so I think there's a
lot of inherent challenges here okay
okay uh we've heard evidence and I'm I'm
completely moving to a different area
now that uh by February 3rd uh mayor
Watson had spoken with the Prime
Minister and with Minister Mendocino
about the situation in Ottawa and the
need for federal resources
from this perspective of Public Safety
then the Convoy occupation by that time
was recognized to be a significant event
right yes
but no one within Public Safety at that
time on February 3rd was considering
invoking the emergencies act at that
point were they there was no Act of
consideration at that time
and the commission's heard evidence that
on February 4th
um a private citizen launched a class
action against the Convoy because
residents felt completely abandoned by
all levels of government and policing
institutions you're aware of that I am
but
um no one within Public Safety at that
time was considering invoking the
emergencies act right it was not under
active consideration at that point in
time
and you've you've indicated that it did
become an Act of consideration around
February 11th is that fair yes I did
so would it be fair then to say that the
federal government never really saw a
role for the emergencies act as a tool
for dealing with the freedom Convoy
until the international borders were
blockaded
um
no I think that's putting it too
linearly I think the um
a combination of factors led it to
become more actively considered
including the borders being located the
protracted protest in Ottawa and the you
know the threats
um of personal and economic harm
okay
but but a significant part of the
consideration with respect to economic
harm had to do with International Trade
didn't it it had to do with blocking
ports and gateways yes
so had it not been for the Border
blockades would in your assessment
um residents of Ottawa have been
continued to have been left to deal with
the effects of the Convoy despite the
tremendous social and economic harm they
were experiencing
there was always going to be a police
action in Ottawa
so I think you are neglecting the fact
that that was mobilizing albeit in a in
a very incremental way but specifically
with respect to the emergencies act
would you you know based on your
understanding of the discussions that
took place around that
in your view with the emergencies act
have been an appropriate tool to deal
with the situation in Ottawa had it not
been for those other events
the emergencies Act is generally
considered to be a tool of Last Resort
under a very exigent circumstances
urgent Time limited so
um there were many other tools in the
toolkit indeed Ontario used one and you
know it was not used until quite a bit
later in time so I I would say you know
we were all conscious of it as being a
tool
um but in the minds of those who were
you know sort of uh
discussing it at with counterparts there
were other tools as well
it next I'd like to call on the Ontario
Provincial Police
this one
good afternoon my name is Chris Diana
counsel to the opp
I wonder if we can start by bringing up
your witness summary which is WTS 66.
and while that's coming up I expect that
most of my questions will be directed to
Mr Stewart to Mr Roshan if you have some
insight or some information then please
chime in
all right
so this is your witness summary can we
go to page 21
and the last paragraph
and I want to ask some questions about
the consultation that took place
before the invocation of the ACT
so it reads DM Stewart added that the
Act was welcomed by law enforcement
especially police of jurisdiction though
they were never explicitly asked to
invoke the ACT they were asked whether
they had the tools they needed and the
answer was consistently that they could
use more tools I want to ask about that
paragraph in particular you use the the
word they which suggests that multiple
law enforcement agencies were canvassed
about tools that could be used under the
ACT is that fair characterization of the
summary
there's a there's a test spelling
mistake in there just for the record
um the were in the second sentence
um
uh
you know this is a composite statement
based on all the consultations we
undertook with officials as well as with
police
right and so my question arising from
that is which law enforcement agencies
were consulted about the use of the ACT
it
what I was saying in this witness
summary and what I am would say to you
is that they were no police agency was
asked about the act itself they were
always asked do you need more tools
all right and so my question is which
agencies were asked whether they needed
more tools uh RCMP Ops all right do you
have any knowledge on how that took how
that consultation took place
I know it would have been Guided by the
RCMP right because commissioner karik
and I don't know if you heard his
evidence he testified that the opp was
not consulted about the use of the
emergencies act or any tools by anyone
with a federal government do you have
any reason to dispute his testimony in
that regard I would I would not be I
would not have firsthand knowledge of
this
the RCMP was our primary interface
as a department and in the con in the
discussions that we were having all
right so is it fair to say that that
paragraph is based on information that
you would have received from the RCMP
rather than your own personal direct
knowledge and insofar as it pertains to
the opp
or other law enforcement agencies
uh law enforcement here could also
represent officials
and in provincial governments
all right because we're talking about
tools which
in terms of law enforcement agencies is
what I'm referring to and so do you have
any direct knowledge of other law
enforcement agencies that were consulted
about those tools
no direct knowledge all right
all right now at the time of course you
would agree that the opp had a very
prominent role within the province both
in Windsor Ottawa and elsewhere in
Ontario I would
and you would agree that the opp
considering its role in multiple
scenarios would be in a good position to
provide a meaningful response to a
consultation request
I would agree
indeed as you heard I assumed they were
and indeed the opp would have a
different perspective than the RCMP
because they have different jurisdiction
correct
that is true they have different
jurisdictions but they work very closely
together
all right and do you know if there is a
written record of consultation with law
enforcement agencies on the emergencies
Act
I do not
considering the extraordinary nature of
the emergencies act do you agree that
perhaps there should be a written
consultation record for accountability
purposes
the council the consultations
were in the broader form were often
recorded and there have been notes to
that effect right
um and again and they weren't about the
ACT they were about the tools and then
the cons the formal consultations were
also recorded and reported to Parliament
right and the reason I asked is because
there is a consultation record which I
won't take you to unless you want to see
it but that consultation record refers
to consultation with different provinces
and officials but there's no specifics
about consultation with law enforcement
and my question is whether are you aware
of any document that deals directly with
the law enforcement side of the
consultation no I'm not aware but you
would agree that perhaps considering the
fact that law enforcement has to use
those tools it would be a good idea to
have written records of that
consultation
I would agree
did you have any direct involvement with
Consulting law enforcement I think you
said you did not fair not police
other than the RCMP right
if we can turn up document PB dot NSC
Dot c-a-n
.503256
actually if you if I may I would correct
that answer because I did have calls
with Chief slowly on which uh
commissioner karik I was uh I was also
participating so I would say I I had
first-hand evidence from Chief slowly
that he needed more tools as well
all right now I don't think I don't know
if you were you don't appear to have
been copied on this document this
appears to be an exchange of emails
between commissioner lucky and Mike
Jones do you recognize this email I do
now Patrick bezen as Council I believe
who are Allison Whalen and Dennis Daly
they are RCMP uh one's a civilian member
the other is a regular member okay did
you see this document at the time that
it was generated or around the time it
was generated I do not recall seeing
this document okay now my tones as I
understand it it was chief of staff for
Minister mini Chino is that correct that
is correct
and if you scroll down to the bottom
it starts with an email request made on
February 13th from Mike Jones to Brenda
lucky part of it is redacted if you
scroll up I think it's clear kind of
what the purpose of the email is if you
scroll up a little higher higher
commissioner Lockheed stop there
commissioner Lockheed kind of gives a
list of some tools that she might find
useful is that your understanding of
this email that is my understanding
now I know that this exchange for the
record that is what I assumed the RCMP
would have consulted with colleagues
about okay
so this is the evidence of consultation
with the RCMP from the federal
government side my question
is whether or not it's unusual that this
request comes from the political side
comes from the chief of staff rather
than from your office from the deputy
Minister's office
under the circumstances I wouldn't say
it was unusual because typically
and I know the way it works eventually
of course because that's my area but
commissioner karig testified that almost
all his dealings were directly with
Deputy D Tomaso and the communication
went through the level of the Deputy
Minister but the commissioner of the
RCMP is a direct report to the minister
of Public Safety right and so it's more
common then for the political side to
engage directly with the commissioner or
the RCMP it is and I wanted to follow up
on a comment because this is an
opportunity for us to look at all these
issues all these kind of broader
systemic issues could you race it
yourself really and your evidence about
Nova Scotia and maybe taking another
look at what is the appropriate role of
the political side as opposed to your
side of the house
do you have any thoughts on
how from a federal from the federal side
that can be improved from where it's at
now
that's a very open-ended question I
don't think my opinion is here or there
I would observe however and this is why
I raised it this morning that this
hasn't become an issue and a number of
dementia and a number of domains
um where uh people have asked what's the
what's the division between requests for
information and advice which this I
think constitutes versus what our uh you
know sort of interference or you know
engagement in police uh operations
um and so I'm I I'm I would certainly
agree with the proposal that that could
be clarified yeah and I guess one of the
reasons I asked you're not copied on
this and as Deputy Minister if there is
going to be direct engagement with a
political side don't you expect you to
at least be copied on it for urine for
your informational awareness
at uh one in the morning it probably
wouldn't matter
right
no I I I I think it would have made
sense for her to copy me she copied her
subordinates right and I guess again
we're here we're in this context where
we can look at these issues these
opportunities don't come across very
well and you've got a lot of experience
in your role as to you Mr Roshan so
you've been away into this question as
well but is there any Merit in having
clearer lines or more clearly defined
lines about how
uh the interaction between the political
side and the RCMP commissioner to avoid
any kind of misunderstandings
there is Merit
and how is there any do you have any
recommendations on how those lines
should be drawn no
do you have any thoughts Mr Roshan no
I'm afraid not all right
and just finishing up on the question
about intelligence
you were asked a question by my friend
who was up before me about whether or
not there was essentially a failure of
intelligence now your evidence earlier
was that you're in a position where
you're only receiving or you're you're
consuming the intelligence correct
correct that is correct but you only
know what's provided to you correct
correct so for example you didn't even
know about Hendon what you're looking at
is what other people are synthesizing
putting together and letting you know
correct correct so really you wouldn't
be in a position especially at the time
to know whether you had reviewed all the
intelligence or whether what had been
provided to you was an accurate
reflection of what was out there correct
I would argue that we the reason why we
have an ADM National Security operations
committee table every week is to have
subject matter experts across 16
departments and agencies
bring forward information that would be
relevant for that table and then we ask
questions and try to anticipate
um threats to National Security and in
this particular instance we would have
all been aware of convoys and but we
would have been deferring to the RCMP or
transport or indeed
csis itac and others to flag for us if
there was something more uh to bring to
our attention and at the early stages
that wasn't the case right and so if the
RCMP or whoever's reviewing is almost
whoever's reviewing this information
decides that information such as there's
no exit strategy an intention to make
the work into government more difficult
if that doesn't get included then
obviously you would never know so
there's a lot that's put on the
shoulders of those who are providing the
information to you would you agree
yes and no I mean there's enough
experience around that that EDM National
Security operations table to ask those
types of questions
um
you know intelligence Fusion is always a
challenge and so bringing together all
of the various pieces of intelligence to
get an accurate picture at a moment in
time is something that we have
experience with and at that point in
time we had no reason to believe this
was going to be anything more than a
peaceful protest
thank you gentlemen much appreciated
thank you next uh up is the Windsor
Police Service
uh thank you Mr commissioner this is Tom
McRae for Windsor Police Service I have
no questions
thank you next is the government of
Alberta
good afternoon my name is Stephanie boes
for the province of Alberta
um I just have a few questions around
the RFA that came from Alberta I think
Mr Stewart you're probably the one who
will be answering these questions today
but um certainly if this is something
that both members of the panel can
respond to please feel free to do so
um for now can I ask that the clerk
please bring up the public safety
institutional report that's document doj
dot i r dot 708
and while that's um happening Mr Stewart
I believe you mentioned in your evidence
that the RFA that came from Alberta
didn't follow the usual course namely
that there wasn't discussion before it
was submitted is that correct that is
correct
do you know if there had been discussion
ahead of the RFA would that have changed
the response by the federal government
in this case
uh in all likelihood it would not
okay and then on that institutional
report Mr clerk can you please scroll
down to page 22 and look at paragraph 75
please
and this is referring to the February
5th RFA from the minister of Municipal
Affairs or Alberta and it says upon
reviewing the request it was determined
that the RFA process was not the correct
mechanism for addressing the issue of
additional law enforcement Personnel
requests for additional RCMP officers
must be made under sub article 9 of the
Provincial Police Services agreement and
not through an RFA so is it true that
the RFA from Alberta was interpreted to
be a request for RCMP officer deployment
no it was perceived to largely be a
request for tow trucks
okay
I'll just take you to that as well
that's documentpb.can.50718
and I'll take it you've seen the um RFA
from Minister McIver before is that
correct I have
okay and then if we look at paragraph
five or sorry paragraph four
um
within that paragraph we see to support
this approach I'm requesting federal
assistance that includes the provision
of equipment and Personnel to move
approximately 70 to semi-trafter
trailers and approximately 75 personal
and recreational vehicles from the area
do you know at the time this was
received what the interpretation of
personnel was meant to be
and I'm not talking from Minister
mciver's point of view I'm asking what
the federal government interpreted that
request to be
uh I can say quite authoritatively I
believe it was not assumed to be law
enforcement because everybody understood
the article 9 process very well
it's been used many times over the years
so this was inferred to be
Armed Forces Personnel okay thank you
and we do know of course that there was
a request for deployment of our CMP
officers that was appropriately made
under the police services agreement that
came just a few days later correct
correct
all right now can we please take a look
at documentpv.can.401514
ah
and this is an email from Mr docklebab
to yourself on February 13.
and it outlines a meeting that um
Transportation Canada
individuals had with colleagues from
Alberta Manitoba and Ontario and if we
scroll down to the bullet points that
begin with Alberta
we can see those there Alberta requests
for CAF support have been denied but
they are surprised that the request to
access reservists with operational
skills needed to drive towing trucks was
not accepted this part of the request is
news to us and we committed to follow up
on this specific point do you know if
there was any follow-up on that point
I do not
all right now ultimately the government
of Canada was going to deny Alberta's
request for assistance correct
actually
what happened
um was that uh we
um evaluated the initial request
and determined that the calf equipment
would not be appropriate
and as this indicates it was not my
understanding that there was another
dimension to the Personnel request
however we did not formally notify uh
Alberta that the RFA would be turned
down on the basis of the fact that we
were still having discussions about the
federal toolkit and ultimately addressed
the tow truck issue via the emergencies
Act
okay now I'd like to take you to
um some draft letters that were in
Canada's production for this
beginning with
pb.nsc dot c a n
four Zero's nine five four seven
we can see that this is dated February
7th it's addressed to The Honorable
Minister McIver which is the Minister of
Municipal Affairs for Alberta and if we
scroll down to the last paragraph on the
first page
it says further I understand that
Alberta has the required authorities
necessary to enforce compliance as a
highway is considered essential
infrastructure and it is unlawful to
willfully obstruct interrupt or
interfere with the construction
maintenance use or operation of any
essential infrastructure in a manner
that renders the essential
infrastructure dangerous useless
inoperative or ineffective as per the
critical infrastructure Defense Act of
Alberta
and this letter is unsigned um do you
know why it was unsigned and unsent at
this time
for the reasons I just explained
okay but you would agree that on
February 7th the government of Canada's
position was that Alberta had the
required authorities to deal with the
illegal protests around coops Alberta
we determined that the
full Suite of provincial tools had not
been exhausted which is sort of a first
principle of the RFA
all right
and then there are a number of other
follow-up
um draft letters that is contain
essentially the same language in it
um just for the record I will take you
to
ssm.can.nsc 402745
and this is a memorandum for the
minister of emergency preparedness I
understand if you scroll down to page
two that you digitally signed this
memorandum on February 9th
do you see that I see that
and in this memorandum you recommended
that the minister of emergency
preparedness sign and enclosed reply
indicating that the government of Canada
was refusing the RFA
okay is that correct I believe so I
haven't seen any attachment but I
believe so well in the enclosed
correspondence on this one is actually
redacted but if we look at the body of
the memorandum we see the init the
reasons for refusing on page two the
paragraph above the heading
recommendation says
this remains an issue within provincial
jurisdiction Alberta has the required
legal authorities necessary to enforce
compliance so very similar reasons for
the refusal that was being outlined in
the February 7th draft correct correct
and then if we turn now to
ssm.nsc Dot c-a-n-403115
this is a series of emails from February
11th
and in the email from ratty Barrack to
minister Bill Blair it says here is the
latest draft in reply to Alberto's RFA
and again going to page two
we see a paragraph starting with further
I understand
and it says Alberta has the required
legal authorities necessary to enforce
compliance and then refers to the
critical infrastructure Defense Act
so again here we are February 11th very
similar reasons to those expressed on
February 9th and February 7th correct
correct
and if we scroll to the very top of this
we see that Minister Blair approved the
response were you aware that he had
approved such a response I was
okay
and I told a provincial official
although I cannot remember who that was
um do you know the the level of
Perpetual official you told or the
meaning in which you told them that a
deputy Minister called me and asked if
we were going to approve it sometime
within 24 to 48 hours of the original
request and I said my expectation is we
would not
okay so very early on the decision was
made it would be refused the reasons for
refusing it seem to not really have
changed throughout the course of the
time when the draft response was being
considered is that fair to say yes
and then I'm going to take you to one
last draft and that is on
um
PB dot c a n dot NSC I believe it's five
zero six nine zero
and this is an email I I my
understanding is with the time stamp
this time is actually uh the true time
that this was sent should be five hours
ahead of this so sometime in the evening
on February 12th
excuse me
um if we scroll down to the second email
there
and on the second page
we again see we've got a draft response
and again the wording is very similar
further I understand Alberta has the
required legal authorities and then
reference to the critical infrastructure
Defense Act
so by as late as February 12th the
government of Canada's position on
Alberta's RFA was that it had the
required legal authorities necessary to
enforce compliance of any illegal
protest activity in Korea in Alberta do
you agree
it had powers to address the
circumstance
um including compelling tow truck
drivers
here now well out of time
and I just have one minute to clarify
which act that um that power comes under
Mr commissioner
okay
so
I'm sorry
um You referred to Alberta having the
power to compel tow truck operators
under the critical infrastructure
Defense Act
um I'm going to put to you that that act
is um not actually the correct act it is
only five sections long and the
commission has heard evidence from the
assistant Deputy Minister de Grande
that'll that legislation makes
interfering with critical infrastructure
and offense but it's not something that
Alberta needs to invoke Alberta does
have the Emergency Management act which
does grants in it the power to compel
service providers to provide services so
despite maybe having a confusion about
which act that power falls under it
doesn't change the position that Canada
of Canada's response to Alberta's RFA
would you agree I would agree
okay
um thank you that's my only question
those are my only questions today okay
thank you next if I could call on the uh
ccla please
good afternoon uh can you see and hear
me okay
yes
my name is Kara zwievel I am a council
for the Canadian civil liberties
Association
um I wonder if we could pull up document
PB dot can dot four zeros 1584-1584
um and this just while it's getting
pulled up I believe is an email chain
related to the technical briefing
um that you mentioned earlier that I
guess there were several technical
briefings uh that happened and um if we
scroll all the way down to the bottom
just so we can see where this starts
um so this is uh someone in the
communications branch of Public Safety
um and writing to say that they're um
there may need to be a follow-up a
second I think here we're talking about
a media briefing
um is that right I believe so yes okay
um because there wasn't enough time for
all the questions given some other
briefings that were going on
um and if we scroll up a bit more
there's there's some discussion here
about the possibility of doing this
another way could we do this in writing
I gather at this point everyone in your
department is
um Running on Fumes and there's there's
quite a lot going on and the idea of
doing yet another briefing is not
necessarily something you feel is the
best use of time is that is that an
accurate characterization
I would simply say from my recollection
that uh we pretty much ran full on doing
a technical brief after technical brief
after technical brief with different
stakeholders uh be they uh
both houses of Parliament
media as well as stakeholders and each
one typically would would run for half
an hour to an hour but in this
particular case we were affording uh
stakeholders sometimes up to two hours
sometimes even longer and we were trying
to address as many questions but as you
can appreciate we had a panel of
um experts from a great number of
departments and agencies and therefore
questions stemmed from
law enforcement activity to border
service activity to
finance uh and uh and therefore
um we were I think if I if I look back
at this particular exchange probably
wondering whether there wouldn't be a
way of having people submit questions in
writing and maybe there would be a
better way of posting our answers online
as opposed to continuing with the uh the
number of technical briefs that we were
providing
okay thank you and can we now go to uh
document ssm.can.402668
so I I think
um this is going to be I believe your
speaking notes for maybe it's one maybe
it's all of these technical briefings
um and if we can just go down to the
First full paragraph on page three
and I think this is the document that we
we were talking about earlier about the
need to to focus on the the public
safety portfolio elements
um a bit a bit more and Not Duplicate
what Justice or other departments may
say
um
and so
yes okay so on this uh page I I gather
this is this is roughly what you what
you communicated during these briefings
um so first noting that the emergencies
act as a significant step one that will
help ensure law enforcement across
Canada at Broad and clear authority to
protect Public Safety ensure our borders
remain open and Safeguard our national
security and then scrolling down a bit
it's also noted that this is a message
to people who are participating in these
protests
and interfering and critical
infrastructure that there will be
consequences
um and then it
a little bit more the next paragraph
notes that these measures will
supplement existing provincial and
territorial measures and assist the RCMP
in becoming integrated I think this it
probably speaks a little bit to that
question of uh avoiding the swearing in
and and some of that uh red tape and
then it's this last next paragraph that
I want to I want to ask about so it says
it's important to underscore that
invoking the emergencies act does not
give the federal government the
authority to direct the police services
of any other jurisdiction so
um two questions I guess the first is
um
it is that statement that the use of of
any other jurisdiction are you saying
here that using the emergencies act
allows the federal government to direct
the federal police the RCMP
or you just clarifying that nothing in
the emergencies act changes the normal
uh the normal situation where the
government does not direct police in
their operations I would say it's the
latter interpretation okay thank you
um but would you agree with me that
while invoking the emergencies act
doesn't give the federal government the
um the authority to direct Police
Services of any jurisdiction the orders
the emergency orders that were made
under the rubric of the ACT Grant police
new authority to to enforce those
measures Grant
sorry can you sorry yes sorry uh sorry
well I wasn't sure if you were finished
that's why I was waiting apologies um
yes I think it certainly gives them
additional tools via the means of
additional authorities uh that they can
Avail themselves of
okay right and just like uh the criminal
code gives the police certain
officers that will make determinations
about the manner of enforcement
yes
okay and ultimately police authorities
that will decide um and how they will
exercise their discretion this notion of
police discretion is a an important
piece of this would you agree I would
agree
um
and you would agree that these um you
know these orders under the emergency
act provided all police across the
country with the authority to enforce
these these new measures
yes
um
and although the federal government was
not directing the Police Service of any
jurisdiction would you agree that by
invoking a federal emergency and making
the emergency orders the federal
government was was clearly intending to
communicate a message not just to people
participating in protests but also to
law enforcement of all jurisdictions
that this is something the government
takes very seriously and we're looking
to you to to enforce
yes
I I think at some point also uh Minister
Blair made a comment this was a bit
before the the Act was invoked uh but I
think he was sharing with the media that
this was something the federal
government was considering and he said
it was important that police do their
jobs
do you recall that comment not
specifically no but I don't disagree
with with uh the thought I guess okay
um and uh Mr Stewart in your testimony
earlier you you said that
um enforcement and I think this is when
you were talking about the engagement
proposal but the engagement proposal was
not
um really an alternative to enforcement
it was something that would be used to
try to shrink the footprint as we've
heard
um and uh sort of
lay a path to eventual enforcement and I
think you said was enforcement was only
a matter of time that's correct
I think you also told my friend Miss
tamman there was always going to be a
police action to dismantle what was
going on in Ottawa it was a question of
timing that's correct
um
one more question related to there was a
document that you were taken to before
um and this is around the relationship
with the government of Ontario and the
powers that they had under their
emergency Act
their Emergency Management and civil
protection act
um and I think you noted that the the
Ontario legislation had had more teeth
than the federal legislation in terms of
the penalties
do you recall saying that that's correct
okay
um but he would agree with me that the
the provincial legislation didn't allow
for the kind of broad
um
Financial powers that were included in
the emergency regulations uh invoked
enacted by the federal government
that's correct
so the freezing of assets
um immediately without notice or due
process is likely something that the
province
would not have been able to do or it's
not contemplated under their legislation
it was not contemplated and indeed it
was done under the bank act so that's a
federal statute
okay
um so we could just go back to
um that pb.can.401584
[Music]
this is the the email chain again
related to the technical briefing and
sorry to jump around a little I'm just
trying to use my time as effectively as
I can
um
so if we just scroll down a little bit
let's keep going
thank you right there
um so Mr Rochelle
um this was again I think you're
discussing sort of how to make the best
use of everyone's time and what's a very
busy time
um and you note there was there was
better control in the first meeting
because it was one that you were
cheering
um
second brief was bananas and Injustice
is at all can you tell us a bit about
that second briefing and what what
happened there in terms of the
communications certainly the way the way
these briefs are typically handled uh in
my experience having gone through many
of these over the course of my career is
that you normally have a moderator so a
moderator from a particular department
will invite
um will essentially moderate a call this
typically will happen on a
teleconference line uh the
teleconference line will be open to a
series of stakeholders if it's a media
event for example you'll have a number
of of media spokespeople who will be in
a queue and they uh having never been on
the other side I'm not sure what
technology they use but they get into a
queue in order to be able to ask
questions
um normally a moderator will open up
will explain who is representing the
government
will walk through
um
the time that will be allotted to an
opening statement by the government
officials then how much time will be
allotted for questions and whether or
not uh questions uh whether or not a
stakeholders are afforded a follow-up to
that question
having been a former assistant Deputy
minister of Communications in a in the
previous Department this is protocol
that we normally follow unfortunately in
light of the way these were being set up
this particular brief from my
recollection Justice was supposed to be
lead so the first the first meeting was
chaired by Public Safety we would have
followed that protocol and therefore we
would only would have gotten to six
questions because the six questions were
likely uh
rather Broad and they were followed by
each a follow-up and we didn't we didn't
um the the cutoff time of an hour if I
remember correctly that first brief uh
ended up limiting itself to six
questions and there were a number of
people in the queue that complained
about that which is my first point
the second brief was one that was led by
Justice officials they didn't have a
moderator and so if I remember correctly
I came on and had to play the role of
moderator and try to police how the call
was being managed because there was no
moderator hence my comment that it was
rather bananas okay so it's it's more uh
it's a question of the procedure
those are all my questions thank you
okay thank you uh next is the uh
Canadian Constitution Foundation
yes good afternoon can you hear me okay
yes ma'am okay great so my name is Jenny
Shen moganathan and I'm here for the
Canadian Constitution foundation and my
questions are for Deputy Minister
Stewart
so sir in your interview summary you
explained that an Ottawa Municipal and
provincial authorities were not used
more extensively because the Ops was
overwhelmed by protesters do you recall
saying that
I do
and I take it what you mean by that is
that authorities like the highway
traffic act noise bylaws we're not being
enforced by the Ops because they were
overwhelmed by protesters
that's correct
so there was this resource issue in
Ottawa you know not enough police
officers on the ground to enforce the
law
that's correct
so I'd like to take you to your
interview summary and Mr clerk this is
WTS 6066
[Music]
and it's page 12 please
so if we look at the third paragraph
under the Ottawa Police Service heading
what it says here it says the DM that's
you sir also described how there was
some tension between the city of Ottawa
and the federal government because Chief
slowly wanted more assistance and
questions were raised about how many
RCMP officers and resources had been
deployed to assist the Ops rather than
to protect Federal assets
so what you're describing here is that
there's this tension because Chief
slowly wants more help to address the
the resource issue and is asking well
how many of these RCMP officers are
really just being used to protect
Federal assets rather than helping us
the Ops enforce things like the criminal
code and the highway traffic act to deal
with the protests is that fair that is
fair
and the tension is that Ops wants more
help and is questioning well how much
help are we actually getting right right
and you go on to say in that paragraph
um the rcmp's position was that the Ops
should have asked the opp for more
resources and that it was the OPP's
responsibility to come and serve he
that's you sir explained that the RCMP
felt pressed by the Ops but that the opp
was the force that the Ops should look
to pursuant to legislation and then
there's a reference to the Ontario
Police Services Act
so there's this tension and the RCMP is
feeling pressed and the response you're
hearing coming from the RCMP is that the
Ops should really go to the opp right
correct
the response is okay not exclusively
though to be clear not exclusively the
RCMP had agreed to come with resources
that they had to hand to help
and there was some confusion around how
they were counting heads and whether
those people were at the disposition of
the Ops or whether they were RCMP under
RCMP control and
potentially Deployable so there's some
confusion about that but at all times
there was an expectation that the opp
would become as well
yes right the RCMP position was well Ops
should go to the opp first and then come
to us is that fair that is the rcmp's
position as I understand it
and so the position you know the
response that you were getting from the
RCMP wasn't well the Ops is asking us
for help we should do everything we can
do to give them whatever they need as
soon as possible that wasn't the
position you were hearing
uh not to that extent no the rcmp's
position was that they could provide
some help but to the extent that more
help was required the Auto Ottawa Police
should be asking the opp
right and so you know maybe it's just me
but it kind of sounds to me like there's
one level of government saying you know
passing the buck and saying you should
look to another level of government but
I take it you don't agree with that
I don't agree with that
now this idea that the opp was a force
that the Ops should be looking to
pursuant to legislation commission
Council asked you about that in her
examination and she suggested that it
was the police services act and you said
I believe so right I did
so there's this idea that's going around
that there is something in the police
services act that means the Ops should
be going to the opp primarily or first
before it goes to the RCMP
that is my understanding
all right so I've taken a look at the
police services act and I think we
should bring it up Mr clerk that's CCF
six zeros 11.
and to page 15 please
and so if we could just pause here for a
moment so section 9 of the police
services act um
section 91 talks about you know when a
police service is absent or inadequate
OPP assistants may be sought so what 9-1
says is if the commission finds the
municipality to which subsection 41
applies is not providing Police Services
it may request that the commissioner
have the Ontario Provincial Police give
assistance so what it says is that it
may request that the commissioner have
the Ontario Police Provincial Police
give assistance
and now if we scroll down to subsection
6
what it says here is a municipal chief
of police who is of the opinion that an
emergency exists in the municipality May
request that the commissioner have the
Ontario Police Provincial Police give
assistance so what I say is you know
these sections enable the Ops to go to
the opp
I don't see anything in the app that
says the Ops cannot go to the RCMP first
or that the Ops can only go to the RCMP
after they've gone to the opp
do you have a different understanding of
this legislation
the first time I've seen the legislation
so I was operating on the basis of what
I understood the case to be but I think
I would not agree with the way you put
it
As I understood it in the circumstances
we Face the RCMP was willing to help and
did not stand on Principle as to whether
they were the first or the second asked
they felt the opp was what the uh the
auto Police Service should be asking
so okay but they were not holding off
and responding because the RC the Ops
hadn't asked the opp
fair enough but you do agree that it was
your understanding that it was the
rcmp's position that the appropriate
force to be seeking assistance from was
the opp is that fair technically yes
okay technically that was what the
rcmp's position was
but not technically that was the rcmp's
position
well I understood it to be in you've
just obviously improved my understanding
that that was what the law required the
circumstances uh drove a different set
of considerations
okay fair enough and now you're not
aware of any other law or legislation
that requires the Ops to go to the opp
for help first before seeking help from
the RCMP I am not
okay those are all my questions thank
you very much
okay thank you next to the city of
Windsor
good afternoon can everyone see me yes
hi good afternoon Mr Stewart Mr Rochelle
my name is Jennifer King I'm counsel to
the city of Windsor I have some
questions for you about Emergency
Management of critical infrastructure in
Canada will you agree with me that local
authorities play a central role in
Emergency Management in Canada I would
agree
you are familiar with the current
emergency framework for Canada Third
Edition
I am and that can be found at
win400-2230
um so Mr Stewart I can't see who's
responding but um is this is public
safety's key policy framework for
federal provincial territorial
coordination with respect to Emergency
Management in Canada correct
correct
and you'll agree with me that the
framework does not directly engage with
municipalities
uh
uh the framework tends to operate
through the basis of provinces and
territories as being the primary
Authority
okay and the framework relies on
provinces and territories to engage with
local authorities that's correct
the approach outlined in the framework
provides for a scaling up where the
provincial and federal government step
in only when local capacity is exceeded
correct
I believe so
and you'll agree with me that this
approach requires excellent multi-level
coordination
I would agree
would you agree then to ensure effective
coordination on the ground
municipalities and other local First
Responders should be directly engaged in
Canada's framework
I think there is a high degree of virtue
in interoperability and
interconnectedness across the all of the
First Responders
um in so far as we were talking about uh
and and ultimately requests for
assistance uh I believe there is a chain
of authority that has to be worked
through and shouldn't be worked around
okay well there are coordination
instruments that are referenced in the
framework and Mr Roshan I think you
referred to a national strategy for
critical infrastructure this morning I
didn't need
and and the intention for this is to
provide for intended to kind of create a
an approach between the federal
provincial and territorial governments
to Emergency Management with respect to
critical infrastructure correct
uh yes not just that but also better
coordination with the private sector and
and all levels of government
okay and all levels of government
including Municipal yes
you would agree that the Ambassador
Bridge in Windsor is critical
infrastructure within the meaning of
this National strategy
I would be inclined to agree that it is
as critical infrastructure however I do
want to clarify the point that we
weren't operating
um in in large measure uh in invoking
the emergencies act under the context
that that strategic that framework uh it
speaks to that that framework speaks to
emergencies other than law enforcement
emergencies
and it doesn't uh address the role of
the different Ministries and levels of
government to support a police-led
response
uh well I'm I'm it's obviously been some
time since I've looked at it but but I'm
uh conveying to you my understanding
here that we did not treat in general we
did not treat the protests as an
emergency management issue and that the
framework that we have designed and
agreed with provinces and territories to
deploy does not
uh typically apply to issues of
public security
in the sense of law enforcement it deals
with natural disasters uh and though and
the like
so you're saying that the national
strategy for critical infrastructure is
not intended to address uh this the type
of protests that we saw in February so
those are two separate things Emergency
Management is one frame where a critical
infrastructure is a separate one and uh
the original critical infrastructure
strategy written back in 2010
um
unfortunately there are different
different strata within uh the
management of emergencies so cyber cyber
event cyber security or a national
security event a terrorist event
does not fall under the rubric of
Emergency Management and it would follow
a different set of circumstances as it
is written now the new critical
infrastructure strategy that we're
pulling together we're currently
Consulting and we're leveraging various
different uh tables in order to better
understand how we can manage critical
infrastructure going forward and that is
still a work in progress
okay well I I think I'm running up on my
time and if I could just have uh one or
two more minutes I have a few questions
to wrap up I just wanted to
um uh perhaps I won't take you to the
document are you aware you can have one
or two minutes go ahead thank you
commissioner
um are you aware that mayor dilkins of
Windsor wrote to minister Mendicino
Minister Blair and the Ontario solicitor
general in March
um
indicating the need for broader
collaboration and support from
provincial and federal governments to
bolster the Safety and Security of our
borders
uh Noah I
if I was aware I had forgotten okay well
I will say that mayor dilkins in his
testimony
it indicated that he went on to request
a meeting to debrief emergency
regulatory obligations regarding the
Ambassador Bridge did you discuss this
request to meet with Minister Mendocino
or Minister Blair
no
okay would you recommend that the
ministers meet with Windsor provincial
and federal recommendation
representatives to discuss long-term
needs and planning to protect Windsor's
International Crossings
I would agree to the more general
statement that it's important that
Federal and provincial ministers Take
Lessons Learned From uh as it pertains
to protecting critical infrastructure
um okay I think that's all my time thank
you very much commissioner
okay thank you
uh next uh call on
province of Saskatchewan please
good afternoon sirs my name is Mitch
McAdam and I'm one of the lawyers for
the government of Saskatchewan
I just have a few questions for you
today
first Mr Stewart in your interview
summary at page 20 you indicated that
you are aware of the federal emergencies
act back in 2020 at the outset of the
covid-19 pandemic and you mentioned that
again this morning so I take it that you
are involved in the discussions back in
2020 about potentially invoking the
emergencies act to deal with the
covid-19 pandemic isn't that true that
is true
and sir I'm going to ask you a few very
general questions about that time I have
some documents that I can pull up if you
need to see them but in the interest of
time I'm not going to pull them up
unless it's necessary but if you do need
to refresh your memory by all means ask
me to pull them up my questions are
going to be quite General
all right to begin with to begin with
sir you'd agree with me that in that
case there was a process of Engagement
with the provinces that spanned at least
a couple of weeks
that is my recollection
and you'll agree with me that there was
a letter that was sent by the prime
minister to the premier's formally
initiating consultations under the
emergencies act that is my recollection
and you'll agree with me that that
letter was followed up with a meeting
between the Prime Minister and the
premiers to discuss the matter
uh I don't have any direct knowledge of
that I know there was a call that was
organized for Minister Blair who was
Public Safety minister at the time with
his counterparts to have a discussion
about the potential utility of the
emergencies Act okay but you're not
aware of any uh telephone conference
call involving the Prime Minister and
the premiers not aware
okay and are you aware that the premiers
were given um about a week to provide a
formal written response to the idea of
invoking the emergencies act to deal
with the pandemic
um not in that specific sense
but I was aware that they were given an
opportunity to respond
and they were given some time to do so
that I don't that's the specifics of it
I don't I don't know that
okay so if I say they were given a week
you can't uh agree or disagree with that
that is correct
okay but will you agree with me sir that
the process that was used back in 2020
when there was discussion about invoking
the emergencies act to deal with the
covid-19 pandemic was quite different
than the process that was followed in
February of this year before invoking
the ACT to deal with the blockades and
protests I would agree
thank you sir
next sir I'd like to ask you a few
questions about the fpt meetings that
were discussed this morning
and Mr Stewart you talked about a
meeting of Deputy ministers that you
attended on February 7th you recall that
meeting yes it was a call
okay
and Mr Roshan my understanding is that
you attended a meeting of the fpt crime
prevention and policing committee on
February the 11th do you recall that yes
I believe that's correct
yes
and Mr Stewart would you agree with me
that at the meeting on February 7th at
no time did you
advise the provincial officials that
were on that call that the federal
government was contemplating invoking
the emergencies Act
that is correct
and Mr Roshan would you agree with me at
the meeting on February 11th at no time
did you or anyone else from Public
Safety Canada advised the provincial and
territorial officials on the call that
the federal government was considering
invoking the federal emergencies act
that's my recollection yes okay
and Mr Stewart would you agree with me
that
these opportunities the deputy ministers
meeting that you had and the meetings of
the CPP committee would have been a good
opportunity to discuss the uh potential
and vocation of the emergencies act with
provincial officials
had the invocation of the ACT been a
subject of Acts of discussion yes but it
wasn't
okay so at the time of these two
meetings it wasn't under active
discussion
in the time I did the meeting it was not
so on February 7th it was not
that's correct
okay and Mr Roshan when you had the
meeting on February 11th was the
emergency doctor under active discussion
at that time
um I'm trying to think at that time I
believe the situation of a national
security threat was certainly uh
uh top of mind and we were
by recollection and not having the
document in front of me
um
I I my recollection is that we were
looking at every available tool
um available to us and to provinces and
territories and municipalities in order
to be able to deal with the situation
the the threat that seemed to be growing
so uh sorry
go ahead
Mr Stewart
you're aware of a meeting that Mr
docklebaub from your department attended
with officials from Alberta Manitoba
Ontario on the RCMP on February 13th
that's a meeting that he uh reported to
you by email on Sunday night you were
call out yes I do
okay and at that time the invocation of
the emergencies Act was under active
consideration by the federal government
wasn't it yes it was
and your information is that Mr
docklebab or the other officials Federal
officials on that call did not advise
their provincial counterparts that the
Act was under active consideration did
they
I
cannot say for certainty that any of
them knew
okay so you're saying the federal
officials that were on the call would
not have known that the federal
emergencies Act was under active
consideration at that time I I'm not
sure that they did I don't I can't say
for sure so they couldn't have advised
their provincial officials of that
indeed had they not known
okay and as far as you know they didn't
advise provincial officials about
I would agree as far as
thank you
so you're now out of time okay thank you
commissioner those are all my questions
okay thank you
next is the National Police Federation
yes hello this is Nene Jones for the npf
we have no further questions thank you
okay thank you next is the Democracy
fund
foreign
good afternoon Mr Stewart and Mr
Rochelle I'm Rob kittridge representing
the Justice Center for constitutional
freedoms and uh I only have five minutes
today so just to make efficient use to
my time I'm going to direct my questions
to Mr Stewart so I apologize for leaving
you out
um uh can we bring up uh document ssmcan
1096 underscore Rel dot zero zero zero
one please and this is the document that
my friend representing the Convoy
organizers was trying to show you
earlier on when you ran out of time
um
Mr Stewart the the liberal research
Bureau is an entity within the liberal
party that receives receives government
funds conducts research and provides
briefs to support the Liberal Party
politicians ministers and MPS right
um I'll take your word for it yeah not
familiar with it okay
um you're not familiar with the liberal
research Bureau at all no I have nothing
to do with it and you've never heard of
it oh I've heard of it but I didn't know
what it does you have no idea at all
what it does no okay
um
so this uh this document on the screen
uh would you agree that it appears to uh
be a brief preparing MPS as to what they
should say in response to the motion and
in debate in response to the motion to
support the invocation of the
emergencies act certainly how it appears
all right can we scroll to page four
please
towards the bottom of page four
and you can see here at the bottom of
page four it outlines the cpc's position
the bq's position and the ndp's position
which it indicates that the NDP will
support the motion would you agree with
that
uh that's what I observe right and in
your dealings with the ministers and
elected Executives uh they told you that
before the emergencies Act was invoked
they already had the support of the NDP
to just to uphold the invocation didn't
they no they did not uh when did you
first learn that the NDP were going to
support the invocation of the act upon
the vote
okay
um are you aware of any polling that was
done to assess public support for the
invocation of the emergencies act not
aware all right
um
all right and moving on a little bit
um numerous Witnesses from the opp and
the Ops have testified that the
invocation of the ACT may have been
helpful but it was not necessary to
clear the protests would you agree with
them on that point
I believe that the invocation of the ACT
provided very useful tools to law
enforcement useful tools but not
necessary tools
well
I I'm not in a position to render an
opinion on that I don't think I I would
only observe as I've observed already
that upon the invocation of the Act and
the use of those tools the protests
diminished and and stopped and that that
goes beyond useful
uh when discussing the invocation of the
act in an email on the night of February
14th you indicated that the emergency
Powers didn't bring a lot of significant
benefits didn't you I acknowledge that
was perhaps an under estimate on my part
right but uh you were at that point you
were having trouble even coming up with
examples of how the emergency Powers
might be useful in clearing the protests
weren't you
I was encouraging my colleague for the
purposes of doing technical briefings to
try to be more specific and clear right
but you were running out of ideas on how
it might be useful
the ideas were already on the table
in the sense of the the the the the the
drafting of the various uh orders and
measures uh the issue here was how they
were explained
right
um provincial Powers at that point
hadn't been exhausted had they
in Ontario I would say they had you
would
your interview summary indicates that
you thought that the power to compel tow
trucks was important do you remember
that I do but really you have no
personal knowledge of whether that power
was actually necessary to clear the
protests do you
it has it was reported to ministers and
I was present at this time that that was
an important element and was used
um you have no knowledge at all of
whether tow trucks had already been
retained by the OPP prior to the
invocation of the ACT do you I do not
right
and you have no direct knowledge of
whether the power to compel tow trucks
was useful to police anywhere in Canada
do you really no firsthand knowledge
right
similarly while you suggest that the
Declaration of Emergency the financial
measures and the other emergency Powers
may have acted as a deterrent you don't
actually have any direct knowledge of
that do you
well that's a um that's a hypothetical I
it in in light of my observation that
the protests were significantly
de-escalated and stopped I think
deterrence was a major factor so you'd
speculate that the invocation of the ACT
had a deterrent effect but you don't
actually know that that was its intent
pardon me that was its intent but you'd
speculate that it was effective it's
hard to observe it in the in that right
so you you have no real direct knowledge
that it did have that effect you just
speculate that it had that effect
okay you could call it speculation I I
would call it conclusion okay uh thank
you very much those are my questions
thank you uh next uh the CLA
cccdl criminal lawyers
thank you very much commissioner
right
my name is Colleen McEwen and I'm
co-counsel for the criminal lawyers
Association and the Canadian Council of
criminal defense lawyers two
organizations with joint standing at the
commission
uh my questions are related to the
consultation process and I'm directing
them to Deputy Minister Stewart
um if the clerk of please bring up uh
the witness summary WTS 6066
and I'm looking specifically at uh page
21 and a paragraph that you've already
been brought to
uh is to scroll down a bit
uh it's the with respect to the issue of
consultation with provinces do you see
that paragraph
I do
at first I have a question of
clarification
um when you say that it is being uh
sorry it's the that first sentence with
respect to the issue of consultation
with provinces DM Stewart stated that
there was a lot of consultation done
with the provinces that was discounted
because it was not premised on whether
the federal government was going to
decide to invoke the act when you say it
was discounted can you just clarify for
us uh who was doing the discounting or
what contacts you're making that comment
in
uh what I was trying to convey there is
that that
um to the point made by one of your
colleagues minutes ago there was uh
there were expressions of of points of
view that there was insufficient
consultation on the invocation of the
ACT
okay and of course
is that right that's my understanding
and of course the federal government
tabled uh with Parliament its
explanation of the consultation process
it undertook
we tabled an extensive report right
now back to this paragraph in the in the
witness statement uh commission Council
has already asked you uh what you meant
by the paragraph more broadly and and
what I've written down in my notes which
um I welcome any corrections uh you have
as I was furiously typing
um what I've written down is that you
explained that you deemed these broader
discussions to be consultations on the
ACT uh because the conversations were
really about the substance of when
they're being the substance of the ACT
about tools what was needed do you
remember saying
yes I do
okay and I just want to clarify uh to
the extent that you're able to answer
this question is it your view that these
broader uh consultations discussions
they're about tools and about substance
but not about the uh emergencies act in
particular is it your view that those
can be considered consultations under
section 25 of the ACT
yes
thank you very much those are my
questions
okay thank you next uh call on the union
of British Columbia Indian cheese
good afternoon
my name is Cheyenne Arnold Cunningham
and I'm Council for the union of BC
Indian chiefs I'm going to be directing
our questions today to Deputy Stewart
so we've heard a lot in this inquiry and
even today on the topic of consultation
um the union of BC Indian chiefs would
like to know what First Nations
governments Representatives members or
indigenous groups did you consult with
during the freedom Convoy situation
I'm not aware
that we consulted with First Nations
on matters associated with
law enforcement in urban
areas or at border points
are you aware of any efforts on behalf
of the government of Canada or police
services to consult with First Nations
of the territory
of the territory
on which the events took place
oh sorry excuse me
um I am not aware
from a public safety perspective would
you agree that it is important for the
government of Canada and police services
to consult and cooperate with First
Nations of the territory in a situation
like this in a public order emergency
event I would agree
thank you are you familiar with Federal
legislation which came into force on
June 21st 2021 to affirm and implement
the United Nations Declaration on the
rights of indigenous peoples
um also known as under
only superficially familiar
um if I could please ask the
last document BCC
49
and I'd like to just quickly go to
section 5 which is on page five of that
legislation
while the clerk brings that up
Section 5 essentially mandates the
government of Canada to in consultation
and cooperation with indigenous peoples
to take all measures necessary to ensure
that the laws of Canada
are consistent with the Declaration
can you explain at all prior to your
departure in the role how laws and
policies were being aligned with under
within Public Safety Canada and how that
would specifically relate to a public
order emergency event
I I can
um
at Public Safety at the current time
there is a very significant engagement
process going on with First Nations on
the issue of
um two on two issues one on um uh
enlarging
um the support for policing that's
provided through our grants and
contributions program called The First
Nations Inuit and Inuit policing program
um and the other part more significant I
would say is on making policing and
drafting legislation co-developing
legislation to make policing an
essential service those in that
engagement process has been going on
since the spring
and has resulted in or involved
extensive consultation across the
country by the minister and officials
um and does relate in its ultimate goal
to ensure in ensuring that first nations
are the beneficiaries of policing
services on an equal basis to other
areas of the country or parts of the
country
um and though therefore by extension
would be
um very much more uh engaged in uh the
management of public order events
thank you did you consider undrip or
work to implement it at all in carrying
out your role and mandate within Public
Safety Canada and specifically in um in
responding to the freedom Convoy
situation well what I just described I
think would be consistent with under it
um and in the Convoy situation uh my
consultations were with Federal
provincial and territorial officials
and okay and just sorry thank you uh
just one last question
is public safetying or policing response
to a public order emergency event from
either a strategic operational or
tactical point of view is it different
depending on who is involved in the
assembly or the event
should not be
um just to follow up on that if I can
keep the same document up but go down to
page 14
appended to the legislation is a copy of
undrip and I'd like to draw your
attention just very quickly to articles
26 and 28.
articles 26 and 28 I won't read through
them for timing purposes but what they
essentially say is that indigenous
peoples have the right to the land's
territories and resources which they've
traditionally owned occupied or
otherwise used and acquired that states
shall give legal recognition and
protection to these lands territories
and resources and that indigenous
peoples have the right to redress
when these lands resources or
territories have been confiscated taken
occupied used or damaged without their
free prior and informed consent
again mind these articles and under Buzz
a hole in the unique distinct legal
rights that indigenous peoples hold does
the protection and recognition of these
rights should they impact how government
responds to those rights in a public
assembly
I don't believe I can answer that
question
would you be able to confirm who you
think might be able to answer that
question
so far as it becomes a matter of
interpretation of undrip I believe
Justice officials would be the first
person first people to ask
very much for both of your time and
efficient for the opportunity to ask our
questions
okay thank you
um next call on the government of Canada
foreign
I'm Robert McKinnon Council for the
government of Canada I wonder just on
that last uh
question you were asked whether we could
go to SSM can
uh five zeros 121
of the consultation report I understand
on page five is relevant
are we on the around the middle of the
page of
consultation uh so that's the bottom go
up a little bit don't go up a little bit
dude stop stop
the government of Canada also engaged
indigenous leaders regarding the
blockades for example the minister of
crown indigenous relations spoke with
the national chief of the Assembly of
First Nations
the president of the Newark intuitive
the president of the metis National
Council the Grand Chief of akosasne and
the Grand Chief of the Manitoba Southern
Chiefs organization
do you see that
I do
is that and for the record when I
answered the question by you're the
person in it prior it was on my own
right involvement all right so do you
see that there's a reference to
consultations there I do okay
uh one of the last uh questioners also
raise the police services Act
uh as to why
um where the RCMP is mentioned perhaps
in that act because it doesn't say
specifically that uh the process is you
go to the opp that's stated but it
doesn't say then you go to the RCMP do
you remember that question I do
uh
we don't have to pull up that Services
act because this is more of a legal
question but section two of the police
services acts defines police force as
OPP or Municipal Police and does not
include the RCMP
does that sound correct to you that
sounds correct and would it uh be to
your understanding that the Ontario
government cannot pass legislation to
bind the RCMP as a federal body that
would be my understanding
you were also asked a question about the
lack of consultation with law
enforcement
do you remember that I do I could ask
you to turn to uh
institutional report for Public Safety
which is d-o-j-i-r-708
if you could go to the appendix Roman
numeral two that's page 27.
and then if you scroll down to page 29
well first this is the list of meetings
attended by yourself Deputy Minister
just so that's what the appendix says
okay
and on page 29 at the top
can you see uh February 5 it includes
meetings with the Ottawa Police February
6th 7th 8th 10th and 11th it includes
meetings with the opp do you see that I
do so did you have some meetings and
consultations with the opp and uh Ottawa
Police yes
uh Mr uh Roshan
uh you mentioned that there were
unknowns in talking about intelligence I
believe in some of your answers and I
just wanted to ask you concerning the
Convoy protest
were there intelligence gaps
uh I would argue there are always
intelligence gaps that's the nature of
the business
part of the
art of collecting intelligence and
fusing it and assessing it is to come up
with questions as to what is in the art
of the possible therefore what do what
is it that we know and what could also
uh transpire and what we need to protect
Canada and Canadians against in terms of
assessing threats so when it comes to
the unknown uh you will have seen
through a number of
Assessments reports whether it be from
the
um integrated
terrorism
Assessment Center itac
or PCO IAS the intelligence assessment
um
Secretariat or indeed from RCMP or
um other other intelligence
organizations they were always flagging
the level of threat they would
articulate it as medium and they would
articulate the possibility of
ideologically motivated violent
extremism and the fact that a lone wolf
could occur and so when when it comes to
assessing intelligence there's always a
a level of uh what is the likelihood
that something could transpire so when
it comes to unknowns there were many
unknowns throughout the situation and as
the situation continued to
be prolonged and indeed as we saw it
expand across the country uh those
questions uh as to whether or not a uh
hostile State actor may be involved in
terms of the funding whether there were
questions of extremist groups or
possible extremist factions involved
would this provide fertile ground for
extremists to
recruit
there were counter protests that were
emerging as well so all of that factored
into a bunch of questions that I would
characterize as unknowns and that needed
to be taken into consideration so it's
not just factually what did we know
because at the end of the day when it
comes to intelligence and when it comes
to law enforcement and security it's not
about
dealing with something once it happens
but it's about preventing something
before it happens and in order to
prevent it you need to think through
what could happen and put in place
measures to protect Canada and Canadians
because you're looking ahead at threats
and you want to protect them from
materializing is that correct that's a
much more eloquent way of putting it yes
uh
Mr Stewart do you have anything to add
to the unknowns
um at the um
at the point where the cabinet made a
recommendation to invoke the ACT
any kind of unknowns
that were in in mind to your knowledge
well I can only be more specific I
believe which is to say on the eve of
enforcement in Ottawa we knew that
enforcement was challenging and we knew
there had been some very significant
negative reactions to attempts at
enforcement such that the police were
deterred from doing so to any great
extent until they mobilized enough of a
critical mass of resources but even on
the eve of that enforcement action
after the emergencies acted invoked we
had of no awareness as to what was in
the trucks or how people who were in the
trucks would react uh to uh an
enforcement action so you could call
that an intelligence Gap or just a lack
of information but but we did not we did
not have a line of sight as to what
would happen
you uh for Mr Stewart you mentioned the
engagement proposal that was considered
by cabinet on February 12th and you were
taken to a comment that was made
uh was the fact that the Windsor
proposed engagement failed earlier that
day and and news later that day that the
Ottawa proposed agreement appeared to
fail
form any part of the consideration by
cabinet in its decision
to not pursue the engagement your
engagement proposal at that time and I'm
talking February 12th the day before
I don't believe I'm at Liberty to
discuss what cabinet
um cabinet ministers said
um I think it's plausible to think that
was in their minds
uh
you also in response to a question you
mentioned a concern that the invocation
of the emergency act might incite rather
than calm the protest do you recall that
as I've just tried to express yes in
hindsight now having seen the evolution
of it
uh would you agree that concern did not
materialize I would agree
you have been taken to page 21 of your
interview summary two or three times now
so I'd like to take you to that same
page again uh for a different paragraph
the WTS uh number of zeros 66
at page 21.
it would be that middle paragraph a DM
Stewart also stated that's right yeah
cool that's right so it where it says DM
Stewart also stated
that they underestimated the the that
they underestimated the deterrent effect
of the ACT ADM
tacklebab emphasized this point adding
that prior to its invocation provinces
including New Brunswick and Quebec were
calling him to express concerns about
border blockades and protests at
legislatures after the Act was invoked
those calls stopped and within a week of
the ACT being invoked the protests and
blockades were gone
so in your
um
view of that you're saying that the ACT
had a deterrent effect from your
inference is that correct I am
one last document I'd like to take you
to
um
is this the actual section 58
explanation
uh for the invocation which that's PB
can
four zeros one one six zero
foreign
just to make sure PB can sorry yeah one
one six zero yeah that's it so if you go
to uh
page bottom of page five
yeah that's it so where it says violent
incidents so
it says violent incidents and threats of
violence and protests
and arrests sorry related to the
protests have been reported across
Canada
the rcmp's recent seizure of a cache of
firearms with a large quantity of
ammunition in Kutz Alberta indicated
that there are elements within the
protests that have intentions to engage
in violence
ideologically motivated violent
extremism adherence may feel empowered
by the level of disorder resulting from
the protests violent online rhetoric
increased threats against public
officials in the physical presence of
ideological extremists of protests also
indicate that there's a risk of serious
violence and the potential for loan
actor attackers to conduct terrorism
attacks
the question for both of you can you
provide any comments on this as to
whether these are accurate facts to your
knowledge
I believe them to be true
and in a more General sense I will
underline a point made by my colleague
that this is a devolving
situation and the
focus on
uh violent extremism has shifted from
coming from abroad to to domestic
um and uh in the context in which we are
and I've said this under equipped and
indeed not empowered to do the work that
we need to do to pay attention to what
uh people's intentions are
um
I would note that since 2014
there has been significant domestic
violent extremism
I believe the numbers are 26 people
killed and 40 injured
in uh over a dozen attacks uh Often by
Lone Wolf actors with no prior
indication that they would do so
so this is a very serious concern
and uh Mr Rochelle the only thing I
would add is is that
um
the opinion around the security and
intelligence Community was that this the
paragraph that you read was uh factually
correct there were indications of
potential uh violent acts uh imve
adherence that
um were certainly engaging online and
were making threats online and and we
needed to be mindful that those threats
could materialize at any moment given
the growing nature of the uh the
situation both in Ottawa and across the
country
okay could you turn to page uh the
middle of page seven
right so where it starts in addition I'm
not going to read this paragraph to you
I'll just let you look at that and just
go down the page I'm just going to ask a
general question it talks about
essentially 13
um
protests that are being referred to
directly important impacting Port of
operations for major ports of Entry
operations and if you go yeah
so it mentions uh over the next
page as well it continues yeah
so
I just want you to confirm your
understanding of these facts and any
comment you might have that the report
mentions 13 protests that directly
impacted Port of operations and
disrupted them in the days leading up to
this declaration
and so there's 12 in addition to the
Ambassador Bridge
more specifically it mentions
disruptions
at ports of Entry at the time of
invocation that we're still of concern
in addition to Ambassador Bridge at
Windsor the Sarnia Blue Water Bridge the
Peace Bridge at Fort Erie Emerson
Manitoba Couts Alberta Surrey BC on the
way uh you know from the Pacific Highway
do you agree with
that those facts as they've been laid
out
yes
and I would also add
um while these were clear and obvious
manifestations of
um
interference with
um people's ability to cross the border
and uh Commerce there were many other
Slow Roll convoys in other places in the
country and so it was
um
uh also a consideration that they might
manifest at other ports of Entry or
indeed elsewhere and interfere with as I
say
um people's lives but would that be part
of the unknowns yes
and at page nine
of the same report
uh in the lower half of the page where
it starts threats
a page
a page not yes stopped right there yet
so that paragraph it was not just ports
of Entry or protests
that we've identified so far it mentions
that there were threats also made to
block railway lines that wouldn't result
in significant disruptions to Canada's
Freight rail industry in addition to
service I'm sure
of substantial
monetary loss can you see that there I
can't and what's your comment on that
um we heard about threats I don't
believe they ever manifested as
blockades on a railway line but two
years ago in 2020 in February we
experienced that
occurrence and it was a very significant
event from an economic point of view
and my last question is at page 11.
the bottom paragraph or sorry the middle
paragraph
it starts there's significant evidence
that's right
there's significant evidence of illegal
activity to date in the situation across
the country
remains concerning volatile and
unpredictable
the freedom Convoy could also lead to an
increase in the number of individuals
who support ideologically motivated
violent extremism and the prospect for
serious violence proponents of imv are
driven by a range of influences rather
than a single belief system
imv radicalization is more often caused
by a combination of ideas and grievances
resulting in a personalized world view
the resulting worldview often centers on
the willingness to incite enable or
mobilize violence
do you have any comment on for both of
you
that that paragraph
I think it accurately reflects the views
of officials in the government when the
emergencies Act was invoked
exactly I mean what I was trying to
explain earlier on today when I was
asked a question
uh is is captured in that paragraph and
that there there was the threat that the
longer that
um this situation
uh was allowed to uh to happen the the
more likely it was that imve groups
would take advantage of it and that was
a significant concern for the security
intelligence community
those are my questions thank you
thank you any uh re-examination a reply
just one area briefly commissioner okay
go ahead
um Mr Stewart this is uh just an area of
questioning arising from the questions
you were asked around police
Independence and uh also relating to
some evidence that we heard from Mr D
Tomaso last week
um so Mr clerk can I just ask you to
pull up
now I lost the document number it's OPP
I think 404583
while that's coming up Mr Stewart this
is a text exchange between commissioner
lucky and commissioner karique
foreign
go to page 52
of the document
bottom right hand corner yeah there we
go okay so just scroll up a little bit
so starting at the text that says so the
green here is commissioner Creek and the
blue is commissioner lucky and the
context of the conversation is with
respect to
um the potential new Chief coming into
opioid into Ops
so
commissioner Creek writes with respect
to your comments yesterday I agree we
need to ensure Ops leaves Steve and play
until we have done what we need to do
introducing a new external player in the
short term will set us back
commissioner lucky then replies I will
see what I can do to get them to delay
bringing in an interim Chief if you
think that will help
commissioner Creek responds if you have
some influence I think it would be
helpful our ministry policing advisor is
going to suggest the same just going on
to the next page
10 4th as commissioner lucky and then
then she says had DM Stewart Reach into
Steve K Ottawa city manager he assures
that they are very sensitive to this
Keen for the ICC plan to proceed and
don't want Belle to be replaced Rob
robbing you got the sense that there's a
lot of political infighting going on and
then commissioner Cree says thanks
Brenda we've made the same
recommendation by The Province hopefully
they stay the course
okay
um so first thing can you tell us first
about that conversation that you had
with commissioner lucky when did she
reach out to you do you remember
um no I'm not in specific terms I mean
we talked often several times a day okay
do you remember this conversation
I do at all okay what did she raise what
were her concerns
uh well
um more or less as expressed by the city
manager there that they wanted
um to keep the ICC which they just
agreed to uh not that long before and
its ability to
um you know execute on a plan going and
they worried that that would be set back
they were ready to go
on the 16th of February
so that was
um the message
um and I undertook to talk to Steve
canalakos
and his answer as as she represents it
that the city
was not going to get an interim Chief
they were going to go with acting Chief
Bell okay do you remember when you
called Mr kanalakis
well sometime in that timeline I would I
would say fair enough
um
and what did you tell him how did he
respond I would have said to him I'm
hearing from uh probably just directly
the commissioner that
um there are concerns about
um you know changing up the guard here
in Ottawa what's your plan and would ask
them the question and do you remember
what what he replied
yeah I kind of paraphrased by this
message okay
um and the reference here to a lot of
political infighting uh can you explain
or elaborate that on that at all
um
it was
um it is my understanding that
uh what the Ottawa Police board was
doing was working to
um find an interim chief
um and the uh police boards by their
nature are independent from the
municipal government although they're
chaired by a counselor
and
um it had not been uh known that they
were doing that
um to anybody
um and that you know when it uh surfaced
as an issue it caused um
some consternation at the senior level
in the city government
um and then as an observational point I
would only say that
Within
um a couple of days I believe there was
a city council meeting in which the
chair of the police board was forced to
resign
that's that's correct so did that come
up on on the call with you had with Mr
canalakos the potential removal of the
chair or
only tangentially
did he mention that he'd be speaking to
the chair about no he didn't no he just
said the mayor is upset
um thank you Mr Clark can we now just
pull up an extract from Mr D Tomaso's
testimony uh it's TR and
21.
at around page 244 please
so we're 250 apparently
of the PDF
okay
so I'm just going to take you through Mr
dear Tomaso's comments on that exchange
and ask you for your view so starting at
the very bottom so we
um commission Council goes through the
exchange and then asks Mr G Tomaso to
what extent were you aware of these
discussions that were being had with
respect to the chief of police in Ottawa
and on the next page Mr diet Mossman
replies in autoware at all and what my
position was with regards to the
selection of the next chief
that was the exclusive jurisdiction of
the Police Services Board and I
certainly didn't want my advisor to
interfere with that at all okay says
commission Council and the discussions
that are being had here would you agree
that this is impermissible the kind of
political interference and something
that's in the exclusive purview of the
board Mr D Tomaso says I don't know
whether anyone fellow followed up with
these actions at all but I made it clear
to both Ken Wetherill and the advisor
that they were not to interfere with the
exclusive jurisdiction of the board and
it was the board's sole responsibility
to select the next chief full stop
and then commission Council asks so if
these actions had been taken is it
review that they would that this would
have been on Pro improper and uh Mr
tishmasa says yes
um can we just get your views on that as
well Mr Stewart
sorry this is a domain of a Mr D tomasos
of which I'm really very unfamiliar I
don't I don't understand
or have deep knowledge of the operation
of local police governance that's fair
enough thank you those are my questions
okay well thank you very much for your
testimony
um and nowhere you're now free to go and
uh we appreciate your coming uh to
testify at the commission thank you
commissioner thank you so we'll uh I
think we'll take it the afternoon uh
break 15 minutes and when we come back
there's a new panel so
15 minutes the commission is in recess
for 15 minutes
literally lost
thank you very much
order a lot
the commission is reconvened the
commission
okay
we have two new Witnesses we do indeed
shantona shodary for the commission for
the record our new Witnesses we're
changing gears completely heard from
Public Safety all day so far and now
we're going to Global Affairs so uh the
commission is called Ms Cindy Thomas
heisen and Mr Joe Co Martin to the stand
foreign
will you swear on a religious document
or do you wish to affirm a wish to
affirm for the record please State your
full name and spell it out
uh Cynthia tremorse heisen do you want
both names spelled yes please
c-y-n-t-h-i-a
-t-e-r-m-o-r-s-h-u-i-z-e-n
do you solemnly affirm that the evidence
to be given by you to this commission
shall be the truth the whole truth and
nothing but the truth I do thank you Mr
Martin will you swear on a religious
document or do you wish to affirm
elsewhere in the Bible
for the record please State your full
name and spell it out Joseph comarten
j-o-s-e-p-h
-c-o-m-a-r-t-i-n do you swear that the
evidence to be given by you to this
commission shall be the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
you God I do thank you
foreign
thank you Mr commissioner I'll just note
that I'll be conducting the first half
of the examination then my colleague
Miss Dalia shuhabar will be taking over
good afternoon Mr Moore Tyson Mr Cole
Martin thank you for being here
um we'll just start by introducing your
witness summary so
um Mr Clark can you pull up
WTF
56052 space
you'll recall having thought for an
interview on August 23rd with commission
Council yes yes
and you've had a chance to review this
this interview summary yes okay and
you'll note that uh certain interviewees
uh who are present at the interview are
not present today namely Ms Martin
Morgan Deputy Minister Mr Loken Mr
Sebastian boulier
um can you confirm on your own behalf
that you reviewed the summary and that
it's accurate to the best of your
knowledge and that in so far as it
contains the information provided by
your absent colleagues they have
reviewed and accepted it as well yes yes
uh then the second uh just a little
piece of housekeeping is the
institutional report so Mr clerk that's
d-o-j-i-r
-702.
so Mr Mercy senior uh do you recognize
this as the institutional report
provided by global Affairs Canada yes
and you've reviewed it yes and you
confirmed that it's accurate to the best
of your knowledge yes okay thank you
very much
um okay so I'll just start now by asking
you each of you to introduce yourselves
um so starting with you Mr Morris Eisen
can you tell us you're well I understand
you're the associate Deputy Minister of
Foreign Affairs can you just tell us
briefly describe that role
sure uh so in maybe just by way of
context uh Global Affairs Canada has
four Deputy ministers there's a deputy
minister of international trade of
Foreign Affairs and International
Development and then there's a fourth
Deputy Minister which is my role which
is the associate Deputy Minister of
Foreign Affairs and so in that role I
support the deputy Minister of Foreign
Affairs and the Minister of Foreign
Affairs in the overall management of the
department but also in the management of
foreign policy files that are delegated
to me okay and the deputy ministers
we've seen as Miss Marta Morgan or at
least was at the time of the Convoy I
think recently changed that's correct
she retired but she was at the time of
the convoys okay and the minister of a
foreign affairs is
exactly okay
and and Mr Co Martin um can you tell us
your position why your position is
Consul general of the Detroit consulate
but tell us a little bit about what that
role involves um yes I was Consul
General in Detroit until the end of
September of this year
um the consulate uh is responsible for
four states in the United States
Michigan uh Ohio Kentucky and Indiana
um
I would say our primary work is divided
between certainly Consular Affairs but
that's a small part of what we do
um the other major part is a breakdown
between uh the trading relationship
between the two countries and the amount
of work that we do in terms of contacts
with mostly with the business community
on the other side of the office deals
with the political and uh academic and
people like that okay
um
I'll now ask you to describe at a very
high broad level how each of your roles
was engaged at the time of the Convoy so
during the Convoy generally speaking
what was your role in all of this so um
for instance uh Mr morseisen I
understand that you essentially oversaw
um the gax response gak being Global
Affairs Canada's response to the events
as they were unfolding of the freedom
Convoy is that right that's correct uh
so at the time where the convoys were
starting we actually had another crisis
situation Brewing which was the imminent
invasion of Ukraine by Russia and so
Deputy Minister Morgan made the decision
that she would focus on Ukraine
primarily and would delegate
responsibility to me to handle the
headquarters aspects of the Convoy
related issues so my primary role at the
time was to participate in the regular
meetings of the dmoc the deputy
Minister's operations committee that I
think you've heard about earlier uh in
these sessions and then also I engaged
with a number of colleagues in the
department particularly our colleagues
responsible for North America relations
and then also colleagues in protocol
which is a part of the department that
is responsible for supporting foreign
missions in Canada okay we'll be getting
into all of that democ is one acronym
that we actually have learned today but
thank you for there are a lot and
especially in global Affairs it's
challenging
um
and our understanding is that uh along
with Deputy Minister Morgan Minister
Jolie's time was very much occupied by
Ukraine during this period is that
accurate absolutely she also was very
focused on Ukraine
and Mr Cole Martin can you tell us at a
high level what your involvement was
during the time of Convoy
but I have to say it was it was mostly
reactive we were being contacted
um both from elected officials
particularly from Michigan but also from
Ohio and a good number of uh senior
business people uh particularly from the
Auto industry in the manufacturing
sector as well uh some from the
agricultural sector
basically looking for
I guess information from us as to how
the blockade at the Windsor Detroit
tunnel was going to her Bridge was going
to be dealt with okay so essentially uh
interacting with U.S officials and and
business stakeholders okay yes we'll be
looking at some specific examples of
that but before we get there
um can you just tell about the very
early days of the Convoy when did uh
when did the Convoy hit the radar so to
speak at Gak
um I would say it probably hit the radar
when it did for a lot of average
Canadians we first started hearing about
a convoy potentially coming to Ottawa in
sort of late January
um and so we were very much following
the news and that would be when we first
were aware of it okay and within the
department what was the what was the
reaction at that point or response but
so I think the initial
um
response was like a response to maybe
other protests that had happened in the
past in Ottawa I mean there Ottawa is
the capital city and so protests are not
infrequent uh and so I think my own
early thoughts were I wonder what kind
of road closures there will be we might
have to ask staff to redirect
um so initially it was I think that kind
of response and then of course as the
Convoy actually came to Ottawa and
settled in there were other reactions
and you were attending the daily dmoc
meetings as they were happening on
behalf of gak yeah so the daily democs
didn't start until I think it was around
February the 10th
um according to my recollection the the
first dmoc discussion that I attended
where the Convoy was a specific topic of
conversation was January the 31st okay
so that's also I think that's when it
started to be a a topic of discussions
interdepartmentally that I was a part
part of so that would be the Monday
after the first weekend essentially I'll
take your word for it that it was Monday
it doesn't matter too much day of the
week but that's the approximate moment
in time okay
um so what would you say that the gax
Mandate became very engaged
so
um I think initially the Mandate was
around
um wanting to ensure that we were living
up to our obligations under the Vienna
convention on diplomatic relations so
this is the international legal
instrument under which we're responsible
for ensuring the security of diplomatic
missions in Canada and so in the
downtown core area that was affected by
the Convoy initially there were about 50
diplomatic properties most of them were
embassies a couple of them official
residences so those are the homes of
ambassadors or high Commissioners and so
the department under that legal
instrument has a particular
responsibility to ensure the safety and
security of diplomatic missions and
their staff and to ensure that they're
able to access their facilities
unimpeded that their Consular clients
are able to attend to those building so
that was the early area of focus for us
and this was primarily done at the
working level in the early days
and then the second aspect of our
mandate that really started to come into
play a little bit later was
um with the blockades of various border
crossings and particularly the blockade
of the Ambassador Bridge became an
enormous area of focus just because it's
such an important Crossing about 25
percent of our trade with the United
States goes over the Ambassador Bridge
so that's when there started to be an
enormous amount of Engagement
particularly with U.S officials
but also concerns that we started to
have about our reputation as an
international trading country and as an
Inc as a country that was safe for
investment and that started to come up
as we headed into sort of the seventh in
a the February and thereafter
okay
um
we'll come back to all of that my
colleague Mr habar will be asking me
some more specific questions about the
missions
um and and I'll be asking you some
questions now about the your engagement
with U.S officials and what you were
hearing but before we get there
um I just want to set the stage
contextually a little bit
um some things that you brought up in in
your interview and are also referred to
in the institutional reports and in the
documents so you've mentioned that
Ukraine was a crisis the gak was dealing
with at the time as well
um and there's a couple of other
contextual elements so Mr clerk I'll ask
you to bring up PB can five zeros 27.
and if you can just scroll down to page
three
there we go so this is a tweet from
representative Elisa slotkin that's
mentioned uh several times in the
documents we received from gak first of
all who's Representatives like can you
tell us
maybe I'll direct that to Mr kobarton
who knows this better than I do
um she's a member of the House of
Representatives at the federal level in
the United States
as an interesting background she
actually was
uh she was posted a number of times in
uh in Iraq she has a military background
and I believe also some association with
with CIA at one period of time
she uh but uh this this particular quote
uh but frankly was of concern to us
um in terms of the context she was
speaking about the impact that blockade
was having at one of the auto plants
that is in her District okay so we'll
just take a moment to read through that
quote
um it's a tweet I believe on February
3rd is the date and it says if sorry
just scroll up a tiny bit thank you it'd
be later than that if we needed another
example of why Supply chains matter look
no further it might be the ninth uh the
blockade of the Ambassador Bridge that's
right so I think it's the ninth the
busiest border crossing in America is
already creating major disruptions for
our businesses in Michigan and just
scroll down a little Mr Clark the next
tweet she says
uh Michigan Earth have been saying for
decades that when our manufacturing
Outsource too much we end up paying the
price it doesn't matter if it's an
adversary or an ally we can't be this
reliant on parts coming from foreign
countries I've been in contact with the
white house today about the situation
they're closely following these events
we're waiting for the Prime Minister
Trudeau's Way Forward so yes thank you
for the correction on the date I believe
it's the ninth
um and then she goes on to say the one
thing that couldn't be more clear is
that we have to bring American
manufacturing back home to States like
Michigan if we don't it's American
workers like the folks at Delta Township
who are left holding the bag
so can you tell us a little bit
generally about that that concept of
bringing manufacturing back to the US
and and what was going on generally in
the Zeitgeist at the time so maybe I'll
start and Mr Cole Martin might might
want to add
um a couple of different things that I
would point to First from a Canadian
perspective we were quite concerned
because of course the block blockade of
the Ambassador Bridge was happening
after two years of covid where we're
already seeing Supply chains um quite
stressed a lot of businesses were
already under considerable strain
and so I think there was a lot of
concern um on the part of businesses
that was exacerbated by that background
um the second issue is that
um we have over many many years had to
fight very hard for
um access to American markets and also
for
um the supply chains including with
respect to the Auto industry uh in
Canada there's a strong Trend towards
buy America in the United States and
also a strong Trend among some parts of
the U.S political class to bring
manufacturing back to the United States
and so there's an ongoing effort by
global Affairs by other Federal
departments but also by provincial
governments and our missions in the
United States to continually make the
case that Canada is a reliable training
partner and also a reliable investment
partner and so that's very much the
context behind this okay
so so this tweet would essentially be an
example of that bring manufacturing back
home sentiment absolutely Mr Co Martin
would you have anything to add to that
um well just that this was the the uh
her comments were the strongest that we
had from any of the elected
representatives
um I think it reflected to some degree
the passion she feels for her for her
District but it also reflects a certain
level of ignorance in terms of the
relationship the treaty relationship we
have between ourselves Canada Canada the
US and Mexico which we had just gone
through you know in the previous couple
of years of renegotiating that agreement
and this idea of you know bringing back
uh manufacturing to the United States
even from allies would have been a
complete contradiction of that agreement
so that you're referring to the
renegotiation of NAFTA yes okay
okay well let's start looking at some of
the the specific examples of of
communications or statements that were
made by U.S officials
um
I don't know if you want to start or
please do start actually by giving a
general overview of what you were
hearing Mr kobart
um well a great deal of concern coming
from the the elected both senators and
members of the House of Representatives
uh I was dealing with those who were
from my my territory
um
I think one of the messages was the the
impact it was having on the on the
supply chain
um they also were expressing
repeatedly I got messaging to the extent
that why isn't Canada doing more uh
their analysis was that the three levels
of government were not cooperating
didn't have a coordinated plan that was
the kind of perception they had of what
was going on and that was difficult for
us to respond to in the first in the
first couple of days certainly by the
10th and the 11th we were we were able
to point out that we were dealing with
specific responses but that message was
quite strong that they did not see that
the all levels of government were
responding in a coordinated fashion okay
um at this point Mr clerk can you pull
up PB can 40 1661
so I appreciate this isn't an email that
either of you received
um it is your colleague Mr co uh Mr
Komar and I'm sorry Martin Logan uh
who's the deputy head of mission foreign
policy and National Security at the
Canadian embassy in Washington and he's
writing to Jody Thomas whom we've heard
as the National Security advisor and he
says at the bottom here concern about
Ottawa situation now overshadowed by the
blocked Ambassador Bridge and supply
chain disruptions to Detroit there is a
sense Canada is not devoting enough
resources human or otherwise to dislodge
the truckers so is is that an example of
what you were just telling us about yes
sentiment and that's something that Mr
Logan was hearing and you were hearing
as well
yes we were hearing that directly from
the White House he was and I was getting
it locally in in our territory my
territory okay and Mr morseis and you
were hearing that as well that's right
we were also hearing that directly from
the United States Embassy here here in
Ottawa
and then also uh there were a number of
conversations at the ministerial level
um between various departments where
similar concerns were being conveyed
um
then if we can just turn up SSM can five
zeros442
and just scroll down a little bit please
so this is a public statement by uh
Governor Whitmer so that's the governor
of Michigan I take it that's correct
okay and uh scroll down a little bit she
says at the beginning my message is
simple reopen traffic on the bridge
scrolling down onto the next page
it is imperative the Canadian local
provincial and National governments
de-escalate this economic blockade they
must take all necessary and appropriate
steps to immediately safely reopen
traffic so we can continue growing our
economy some supporting good paying jobs
and lowering costs for families
um
so I can just ask you this so this
statement I believe the date was
February 9th as well
uh and this was a public statement made
so in addition to Direct Communications
being made to you there were there were
politicians making public statements and
what was the purpose of that do you
believe
um I think the public statements
um were very much an opportunity to send
a message not only to the Canadian
government but also I would suspect to
their own publics
um to make clear that they were working
hard to do something about this
situation I mean the impact
of the closure of the Ambassador Bridge
was almost immediate particularly on the
auto sector which Mr Co Martin would
know better than me is a critical part
of the Michigan economy and of course if
the Ontario economy as well
Mr Cole Martin why don't you tell us a
bit now about what you were hearing from
the Auto industry from who and what they
were saying
well starting on the on late in the day
on the 7th which is when the uh it first
got shut down uh we were already hearing
from them of having to shut down lines
of production
um they were beginning to look at uh
alternate ways of moving the product
across which was primarily going to be
it turned out they were already looking
at it but primarily at the Blue Water
Bridge up at Sarnia Port Huron
um and at other methodologies of trying
to move their product uh they were
trying to wear my Diplomat hat here for
a second they were much more
aggressive
that's not the right term they were much
more forceful in their comments about
the fact that Canada had to get you know
get there
uh their organization in place and and
uh and get this stopped uh right away
okay Mr Clark can we pull up SSM NSC can
40s 1605.
scroll down to page three please
okay so this is a weekly advocacy report
that sort of Recaps what happened over
the the course of February 7th to 11th
and the first thing addressed
essentially it Recaps some of the
conversations you've had Mr Co Martin so
I'm hoping you can take us through a few
of these with the the assistance of the
notes here so the first thing that's
mentioned is a call that you had with
congresswoman Brenda Lawrence and I
believe that was in response to a public
statement that she had made the day
before or earlier also calling on the
Canadian government to do something
about the Ambassador Bridge
um that is accurate but it also was
um she had been been wanting a call with
the Ambassador our Canadian Ambassador
in Washington and who was not available
at that particular time so it was
offered that I would speak to her
initially I've had I've had several
content I have had several contacts with
her before
um uh you know worked on a number of
items of relative interest to the two
jurisdictions so that's how the call
came about and she did I believe
subsequently have a call with the
Ambassador
the important part about her role is
that both the Ambassador Bridge and the
the tunnel are in her District as is the
new crossing that's uh that's being
built currently so she has a major
interest in the in the impact that this
was having and again she had Automotive
plants and other manufacturing plants
that were being negatively impacted
already okay
if we can just scroll down a little bit
more Mr Clark the second call that's
mentioned is with congresswoman Dingle
can you tell us a bit about the context
of that one
yeah I've had
quite a lengthy uh contact with her
prior to the blockade
um
uh I had pushed for this call because
she had been on as it happens on CBC the
night before and that have been on the
10th and had made some which surprised
me quite frankly because we've always
had a very close working relationship
and she has with Canada as well I made
some statements that were fairly close
to what uh the statements were that you
saw from Lisa uh slotkin so I wanted to
raise that with her and so we had a a
good conversation
um I I had asked her uh in keeping with
what calls I had had with representative
kildee and with Senator Peters that we
were seeking from them
for them when they were talking about
this in public that they would stress
the importance of the relationship
between Canada and the United States and
she assured me in the course this
conversation that she would attempt to
do that going forward I think the other
point of this this particular time so it
was easier for me I think to convince
her to be sympathetic was the injunction
either had been granted I think this was
that call was in the morning injunction
was granted by the Superior Court in uh
in Windsor later that day and I had seen
I had assured her that I had expected it
would be a positive order and the
injunction would be granted so you know
proof positive I guess that we were we
as a jurisdiction we're moving on this
taking some action okay
um then the next call referred to just
scrolling down a bit is the Detroit
Regional Chamber on on February 10th
yeah president Guru is a um uh been a
long time friend he's the head of the
Detroit Regional Chamber of Commerce
which takes in not only the city of
Detroit but a number of the
municipalities in in Southern Michigan
it's the most influential chamber in the
state
um and again he was
speaking forcefully this was the day
before I had told him the injunction had
been sought but had been kicked over to
the following day
but was quite positive in uh
willingness I guess to to send his
messaging out to his membership and to
the general public about the importance
of the relationship that it was a strong
one and needed to be needed to be
preserved
and the next series of calls there
that's that are mentioned is the oesa
and Mema can you tell us about those
conversations who those are those
organizations and what was said yeah
they're both basically manufacturing
associations
um the uh you always say stairs for
original equipment suppliers Association
and then the motor equipment supplies
again we've had extensive contact with
these uh associations over the years uh
they're very knowledgeable of the
importance of the supply chain
relationship between the two countries
they were
mysterian in particular was
um
upset she'd raised the concept of the
emergency act whether it was going to be
a state of emergency was going to be
declared I don't think she understood
the the act itself but uh wanted that at
that point my information was that it
was not being considered I didn't have
any indication to the opposite
um and indicated some of the other
things that we were doing again this
this call took place on the 11th the day
the injunction of it granted and I think
this call took place after it was
granted so I was able to say we've got
that and at that time I think I also
knew that the province was moving on
their emergency legislation as well okay
so that's February 11th and you were
specifically asked by the stream whether
uh the Canadian government was planning
on or intending to invoke emergency
legislation and your information at that
time was no that was what I had to
communicate to her okay
I think in the interest of time we'll
leave that document
um
can we pull up Mr Clark PB can 5038
foreign
bottom half okay yeah that's exactly
where we're supposed to be thank you so
this is an email from Steph no Marin
who's that can you identify who Stefano
marinus
he's an employee at our Embassy in
Washington okay and he's writing to
master Hillman uh and Mr Locust and Mr
Co Martin are both copied on this
um he's giving an overview that the
situation key takeaways and one of the
things he says about Midway down that
paragraph is he emphasized the shared
nature of he's talking about a
conversation with representative kildee
uh can you just tell us who who
representative killed he is he is a
representative for one of the districts
in Michigan I think the important thing
to know about him in terms of his
background is he was a strong proponent
of
um
the where on the side issue here but uh
the tax credits for the electric uh
batteries and uh thank you and
um uh they've been strong on on pushing
this that those the these credits were
going to be limited to batteries having
to be built in the United States as
opposed to in Canada and Mexico so his
um his support that we were trying to
get to uh have them uh agree that the
credit should be granted to vehicles or
batteries built in both Mexico and
Canada his his support was really
important uh that we were able to do
that which we eventually did but at this
period of time it was still up in the
air and so we really needed to get him
on sign as much as we possibly could
okay so representative kildee is someone
that you essentially needed on your side
in this in this battle okay and what Mr
Logan mentions in this evening sorry
it's not Mr Logan it's Mr Marin mentions
in this emails he emphasized the shared
nature of the channel and referencing
American Support including through
funding for the convoys in Canada and
then the many wages in which the
officials are working together is is
that something that you were hearing
about as well American Funding American
support for the convoys in Canada
so maybe I'll start and again Mr Cole
Martin may need to add something but
there were a number of concerns first
about first of all about
um American citizens
um funding through some of the
um kind of crowd funding platforms that
were being used by the Convoy and in
fact
um there was information when one of
these crowd funding platforms was hacked
that a very large percentage of the
funding was actually coming from U.S
sources so that was something that I was
aware of
um and there was also concern about the
Ottawa 911 number being flooded and many
of the callers were actually from the
United States and this prevented Auto
emergency services from
appropriately doing their work and I
believe both of these issues were
referenced in the call that took place
between President Biden and prime
minister Trudeau around this
um and I think these were referred to as
well in the readout of that call
I think that's right and we'll probably
be hearing more about that as the the
next couple of weeks unfold
um for now I think we've probably've
given us a good overview of what you
were hearing from the United States so
we're going to move to other countries
now Mr clerk if you can pull up
ssm.nsc dot can five
zeros156 please
thank you
so this is the material that was
prepared for you Mr morseisen uh
skipping a little ahead in time on on
February 14th but it gives a bit of a
summary of of some of the things that
were were being said so if we can just
scroll down a little bit Mr clerk to
where it says top level messaging there
Gat continues to monitor the situation
in the U.S and around the world
concerned that the Canadian
quote-unquote model is being exported
and that the Canadian flag is being
misused as a symbol to fuel protests and
capitals around the world EG France
Belgium Netherland New Zealand can you
tell us about that Mr Morrison what you
were hearing what was going on sure I
mean one of the things that we are
always worried about is Canada's
reputation abroad and that's for a
number of reasons
um from an economic perspective we're a
very trade and investment dependent
economy over 60 percent of the value of
our GDP is made up of international
trade and goods and services so we're a
particularly trade dependent country and
so we need to maintain a strong and
positive reputation as a place where
people can safely trade and invest and
do business
and part of that sort of positive
trading and investment climate is a
climate where the law is respected and
so clearly what we were saying during
this period was a very significant
Defiance of the law at both significant
border crossings and in some of our
large cities including Ottawa I think we
were also really concerned from a
broader reputational perspective that
our flag was being used in some of these
copycat protests that were happening
around the world the flag is a symbol of
our country and it was being used
frankly as a symbol of defiance of the
law and we were quite concerned about
those reputational impacts okay we're
gonna come back to some of the copycat
protests in this but I just want to take
you to something else right now because
it came up Mr Claire can you pull up SSM
NSC can five zeros141 please
okay so again this is some material that
I believe was being prepared for you and
if in preparation for a demog Mr Morris
hyacin
um we'll scroll down a little bit to
page two please there we go
impact on Canada us so this is going to
the trade impact
um that you mentioned so it says there's
a high level of U.S concern on
implications on flow of goods ripple
effect of protests across the U.S then
it says immediate trade impact 2.4
billion a day two-way trade 500 million
by Ambassador Bridge alone and then some
talk about the longer term impact and
pressure on for near Shoring Supply
chains um so first of all was gak doing
its own economic analysis or analysis of
trade impact or where did this
information come from do you know
so I don't know what the exact source of
these particular stats were
um we do have a chief Economist at
Global Affairs Canada and so
um our chief Economist
um in in particular one of the areas
that she and her team monitor is our
International Trade performance and so
she will she and her team will regularly
produce stats on those issues so these
may have come from our chief Economist I
I can't confirm that we did not do to my
knowledge at least uh detailed economic
assessments of the specific impact
um I believe other departments uh were
doing that including the Department of
Finance and possibly the Department of
Transport but um specific economic
impact assessments weren't being done to
my knowledge by global Affairs Canada
okay so you had less knowledge of the
specifics and more of the broader
pictures that is that fair that's right
I mean we we would definitely as a
department have information on you know
sort of average daily trade on the scale
of the of the trading relationship with
the United States trade flows that kind
of thing okay thank you thank you Mr
clerk we'll go back now to SSM and SC
can 156.
sorry
we can scroll down to page two please
keep scrolling
keep scrolling Okay so
we're talking now about what happened in
Wellington being New Zealand
um the Super Bowl can you go just give
us a bit of a an overview of those
concerns Mr Morris Eisen
sure one of the things that we were
monitoring is
um the extent to which uh the Convoy
protests and economic blockades in
Canada were being
um copied if you will in other countries
and I would say probably the largest uh
copycat protest that we saw was in
Wellington sort of quite similar
phenomenon of large numbers of protests
entrenching protesters entrenching
themselves around the Parliamentary
Precinct in Wellington we also saw other
protests of smaller scale in The Hague
in Paris there were some smaller ones I
think in Rome in Sweden so we were
monitoring these protests
okay uh thank you Mr clerk next document
I'd like to pull up is SSM NSC can 50703
so this again is on the topic of
concerns being heard from other
countries
um this is an email sent by Ralph
Goodale so can you just tell us what Mr
Goodale's position is yes Mr Goodale is
Canada's High Commissioner to London
England okay and he was writing to a
number of people at Global Affairs can
we scroll down please Mr Clerk
um two themes he says uh disbelief that
this is happening in Canada of all
places and no one wants this to become
an unwelcome Canadian export as the
protests spread elsewhere
um can you tell are you familiar with
this email yes I am okay can you tell us
a little bit about what Mr Goodale was
saying and you have in front of you for
your reference but uh where this email
came from and what was being expressed
and why
uh so I we had asked a number of our
missions abroad so that's our embassies
High commissions and consulates general
to report back if they saw these kinds
of protests emerging in other countries
so well I can't say exactly what Mr
Goodale was was thinking when he wrote
this my interpretation of this is that
um you know a lot of people that he was
talking with were surprised that in
Canada you would see protests like this
where there was widespread violation of
the law
um and that this wasn't the kind of
protest that people would associate with
Canada
um and I think also uh one of the things
that uh we were talking about at the
time was also the significant impact of
disinformation on
um the climate here in Canada
um and abroad so uh that was how I
interpreted his message
okay and if we can just scroll down to
the next page please
there if it's the last paragraph uh the
concluding paragraph of Mr Goodale's
email he says two consequences need to
be watched very carefully the negative
economic and reputational impacts from
trade disruptions
and the possible impression that
Canadian police security and
intelligence systems are incapable of
responding effectively to blatant
large-scale illegal conduct
elaborate a bit on that concern
so I talked about it a little bit
earlier but you know from a Canadian
government perspective
we always need to ensure that we remain
a country that is seen as welcoming
um to foreign investment to
International Trade those are really
some of the foundations of our economic
prosperity and one of the foundations of
you know being able to have that kind of
trade and investment environment is to
have the rule of law uh and I think
there were real concerns as as Mr
Goodale is expressing here in his uh in
his email
um that perhaps Canada was not able to
respond effectively uh to some of the
illegal actions that we were seeing in
the protests and then I think more
broadly it's not just about that trade
and investment environment it's also
um the fact that you know Canada wants
to protect its reputation more broadly
as a country where there was rule of law
alongside democracy
okay
um the last question I'll ask you when
closing has to do specifically with the
section 58 explanation provided by the
government it's one line we can pull it
up if you'd like to have it in front of
you or or I can just read it sure okay
it's uh calm
50670
[Applause]
okay I think it's the bottom of page one
yeah there we go bullet number three
references
uh as part of the justification for the
for the emergencies act the adverse
effects resulting from the impacts of
the blockades on Canada's relationship
with its trading partners including the
us that are detrimental to the interests
of Canada so the reference there is to
its relationship with its trading
partners in the plural did you hear any
any concerns directly from trading
partners other than the us or was it
primarily the US
so I think the overwhelming Focus was
the United States and you know in part
that's because 75 percent of our trade
is with the United States was
overwhelmingly our largest trading
partner also the United States is
overwhelmingly our largest investor
about 50 percent of all foreign
investment in Canada is from the U.S so
it's not surprising that the U.S would
dominate that conversation
that said um just to give an example
some of the key companies that were
directly affected by the blockade of the
Ambassador Bridge were actually not U.S
companies they were Korean and Japanese
companies so both Toyota and Honda
experienced immediate effects in Ontario
as a result of the blockade and the
inability to get part so while we didn't
hear directly from those countries
clearly those major foreign investors
from other countries were directly
affected and so we were concerned about
the perceptions of other trading
partners to in terms of their view of
Canada as a safe place to do business
thank you those are my questions I'll
turn it over to my colleague now
[Music]
good afternoon for the record I'm Dolly
jehabar with the commission so I have
some questions for you Mr Ms Tyson about
the missions and embassies in Ottawa and
so you mentioned earlier the office of
protocol can you just explain
I'm sorry yes uh can you explain in a
bit more detail what the office of
protocol is
sure So within Global Affairs we have an
office of protocol that has a number of
responsibilities one of its
responsibilities is to support both
incoming and outgoing high-level visits
so the office of protocol supports
visits uh in and out going that are
related to the Prime Minister the
governor general and the Ministers of
global Affairs Canada
but it also has a specific
responsibility with respect to the
Diplomatic Corps in Canada so there are
about 8 000 diplomats accredited to
Canada they're across the country but of
course given that Ottawa is the capital
city they are heavily concentrated in
Ottawa
and many of the embassies and consulates
um located across the country would
engage with us there's a whole range of
things that we take care of for them we
take care of their accreditation
we provide advice help with a lot of the
documentation for them and we have as I
mentioned earlier to your colleague a
very specific responsibility uh to the
to the Diplomatic presence here in
Canada under the Vienna convention on
diplomatic relations and that governs
all of our obligations under
international law with respect to
diplomats here in Canada okay I
understand that the office was receiving
some complaints from missions during
this period can can you elaborate on
those that's correct so we have
um a mechanism whereby
embassies or any diplomatic presence or
Diplomat can a large formal complaints
or concerns with the office of protocol
and we have have on record a number of
embassies based in Ottawa raising
concerns about the impact of the Convoy
protests in Ottawa on their ability to
function effectively I should also note
that in addition to that formal Channel
with the office of protocol there are
also informal channels of communication
with our Geographic branches in global
Affairs Canada so we have branches that
are responsible for Europe and the
Middle East for Africa for North America
and for Asia Pacific and so there are
daily conversations between missions and
those parts of the department and we
wouldn't necessarily have formal records
but we do understand that there were
also complaints lodged through those
more informal mechanisms so did they
have any security concerns or what kind
of concerns did they have in particular
uh so we heard a range of concerns a lot
of the concerns were around access
um it was very hard to get in with into
the downtown core with any kind of
vehicle
personal or otherwise there were a lot
of concerns about noise which I think
were quite similar to what you heard
about from Ottawa residents earlier on
in the commission's proceedings also
concerns about fumes and then we of
course were also concerned about the
ability of of staff to access their
offices and also for Consular clients to
access their offices and I believe you
raised these concerns at the dmoc
meetings is that right yes I did
like to pull up a SSM NSC can five
zeros155
and so just for contacts I believe the
office of protocol sent three notices
divisions during this period yes that's
my understanding as well yeah so this is
the third one from February 9th if we
could just look at the part in Red so if
you scroll down a little bit oh it's not
right on this situation okay the the
paragraph started in the rcmb so the
RCMP has advised the office of protocol
that it currently has no specific
concerns for diplomatic missions in
connection with this event from a
protective policing slow down again yeah
excuse me sorry uh has no specific
concerns for diplomatic missions in
connection with this event from a
protective policing concern a
perspective so were you aware of this
assessment from the RCMP
yes so
um maybe a couple of things to clarify
as and the RCMP can probably speak to
this better than I can
um usually the concerns of both
embassies
um and consulates
um and frankly our own protocol people
is around demonstrations that are
focused on a particular Embassy so
you'll you'll see protests because of a
certain country's um policies or
activities and there are demonstrations
like that quite regularly and so we
would count on the rcnp to provide
um protective policing if those
demonstrations were to the point that we
were concerned about the security of
that particular facility what was I
think quite interesting about the the
Convoy protest is they weren't directed
at diplomatic Missions at all in fact
um we we were obviously concerned about
the safety of diplomatic premises but we
we never had any any indication that
embassies or official residences of
ambassadors were the target of any of
the issues I think a lot of our concerns
were more like the concerns that we
heard from regular Ottawa citizens which
was their safety on the street we were
concerned about potential harassment
because I think we had heard of many
cases where that had happened with
public servants with Ottawa residents
and so under international law we have a
particular responsibility to ensure the
safety and security of diplomats and so
was that broader context that we were
concerned about would you say that
Canada was unable to fulfill its
obligations under the convention during
this time
I think it's fair to say that we were
concerned that we would be unable to
fulfill our responsibilities and I think
as the Convoy went on longer and there
were more and more uh stories about
assaults on the street about unlawful
conduct and unwillingness to comply with
injunctions and so on that concern just
continued to rise over time
so I like to switch to a different topic
which is the the invocation of the
emergencies act so when did you become
aware that it would be invoked
um
I became aware of when it would be
invoked
um
I think it was the day of okay so was
gak providing any input on that or
advice to to invoke it that kind of
thing so the input that we provide
provided was through a number of
different channels so it was first of
all through these democ committees
um you know each day we would do a tour
de tablet and provide inputs from
various departments perspectives and
share information so each day I would
provide inputs on what we were hearing
from diplomatic missions what we're
hearing from trading partners from
businesses and so on so that was one
channel we also provided reporting into
the privy Council Office on issues under
Global Affairs Canada's mandate and then
we also provided information where
appropriate to the government operations
center so for instance our
um rapid response mechanism which is
referred to in some of our documents
provided its input through uh the
operations the government Operation
Center so in answer to your question yes
we were providing input in through
various channels that that may have
informed the the decision making since
you mentioned uh RM Canada I actually
had some questions about that okay could
you just uh explain what that is in
general terms sure so RRM um stands for
the rapid response mechanism uh so this
was something that was agreed to at the
G7 leaders meeting in 2018 in Charlevoix
when Canada was the host
um and the Mandate of the RRM was really
to
identify and respond to
threats from foreign State actors
um on G7 democracies and we were
particularly focused on threats oriented
towards Democratic institutions and
processes towards threats towards our
media and our social media and online
environment and then also threats to the
exercise of Human Rights and Freedom so
this was really I want to stress about
foreign State actor threats uh to our
democracy so I understand that ROM
Canada produced several reports during
this period I'd like to pull one up it's
SSM NSC can 40 50169
this is from February 14th
if we look at the the key findings the
first one says RM Canada has not seen
evidence of significant foreign
state-sponsored involvement in the
online information space to date so were
you seeing these reports at the time yes
I was yeah and was this um when they
speak of significant foreign
state-sponsored involvement can you
expand on that I think you've touched on
it already what were they looking for
so because the Mandate of the RRM is to
really focus on foreign state-sponsored
threats to democracy that's really what
the RRM looks like so sorry looks at so
the RRM uses tools that would be
publicly available to do analysis of
social media and its focus is really on
identifying are there foreign State
um actors that are introducing
disinformation are they amplifying
certain messages in order to mislead or
deceive Etc
and were these reports shared with other
departments during this time as well yes
so these were reports were fed into the
government operations center
um and while I didn't share these
reports in their entirety with uh dmoc I
did provide some of the sort of Top Line
messaging from time to time at Dean walk
meetings
so I'd like to return to just another
few questions about the emergencies act
itself and just when we looked at the
session 58 explanation before it talks
about the adverse effects on trade
corridors international border crossings
and Canada's relationship with its
trading partners can you comment on how
the measures were designed to address
those concerns
I wasn't really involved in the design
of the measures so I don't really think
I can speak to that question unless I'm
misunderstanding no that's okay um how
did they affect the concerns I suppose
were they effective in the end these
measures
so
um and again maybe Mr Cole Martin will
have additional points to add but I
would say that the response from many of
our particularly U.S interlocutors was a
sense of relief after those measures had
been invoked the the concerns about
particularly the economic blockades at
border crossings and not just the
Ambassador Bridge but it was Emerson it
was Coots it was the border crossing
near Surrey in BC and then concerns that
some of these would reoccur and so I
think the sense of relief was palpable
amongst many of our interlocutors in the
United States at both the political
level also the the business associations
and amongst unions do you have anything
to add Mr Martin like did you hear from
stakeholders
not so much at that immediate period of
time but subsequently over the next few
weeks even few months
um the same point that my colleague is
raised of that sense of relief and a uh
I think a conviction that Canada was not
prepared to let this happen again to the
extent that they would move to invoke
that type of legislation so that that
messaging was was fairly clear but it
it sort of drifted in over a period of
time it wasn't immediate and did the
measures ultimately resolve the concerns
that missions in Ottawa had as well
yes I mean I think with the
um with following the invocation of the
emergency Act and the enforcement action
that happened the uh Convoy protests
were cleared and missions could go about
their usual business and our concerns
about being able to uphold our
responsibilities under the Vienna
convention World Aid I think I'm just
about out of time so just a general
question is there anything I haven't
raised that you would like to raise for
today
I think maybe one thing I just want to
add with respect to the point about the
RRM
um while we did not see significant
amounts of foreign interference or
foreign State
um interference in the convoys I think
it's fair to say that
um there was a real underlying
environment of disinformation that had
been profoundly exacerbated during the
two years of the covid pandemic and in
fact during the covet period we saw
extensive
information
and data from the analysis that we did
of significant disinformation efforts by
Foreign States so that underlying
disinformation environment was I think a
really important uh factor for us in
looking at and trying to understand what
was happening around the convoys thank
you anything you would like to add Mr
Martin
you know maybe maybe just to emphasize
um the and again I'm speaking
particularly of my territory the uh when
the blockade hit it hit at a really
crucial time both in terms of what was
going on the auto manufacturing sector
um the types of development that's
coming we're going to build a whole new
supply chain in order to have the
electric vehicles come online and
um Canada has the potential to play a
great role in that that was jeopardized
by this blockade
um think we've been able to put most of
it to bed now but it was a high risk
period of time for that to occur
especially coming out of the pandemic
when the manufacturing sector had been
so hard hit
um it was it was just a very difficult
uh
time to be able to convince our U.S
partners that we were serious about
being their partner on an ongoing basis
as we have historically
thank you very much those are my
questions
okay
so can we uh now go on with the
cross-examinations for the Convoy
organizers
you're up first
good evening good evening my name is
Brendan Miller I represent Freedom Corp
which is an interview that represents
the protesters that were in Ottawa on
January and February of 2022.
uh so I take it given your positions uh
with respect uh to International Affairs
and all of that your focus uh in the
protests was more dealing with the
protests that were occurring occurring
at uh
essentially uh border passings Etc uh
with respect to commercial trucks and
vehicles being able to come in and leave
Canada correct
I would say that Global Affairs Canada
was particularly interested in the
border crossings and the economic
blockades that were happening there but
also in the uh Convoy protests here in
Ottawa given the concerns we had with
respect to diplomatic missions in the
downtown core right and I take it uh
that at least from reviewing some of the
records Etc that the concern with the
Diplomatic missions was not that the
protest was interfering with the
missions but that it inconvenienced some
of the diplomats is that fair
uh no I wouldn't agree with that
characterization it wasn't just a matter
of inconvenience
um as I mentioned to commission Council
the government of Canada has an
obligation under the Vienna convention
to ensure the safety and security of uh
of diplomats here in Canada
and to ensure that they are unable to
carry out their functions without undue
uh difficulty so we were concerned about
being able to fulfill that obligation
and I think given the context in the
downtown core the concern was more than
one of just inconvenience right and it's
fair to say that not a single Diplomat
from a foreign state was physically
assaulted by a protester correct
um I am not aware of physical assaults
um but we were always concerned about
that possibility given the reports that
we had heard of quite a number of
physical assaults during that period
well this commission has heard evidence
with respect to physical assaults During
the period of the protest that there is
a total of five charges
in total so that's from the beginning of
the protest and until the end and I
understand you're concerned but you have
no evidence that any Diplomat was
physically assaulted by any of the
protesters in Ottawa is that correct
um that is correct thank you and I also
understand that you have no evidence
that any of the protesters in downtown
Ottawa verbally threatened to harm any
of the diplomats is that correct
that is correct and it was always a
concern that uh that might happen uh and
hence Our concern about uh being able to
live up to our Vienna convention
obligations right and it's not like a
situation for example in 1970 during the
flq crisis where a diplomat uh was
murdered and another one kidnapped where
they actually invoked the war measures
act that wasn't it you were concerned
about maybe someone might threaten a
diplomat we were concerned about being
able to comply with our International
legal obligations under the Vienna
convention correct right okay and uh I
take it uh with respect to the just
turning your mind now to the Border
blockades
um the information that you have you
said there was no actual report done uh
with respect to the losses that were
suffered uh with respect uh to the
blockades causing those losses is that
fair the government has never done a
full tally of what was the economic
ramifications of the blockades is that
fair I never said that I only said that
Global Affairs Canada did not do that
analysis all right and is it fair that
stats Canada has and they concluded that
all it did was inconvenience the
truckers and in fact or the people
crossing the borders and and imports and
they simply had to use other ports
I haven't seen any statscan data what I
would say is that there were multiple
impacts including factories having to
close down
and I think as my colleague and I have
both mentioned there were an enormous
number of concerns about
the economic impacts particularly on the
auto sector
and there were long-term implications
that we were very concerned about about
Canada's reputation
as a trade and investment destination
does the undermining of Canada's
reputation and protests in Canada in
your view is that a
security threat under section two of the
thesis Act
so I'm not an expert on section two of
the thesis act our primary interest from
a global Affairs Canada perspective when
it comes to security is really thinking
about our Economic Security and when you
consider that the international trade
and goods and services is valued at over
60 percent of our GDP we were actually
very concerned about the economic
security of this country right and the
country's reputation right yes okay so
how was the country's reputation when
various ministers and the prime
ministers the Prime Minister announced
that there was foreign funding coming
from the United States and that this was
undermining Canadian democracy and I've
seen in the disclosure in others that
wasn't the United States some of sitting
members of their government including
their Ministries weren't they a little
upset about that when it was accused
that the U.S was financing this protest
weren't they upset I understood the word
um I can't speak to the the views of all
members of the U.S Administration I can
just say that there were a number of
conversations
um that were had by Canadian government
officials including the Prime Minister
where there were actually concerns about
U.S funding through
the uh the platforms that we had
discussed earlier right and you know you
you can agree with me that there's
nothing wrong with a Canadian donating
to an American cause and an American
donating to a Canadian cause with
respect to funding protests or Charities
there's nothing illegal about that is
there I think the concern was that some
of the activities of the protesters were
illegal right and you're saying that was
illegal was the blockade correct yes the
blockade were illegal right and the
being in downtown Ottawa
it wasn't a matter of being in downtown
Ottawa that was illegal per se in fact I
think in this democracy we fiercely
protect the ability to peacefully and
lawfully protest it was the matter of
the illegal aspects that were a concern
so what was the illegal aspect to you of
the protests in in downtown Ottawa can
you tell me what the illegal aspect it
is that you're referring to I think that
on matters of what particular aspects
were illegal it is probably better to
speak to other Witnesses what we have
and I'm still confused so what is your
understanding your personal
understanding of what the illegal
activities in downtown Ottawa were I
think this is probably a question that
is better uh directed to other Witnesses
so you were concerned about Canada's
reputation due to illegal activity in
downtown Ottawa but you don't know what
that activity is is that correct it's
not a matter of not knowing it is a
matter of others being better placed to
speak to this right thank you
okay next the city of Windsor
good evening my name is Jennifer King
I'm legal counsel to the city of Windsor
our questions have already been
canvassed we have no further questions
thank you
okay uh the Democracy fund jccf
good afternoon I'm hatchim cure Council
for the Justice Center for
constitutional freedoms good afternoon
in the interests of time I'm going to
focus my questions on you Ms uh
termersheisen
uh so you said in your testimony in
Chief something to the effect that it's
important that Canada be seen as
welcoming to investment uh would you
agree with that statement yes
and maintaining that reputation involves
being known as the kind of country where
that has conditions that are favorable
to investors that's correct okay so
taking a step back from Canada
specifically uh would you agree that as
a general principle one of the things
that investors look for is stability
yes
uh that includes social stability yes
economic stability yes legal and
political stability yes
uh and that's true because in many
countries there's political instability
that can affect people's legal rights
for example their property rights
correct
um
I'm I'm not sure what you're referring
to but I would say that yes that there
are countries where there is political
or other instability and that makes
Investments more risky
right and uh you know the kind of
situation where the political
instability in a country might for
example affect the the property
interests of an investor would make that
undesirable to the investor right
well I think for instance if you have a
country where you're making a major say
mining investment
um and you
um and you have significant instability
and you maybe can't access that mind
this happens in some countries that
would be an example of the kind of
stability you would be looking for
right and uh would you agree that
investors would be hesitant to invest
somewhere where their property might be
subject to confiscation without judicial
authorization for example
in terms of investors yes I would say so
uh and the same would be true for
seizure or freezing in term without
judicial authorization
for Investments yes
now under the emergency economic
measures the bank accounts of protesters
and donors could be Frozen without prior
judicial authorization don't you think
that that could affect their confidence
in Canada as a place to make their
Investments
I wouldn't say so
um I think that uh
what you had was illegal conduct by
individuals and therefore actions taken
in response to that illegal conduct that
is not a corollary to a law-abiding
investor
but prior to the Declaration of
emergency there wasn't a law that
authorized the freezing of those bank
accounts right
there was illegal conduct at the time
foreign
so the emergency economic measure wasn't
necessary to take that action then
I think others are best placed that is
not a global Affairs Canada area of
expertise nor is it my area of expertise
but don't you think that responding to a
political protest by extrajudicially
preventing people from accessing their
own funds would deter people from
wanting to place their money in the
Canadian Financial system
I think that that is
um
I I couldn't really speak to that but I
think investors would be looking at much
broader considerations in making
decisions to invest in a particular
country
so you don't think that subjecting
property rights and the financial system
really as a whole to rules made without
legislative deliberation or any sort of
judicial pre-authorization system would
concern a potential investor
a very special consideration that to my
knowledge is not applied to investors
now one of the things you stated is that
the emergencies act sent a message to
investors that Canada was doing
something about the protests but that
same message could have been sent by
other federal government action couldn't
it
so
I think that on the emergencies act
um I can't really speak to what other
measures you're referring to I think the
reality is that there were a lot of
concerns particularly on the part of
some of the U.S entities that we spoke
to
that in fact the economic blockades at
border crossings were continuing and
there was a tremendous amount of concern
on the part of U.S
officials businesses unions that there
weren't effective measures being taken
to end those blockades
but successful police enforcement would
have assuaged those concerns wouldn't it
I would simply say that
um it's kind of a counterfactual point
um the reality is that that hadn't been
possible
um so uh certainly in our conversations
with U.S interlocutors
um there there was a sense of relief
once those blockades were ended
well we've heard from police witnesses
that the protests would have been
cleared even had the emergencies act not
been invoked and you have no reason to
believe for the purposes of global
Affairs responsibilities uh that the
emergency act would have been necessary
for other reasons then do you
I can only say that not being an expert
on the emergencies act itself that the
clearance of the blockades was greeted
with relief
right but what I'm asking is that
given that the we've heard from police
who are the experts in policing matters
uh that they've said that they could
respond to the the protests without the
emergencies act for the purposes of
matters directly under the concern of
global Affairs Canada the emergency act
wasn't necessary for something outside
of policing the the protests correct
I've already answered your question okay
no further questions thank you
thank you next is the Ottawa coalition
good evening commissioner or we don't
have any additional questions thank you
Emily tamman for the record
okay next is the opp good evening
commissioner Chris Diana for the opp we
also have no questions thank you
the Windsor Police Service
sorry my video is not starting uh Tom
McRae for the uh
Windsor Police Service we have no
questions thank you
okay
next is the government of Canada
thank you commissioner Mr Tyson and Mr
Cole Martin my name is Brendan van
nianheis and I'm counsel for the
government of Canada
and I just wanted to follow up on a few
of the items you were asked about by my
friends
um first of all Mr says in yours it was
suggested or sorry you suggested that
others were likely to be better placed
than you to answer questions from my
friends for the Convoy organizer group
and the jccf about specific laws being
breached and about whether the
emergencies Act was necessary do you
recall that yes yeah
um was the perspective of a threat to
the reputation of Canada into the
economic security of Canada
that you've spoken about was that
simply gax input into a broader
consideration of that latter question
absolutely Global Affairs Canada has a
certain mandate focused on a number of
issues and there are obviously a large
number of players who fed into decisions
around this matter
I wonder if we could pull up PB dot can
2.4016
um actually sorry we don't need this
reference
Mr Cole Martin I think you'll probably
recall this you you described
your call on February the 11th with
representative Debbie Dingle of
Michigan's 12th District
um and you recall that that was the day
of the Windsor injunction being granted
right that's correct and what I will ask
to call up and we'll come to it in a
moment but I'll call it up now is
pb.can.401802
and just coming back to your
conversation with representative Dingle
uh I believe you said that it was
reassuring to her that either that this
injunction was being pursued and would
soon be decided or possibly that it had
already been granted by the time that
you spoke that's correct awesome
and um
why was that reassuring to her
again going back to the comments she had
made the night before and as it happens
she was obviously uh concerned about the
relationship
um and the long-term impact it would
have the blockade would have on that
relationship
um
and at that point in time it was not at
all clear that it was going to be
resolved quickly so when I was speaking
to her the following day I was able to
give her assurances in fact it was going
to be resolved quickly at that border
crossing
and I think it was also on the 11th and
you you're more specifically recalled
when you testified earlier about it that
the injunction had been granted in
Windsor by this time when you had a call
with the representatives of the oesa and
m-e-m-a do you recall that that's
correct those are significant
manufacturers uh um uh trade
organizations they are and they have a
long history of working very closely
with uh with companies on the Canadian
side
and were were they too relieved that the
injunction had been granted in Windsor
for the same reasons as as
representative Dingle they were but they
were also concerned about
um reoccurrences uh which was when the
emergency act issue got raised by uh by
Ms Freeman
could we go then to that um uh
multimedia file at pbkan 1802 at the 222
Mark please
reinforce tighter restrictions on access
to the site yet protesters were freely
allowed to bring gasoline and other fuel
back to their vehicles where they've
been living and sleeping what's wrong
with fueling up the vehicle police told
us they can't stop the resupply effort
so will those occupying the bridge
follow a court order to leave will they
follow an injunction that is illegal
probably not I'm walking on the street I
asked one protester whether an
injunction would be followed but imagine
it's like in any scenario there might be
someone who says I don't like that
or someone who shakes their fists the
sky uh
it doesn't mean violence and a question
also likely being asked by police did
the police have anything to worry about
from the perspective of push back fight
back guns resistance the only thing the
police have to worry about is God's
judgment
on their actions late this afternoon the
city of Windsor and the automakers got
their wish they got that court
injunction requiring the protesters to
leave tonight we are now into
did you hear the gentleman Express the
prediction or opinion that the
protesters at the window Windsor
blockade would not in fact obey the
injunction granted by Justice morowitz I
did
and was that the case sir did the did
the protesters there at the Windsor
blockade um obey the injunction as of
February the 11th
well certainly in you know we heard a
lot of this evidence last week from both
the opp and the Windsor Police Services
that it took another 24 hours before it
really began to permeate and certainly
by the end of the day of the 48 Hours uh
it was it was over
um so ultimately it did
um the final group that was there was
very small uh I think there were 30 40
50 people maybe as opposed to the
hundreds that have been there before but
by the end of the day on the Sunday the
13th there were very few people left so
I think both the the injunction and the
emergency uh act invocation by The
Province had its desired effect
now when you when you speak of the
emergency actor speaking of um the
federal elect or the provincial the
provincial act I see it was invoked on
the uh on the Friday afternoon uh
shortly after the injunction was granted
that that's that I believe that's what
the evidence shows that that was invoked
as well on the 11th that's correct I
think at 9 30 in the morning
um but uh what am I am mistaken sir that
the public order operation actually
wasn't able to commence until the 12th
and it took till still took still 24
hours from there we did not know what
the uh you know what the actual
implementation of the uh of the new
rules under the provincial emergency act
would be until the following day were
you aware of concerns from your American
counterparts at all with respect to um a
continued concern such as the one
expressed by the oesa and Mema about
recurrence
I think the the one I can probably think
of would be the chief legal counsel for
the governor of Michigan you and I were
having regular conversations
um on this and a number of other issues
but
um he certainly raised it uh about you
know the way are we able to give them
assurances that this was the end the
actual end of it
um Miss Thomas Eisen you were asked and
you spoke of what you called
International copycat protests from time
to time do you recall them those
questions yes
and um I'd like if we could take the
same file uh PB channel four zeros 1802
and play from the 14 second Mark to 155.
so what does that tell you
Echoes of Canadian protesters honking is
now being heard in a growing number of
countries like France where the maple
leaf was spotted Wednesday waived by
demonstrators who are against covet
restrictions all this coming on the same
day as the who warns the pandemic is not
over yet
[Music]
motorcycles and cars and a bicycle Too
part of this Convoy in southern France
[Applause]
restrictions as they gathered in nice
carrying Canada Flags
stations in Ottawa
Ottawa there are plans to bring this
rally to Paris before heading to the
European Union's headquarters in
Brussels
foreign
's Capital where protests inspired by
Canadian unrest stretched into another
day only now with a heavier police
presence outside the country's
Parliament
some arrests here demonstrators say
they're planning to camp out until kobit
measures are lifted New Zealand's prime
minister Jacinda ardern said Tuesday the
protesters don't represent the majority
and this March against vaccine mandates
held Monday in New York the red and
white once again on display there are
reports of a larger truck Convoy in the
works in the U.S similar to what's ruled
out in Canada that could make its way to
Washington DC it's called the free
thank you um uh Mr President are those
some examples of the uh sorts of um
copycats you had in mind yes they are
okay and you you noted that the each
appeared as I sought to illustrate the
use of the Canadian flag in the protests
right yes
um
I believe you said that the Canadian
brand internationally was thereby being
associated with Defiance of the rule of
law
yes
could you tell me what does global
Affairs Canada aside from the damage
that we've seen to the brand as you
described it earlier but does global
Affairs Canada have a sense or an
assessment about the strength of the
Canadian brand for
um being a peaceful and lawful Society
I think our brand for that is very
strong and we'd like to keep it that way
is it a concern to Global Affairs Canada
the effect that this has on the brand
strength not only of Canada as a lawful
Society but uh on the effectiveness of
democracy more broadly
yes I think that's true
is that a a sort of a branding issue
that Global Affairs
assesses as being under deliberate
attack by foreign foreign States
I mean I think what we've seen in the
data shows it that um that democracy
worldwide is in a period of retreat
um we're seeing a rising number of
authoritarian governments uh taking the
place of democratic governments or
democratic governments becoming less
Democratic so it's always something that
that we keep a close eye on and at
Global Affairs Canada we do have a
number of programs where we actually
support other countries ensuring up
their own democracies so
um I think we're we're very Vigilant
about our own
do you have a sense of what the intended
audience are for you know attacks on
brand reputation like that that affect
um Democratic countries
I think that
um certainly there are some uh foreign
State actors that would be quite Keen to
see
um the democracies
um be under attack and be under threat
so it's something that we're vigilant
for is that part of why RRM was
established at the G7 absolutely
I wonder if we could go briefly on our
the RM point to ask you a few questions
from a recent report issued it's
pb.can.401836
and if we go to page five once it's up
if you go down the middle of the page
um and just that paragraph that starts
this information thrived in the context
of covid-19
um and I'll highlight
hear the
uh
what the report describes as a fertile
ground for Austell State actors to
manipulate the information environment
you see that yes I do and is is that
something that you saw reflected in the
events of the Convoy
I mean I think this is what I was trying
to refer to earlier
um where you know the Convoy
um from the RRM perspective
um and I think from the perspective of
many who looked at this did not happen
in a vacuum there was a long period
particularly during the pandemic
um where we saw an enormous amount of
manipulation of the information
environment and what you saw is
um foreign State actors using
disinformation or manipulating
information to
undermine the reputation of Democratic
states and their approach to dealing
with covid to undermine
um confidence in vaccines particularly
vaccines produced by Western countries
so there was a whole series of very
deliberate efforts that we could track
through our social media analysis
showing
um frankly quite successful efforts by
some key foreign State actors to sew I
think a real sense of mistrust in
democratic governments and their
approach to dealing with the pandemic
can we just move to page nine for a
moment
um just looking under the first adding
their implications if you just take a
look at that first paragraph it
indicates that these Trends it
demonstrate that foreign sponsored
disinformation online and offline just
one tool in the broader arsenal of
hostile State activity
is increasingly transnational
multi-dimensional and cross-platform and
that in this context it's difficult to
distinguish between foreign and domestic
actors you see that yes I do and in the
next paragraph it indicates that
attribution is increasingly difficult to
achieve with a high degree of certainty
yes and finally that measuring the real
or potential impact of disinformation is
challenging that's right are those fair
fair assessments at this point in time
yes I mean this is very much what
um the uh the RRM is finding and I
should note that this report that you've
put put up on the screen is a report
that was done collectively by all of the
members of the g7rrm so this is an
analysis that is shared across the G7
and it also includes input from the
European Union and other partners so
this is not just a Canadian RRM
perspective is RM quite a young
organization or collaboration of
organizations a ticket it is a young
collaboration I mean the the G7 version
of the RRM was stood up in 2018 so it's
been around for about four years and
this annual report that you're referring
to is the first annual report that the
RRM G7 group as a whole has done
um so it's a very it's a very important
analysis from our perspective
of the of the disinformation environment
that we see around us
and has that disinformation environment
as you see it and it led to the decision
by the G7 collectively to establish this
network
um called RRM
um that's been going on for a lot longer
than since 2018 I take it near
assessment
absolutely I mean I think there's you
know disinformation is a is a
long-standing tool
um of governments um well before the
social media age I think social media
has
um created an entirely new tool
um and so the RRM Canada is specifically
focused on that social media environment
and understanding it and understanding
how disinformation plays in that
environment and what its impact is on
Democratic states like Canada okay so is
it fair to conclude that the RRM
analyzes if we see RRM say it hasn't
seen evidence of significant foreign
State involvement relative to the Convoy
that isn't to suggest that there's a
complete lack of connection between the
disinformation environment in the
broader sense and those events is that
fair
yeah I mean some some analysts have
suggested that
um there really wasn't much of a need
for foreign State actors to
um engage significantly in the Convoy
um information environment because there
was already such a high level of
disinformation surrounding it
what about you've focused on the online
environment but do these um as at least
AS Global Affairs assesses it do these
operations objectives whatever you want
to call them on behalf of malign actors
in the information space include the
discrediting of media and the
reliability of the traditional media in
reporting the truth absolutely
could we go to pb.can.401800
and commissioner I'm just going to ask
to play a short clip and I'll have one
question and that will be my time if
that's acceptable
okay
when this is called up would you play
from 555 forward please the protest now
over code restrictions in Canada
Goose here in Canada have brought part
of the country's capital to a standstill
right outside the national Parliament I
was uh hired on at a job not too long
ago for a Transport company out of
Whitby Ontario and I was let go due to
not willing to get the vaccines for my
job and I mean that's not right for
companies to be able to decide that and
take away our right to earn money and
support our livelihood and for you
always important for you to be here
today well because news sorry because
like you're don't talk to them this is
the fake news but despite the fact that
these people may be part of a minority
in Canada they are receiving a lot of
support from conservatives and other
right-wing figures in the United States
we are now aware of a significant
element from the United States that have
been involved in the funding the
organizing and the demonstrating the
Canadian truckers are Heroes they are
Patriots and they are Marching for your
freedom and for my freedom this is very
much a 21st century protest playing out
as much on the internet as it is on the
streets viral memes and sometimes false
and highly offensive historical
comparisons that circulate online are
being repeated verbatim here like this
and because you're not vaccinated have
you is there business is there stuff you
can't do in Canada now yeah like I'm
like well basically if you want to
compare Canada uh to anything it's like
Hitler Germany and we're like the Jews
eh one of the goals is to Simply is to
get a group of people you can get
everybody angry with and this case is
the backs unvaccinated there's a lot of
people here streaming live online I'm
just gonna follow you guys make sure you
tell the truth okay
documenting every moment on social media
you take those
carotesters please have begun
confiscating gas canisters resulting in
encounters like this that clock up
thousands of views online my name is Jim
Kerr and I give a [ __ ] about cleaners
how do you feel
hi my name is Jim Kerr and I care about
human beings especially ones who are
trying to keep themselves warms in a
truck while fighting for the freedoms of
Canadians how you feel
the main problem I have is all the
censorship that's going on that's that's
the main problem that I have there's
censorship everywhere yeah people's
accounts get taken down even Facebook if
you don't say the right thing even this
Convoy a lot of groups started and
people are even live streaming and also
I heard yesterday in the restaurant my
feed was cut my feed was cut Facebook
shut down some groups on its platform
supporting the truckers after the online
outlet grid news found that they were
being administered by a hacked account
that had belonged to a woman in Missouri
so whoever was really running the groups
wanted to hide their identity and
GoFundMe shut down a fundraiser for the
truckers after police told him the
protests had become an occupation but
organizers here have still been able to
raise millions of dollars true and
alternative service a self-described
Christian fundraising platform
organizers say the money will help keep
the truckers on the streets
these are 3C and my previous
we want those Great Canadian truckers to
know that we are with them all the way
Trump indicating he is supportive of
truckers descending on Washington D.C
other American right wing figures
goading their audiences to act the
question is how long before protests
like this
come here will we need our own trucker
rally to end all of this Insanity once
and for all
what is the main goal the main objective
of of the truckers there freedom
uh misthermicizing to these interactions
uh what we saw on the screen between the
CNN reporter Mr Sullivan and Convoy
protesters in Ottawa illustrate the
concerns that led to the establishment
of RRM by the G7
well I think when the RRM was
established of course it was well before
these um these protests took place but I
think the RRM was broadly
set up to ensure that we were Vigilant
about
um any kind of foreign interference in
our democracies
thank you those are my questions
any uh re-examination
no re-examination
okay well thank you for coming uh and
testifying and we appreciate uh you
taking the time to do so out of your
schedules and you're now free to go
thank you
sir before we uh end for the day I just
wanted to raise a point if I may you
absolutely may but maybe do we need the
the wit that can the witnesses leave no
we do not need the witnesses so you're
afraid to go and
we'll deal with the I can deal with the
issue
okay yes so serve for the record Brennan
Miller appearance Council for Freedom
Corp uh sir there's been an issue with
respect to this closure from the
Department of Justice for some time I
just wanted to point out some things
uh
as per relativity I've been told how to
organize it with respect to uploads and
when they were uploaded I can advise the
commission that since November 6th uh
the Department of Justice has dumped in
about
1299 new records and over the weekend
alone
um since we adjourned 409
. some of these documents are
extraordinarily relevant including
entire team message chats with Brenda
lucky and the RCMP during the IRG
meetings
commenting on what's going on they're
not even in the commissions list of
documents for tomorrow because they
probably don't know about them they're
not labeled I found them by accident
there is an issue at this juncture in my
submission with a dump truck approach in
my submission on behalf of the doj
in order to provide a disclosure late
that is relevant material should have
been provided quite some time ago and
it's not even properly labeled for
example all of those there's teams
meetings with all the executive of the
RCMP about what's happening it's very
interesting I'm just finding it now but
nobody seems to know about it because of
late disclosure and because it's not
properly labeled and because it's coming
in in mass quantities
so I sir I wanted to raise that with you
I I would submit that this commission
has jurisdiction
to compel the doj to outline and
properly label materials and provide
them properly outline what they are and
not simply name them random letters and
numbers so that people don't see them I
only spotted them today a couple hours
ago because I got lucky
okay
it's a rather non-specific complaint and
I don't take it my friend is seeking
relief I can assure you commissioner
that in a large number of people are
working incredible hours and have been
doing so for many months to assemble
documents the government of Canada is a
large institution with many document
sources and the items that are of keen
relevance
um accordingly to a great deal of time
to identify a process some code if
there's a specific complaint about a
specific item that I can be of
assistance in addressing I think would
be more efficient to address that
offline with my friend in terms of the
concern or through commission Council
would be the appropriate route but in
the absence of a specific request or a
specific complaint so I I don't think
there's more I can say sitting here now
and not some prepared to speak to the
issue at the moment in in more
particularity sir I'm simply asking if
the commission can direct the doj to
properly label uh what the items are in
relativity
who the parties are discussing matters
in there with the proper date
as opposed to just it being dumped in
with random numbers and then
you know we're dealing with literally
1299 documents records not Pages records
that have been dumped in since November
6th and we're all here
all day and then trying to find this
stuff it's like trying to find a needle
in a haystack and it's it's not
something for example in a civil case we
call them affidavits of Records back
home I believe in Ontario they're called
a
statement of Records I apologize I'm not
from here but you're required to label
the date the actual record and et cetera
and that's how relativity's set up but
I'm finding these extraordinarily
compelling documents that not even the
commission has in their list of
documents for tomorrow and we're talking
about text messages and an iMessage
system of sorts between commissioner
lucky and all the executive of the RCMP
during the IRG meetings and other things
about what's going to be done
and they're not labeled and I found them
by by luck and in my submission
that's just not appropriate these things
need to be labeled they need to actually
say what they are they can't just be
dumped into this system last minute in
the hopes that one of us luckily finds
them I don't know what else is in there
in those 12 1999 documents I'm trying to
get through them
but it's impossible to assess it by just
looking at the labels Etc in relativity
when they're not actually labeled at all
as to what they are
so if I understand correctly you're if
you're you'd like
to have some sort of a an index or some
sort of an indication of what the
documents are
okay at this stage I'm I'm not in a
position to to
respond uh I don't know if uh the
government of Canada can respond but
it's uh
maybe you can provide information I
think what I can say is if it's a
complaint about the adequacy of the
coding we are all in the council table
here in the same boat if the commission
Council has a concern about the adequacy
of the coding we'll be happy to do our
best to remedy that obviously these
things take time and if they take time
then that slows the process of getting
things into the database which is the
whole purpose of the inquiry so that
they they can be put into the public
record as uh as appropriate
Mr I think this is a concern that's
probably best addressed offline
okay well I think at this stage uh
certainly as I did at the outset uh the
council are encouraged to raise issues
with commission Council
as soon as they arise and to the degree
possible they can be addressed that way
if they can't be addressed and
some relief is necessary then you bring
it to me
um I think your concern has been raised
I think commission Council will
look into it I do want to cycle back
and point out that
I have acknowledged and continue to
acknowledge that it is challenging for
Council
and certainly for
counsel for the government of Canada but
also Council
for all the parties and and I think
to the degree
that you have frustration I understand
it and I think that at one level it is
totally understandable because of the
way
uh the compressed timeline that the
commission has to operate under
um so it if it is possible to provide
some relief in the way you describe I
think it is highly desirable but not if
it's going to mean that we won't get
access to documents and
and I know that's been a concern of mine
to make sure the record is as complete
as possible if there is a real un
unfairness that's something
I will certainly entertain because
ultimately the objective of this
commission is to
share and as open
in the context of the constraints we're
operating under
so I'd encourage you to speak to to
commission Council if there's some way
to
alleviate because I know
the government of Canada obviously is a
very significant
a player in this as are there Witnesses
so I want to be sure we do what we can
to ensure I bet the best possible
analysis of their documents and
listening to their witness so with that
I apologize for being a little preachy
but but I do I do understand and we'll
see what we can do
so we'll adjourn until 9 30 uh and uh
again I expect it'll be a similar day
tomorrow and probably similar days this
week that will be fairly long
the commission is a general